Joe Rogan podcast check it out The Joe
Rogan Experience Train by day Joe Rogan
podcast by night all
[Music]
day hello Joe how are you my friend I'm
great man I'm psyched to be here cheers
sir cheers brother har Krishna har
Krishna great to see
you
always that's good my friend it's a
strange times and uh we're both
departing this land I know for greener
Fosters I keep
thinking back to when we first became
friends in the strange
path since from there to
here and all our predictions and all the
things that we we never would have
imagined this you know specifically like
that there would be this [__] Global
pandemic that we would suddenly be like
some kind of like Refugee is way too
dramatic a word for it but suddenly just
part of this diaspora of comedians
pouring out of La like and not just
comedians but just people leave leaving
man well um I talked to Joey today from
New Jersey called you know I called him
he's in New Jersey and it was just such
so strange I'm like you're in Jersey
he's like that's right [__] yeah
you know he's he's all happy in Jersey
you know he was the last like you
leaving was intense but I was still like
you know maybe we'll stick around and
see what happens and then like I'd been
getting all these you know the problem
with me is like I get weird Vibes all
the time and like the last I was on here
I legitimately thought a meteor was
going to hit the earth I I really
thought that so I I work very hard on
not listening to that part of me most of
the time but I was getting this real
weird vibe from LA and I'm like come on
man you're just like superstitious it's
it's probably nothing and then then my
wife would say like I'm getting a really
weird vibe like we maybe maybe I don't
know if we should stay here renting if
we stay in the place and I didn't want
to tell her oh I've been getting a weird
vibe too cuz I didn't want to amplify
whatever that was and then I got on the
phone with Diaz and he's like yeah I'm
leaving getting the [__] out of here and
that was it Diaz was telling me Burbank
was sketchy where he lives in Burbank CU
my neighborhood turned the [__] like
instantly dude it's like yeah it's it's
it's not and it's not just any one thing
you know it's like not just like some of
the stuff I get stuff had to get shut
down and because stuff was shut down it
got a little more weathered than
usual and it's like the you know the
homeless encampments I was an Echo Park
man and like I really feel like you know
like the red State people one of the
things they love to tweet is like don't
bring your liberal [__] here right
and right well this that's where I'm
eating [__] a little bit because you
know I am I do still believe that we
need to uh decriminalize drugs that the
the drug policy's [__] the way we're
handling it's all wrong
but they there used to be a way that
they could get people who are like
camping out on the streets and a lot of
the times that was possession of like
illegal drugs and because that that
stuff got removed uh suddenly you were
witnessing like holy [__] man there's
people who are making like
real
like ra a rational decision from the
perspective of a heroin addict which is
they love heroin so much you know that
Doug Stan hope joke some things are
better than life like they love heroin
so much they're addicted to it they love
it and the shelters that are apparently
available won't let them do drugs in the
shelters they want you to kick it yeah
and so that's ridiculous but now I could
be wrong about that but that is what
I've heard as one of the reasons these
people are staying out in the street
is not cuz they don't want to be in a
shelter it's because they don't want to
be prevented from getting hot and so
this has produced this like situation in
a lot of the big cities which is we're
seeing like massive tent cities and by
the way the Tent City thing
aesthetically it's not uh it's not the
best look but the stuff that I began to
experienc in Echo Park man I took I I
took my kid to the playground right and
there's like a dude that looks like he
emerged from a time portal from an
apocalypse you know what I mean I'm not
talking about like you know
run-of-the-mill like somebody who's a
junkie who's like I'm talking like
covered in like soot like pure dilated
eyes not wearing like you
know the disheveled clothes you might
expect from someone who's been addicted
to heroin for a long time but like
wearing like like he broke into wherever
the costumes from Mad Max were like some
kind of weird leather vest thing and
like like creepy [__] cut off shorts
and he had a a machete oh Jesus and he's
throwing it into the ground of the
playground and pulling it out like he's
practicing throwing a machete I'm with
my [__] toddler man and you know it's
like and so obviously we didn't go to
the playground but that was you know my
you know it was not uncommon in that
area to see completely naked people just
not that that's bad but not naked like
the way covered in dirt wandering
aimlessly you do even worse than
wandering aimlessly wandering with what
seems to be a purpose in their eyes some
of them seeming like they're late where
the [__] are you going naked that you're
laid
for like are you being summoned like
that was that was but that wasn't just
it man you know it's a lot of other
things too and it all just started
piling on top of dude I don't think this
is sustainable living in giant groups of
people I think it's when it's when it
works great it was wonderful when when
La was was working well it was fantastic
when The Comedy Store was packed and
restaurants were doing well and the
economy was doing well and the crime
wasn't high it's great but when things
go bad there's no sense of community so
then there's a sense of like people
capitalizing on other people who either
own stores or who aren't home or
whatever people who are Des there's to
there's too many people yeah if you're
in a community that's a small town and
something goes wrong you can kind of
bunch up together and help each other
yeah cuz you feel like you need each
other and you feel like you're you're a
part of something people don't feel like
they're a part of something here they're
all transient everybody's moved here
from someone else from somewhere else
everybody thinks they can go somewhere
else and they can and they probably will
I mean I you know we all came from
different you were North Carolina I came
from uh New York at the time we all
everybody who comes to LA in Show
Business God what are the percentage of
like how many do we know that are just
straight la like Christina pizitz she's
straight La who else um Sebastian came
from Chicago Theo came from Nashville
did Nashville is that he came from noou
no Louisiana that's right I mean Joey
obviously Jersey yeah well gywn which is
something I've always loved about it
I've loved that element of like just
this wild vortex
artist and narcissists and people who
just Gane and like it's a lot of Sparks
Fly in in that kind of insane cauldron
of identity all that stuff is super cool
it's it's beautiful that's one of the
things I loved about is like the place
we all know this is the place is a place
where you make illusion that was the
idea you make things that aren't real
seem real and people like to watch that
that's the whole TV movie industry the
whole place is based on it cre creting
an identity that you like somehow
monetize or a studio makes monetizes
your identity or something it was
something magical and beautiful in all
of that but not it seems like there's a
real emperor where's no clo thing
happening right now not just in LA and
but I feel bad talking [__] about La cuz
man she's been so good to both of us I
this city is like I will always love
this place it's not the problem is not
the city this is the this I've been
thinking about this a lot lately and
here's an issue um I am Progressive on
just about every issue across the board
yeah uh gay rights civil rights women's
rights whatever women's right to choose
fill in the blank Pro Medicaid Pro
Universal basic in um um Pro so many
things but there's a thing that happens
in large cities where large cities are
always blue and I'm trying to figure
this out cuz like New York is and I used
to think it's oh it's because they're
educated you know and educated people
are more likely to be compassionate and
compassionate people more likely to be
Democrats but there's a balance that has
to be achieved and when the [__] hits
the fan you need Law and Order and I
think that some people who are Democrats
who are pro Progressive people they
don't understand that aspect of human
nature or they want to deny that aspect
of human nature like when the mayor of
Seattle was dealing with that whole six
area lock down little small little
country that they had put up barriers
and [__] and and like literally were had
armed guards there that uh what was it
called again Chop Chop or Chaz right the
the mayor said maybe this is our Summer
of Love Like no it's not Summer of Love
some people took over other people's
businesses with Force like just because
they think the way you think or they
subscribe to Liberal ideas like you like
you're a liberal too so the this is like
your gang of thugs that you have to
support when they take over other
people's businesses no we have to be
able to call out everybody and just
because somebody is on your side you
can't let them take over city blocks and
just Institute their own government and
then say it's the summer of love this is
crazy talk and this is how this is gets
get cities destroyed and this is what
gets the police defunded and this what
what gets people saying crazy things
like we we need to disband release
everyone from prison and no more prisons
and no more laws and no more police and
like no no the way things go well is you
have to be safe the only way you're safe
is if you have a strong military and a
strong police force and there's
something about liberals that don't want
to believe that they see the bad cops
they see these videos and we all agree
we got to get rid of bad cops they got
to reform the police they have to but
those are not all the cops that's crazy
you just only see the bad no one's no
one's filming excellent interactions
with friendly cops and compliant uh
people that's not you're filming not
going to get a lot
of but that's the majority of these
interactions but we have this distorted
perception based on what we're exposed
to which is viral videos of cops being
[__] cuz there are cops that are [__]
because there's people that are [__]
and there's who knows how many [__]
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
cops there are the odds that they're not
hundreds and thousands of [__] is is
outrageous well you know what I've been
doing with this whole [__] thing man
uh because if I get because because you
know me the way my mind goes is not
going to be like red State Consciousness
when it comes to that [__] cuz when I
saw that autonomous Zone pop up I'm like
let's do it baby spread it out come on
but what did you think would be good
what could good could have come of that
well I mean the history of America is is
is is this in beautiful yet somewhat
like there's a there's a Mania a utopian
Mania in the heart of I think the
American Spirit which is like Americans
identify with this it's you know and
George Carin did a great job of desica
it by saying it's called The American
Dream because you got to be asleep to
believe it I love that joke but I love
the American dream and the what's so
beautiful about it is it's this idea of
like I think together we can do
something new that's going to be better
than anything that happened before and
from that Spirit you get all great
Innovation that goes across all
political ideologies right so to me you
know and they always call it I've always
loved that they call it the American
experiment [__] love that man cuz
it's an experiment it's like let's see
what we could do here together and for
an experiment to work we need to be able
to look at what didn't work in the
experiment and improve upon it now that
being said it's like for me I've been
trying to like pull myself out of the
even though I I identify as a
progressive I'm going to vote Democrat
I'm that's just what I'm going to do but
that being said I try to pull myself out
of that cuz I don't want to be cubby
hold man and I have a lot of friends who
are like hardcore conservatives and I
know that there is this idea and I think
a lot of the the idea gets perpetrated
by people who are into tribalism blue
red and so the the blue people they
propagate a conceptualization of the red
people which is kind of what you said
that well they're not compassionate yeah
it's like shut the [__] up ridiculous
get the [__] out of here these are some
of the most compassionate people I've
ever met in my [__] life they would
die for people that they've never met
they do you think a big problem is the
figurehead right now the Republican
party is Trump and Trump is such a
polarized figure and he doesn't seem to
have much empathy if if any seem you
know I mean that's it's you don't know
who he is really because you don't talk
to him privately but his public Persona
is that of a winner who doesn't give a
[__] and you're fired I mean that's
that's a non-empathetic perspective and
we ass associate people who support him
with also lacking empathy then you add
into it children in cages at at the
border and you see those videos you know
what bothered me more than anything
about the kids in cages there was one
video that really bothered me where Mike
Pence went to visit like he's on the
ground like next to the cages see if you
can find that Mike Pence visiting the
the Border cages now apparently these
cages had been put up through Obama and
that's what's interesting about this
whole border wall and Border discussion
and immigration discussion cuz Obama
particularly when he was running for
president he was very tough on illegal
immigration I mean he uh he said a lot
of the same things that Trump said if
you listen to the speeches that Obama
said people believed him and agreed with
him because it wasn't a republican
talking point it was just a safety
talking point and he was also a way that
he could get people that were more like
more concerned about the problem with
illegal immigration or more you know he
could he could tie that up with just
saying listen we have to follow the rule
of law and you know they they had the
these talks and they built these these
cages they did that during the Obama
Administration right uh yeah see if you
can so here here's this so sir these
These are the guys that fled from Mexico
and who knows where else and came
through the Mexican border and then
Pence is standing there in front of
these guys so like imagine you're a dude
you live in you know Ecuador and you
make your way up through Mexico because
you have a [__] dream like America is
the land where people can make it this
is this guy who fights in the UFC his
name is Marlon Vera and uh he's a bad
[__] and he just won this
weekend and he's I believe he's from
Ecuador right that's Marlon's yes and he
um talked about it in his his victory
speech he was talking about you know how
hey man you know you can you can
actually do it he came over here he was
talking about in the countdown show too
he came over here he lived a year
without his family just building up
money fighting to try to get money to
bring his family over and then he
brought his family over and then as time
has gone on he keeps winning he's on
like a seven fight win streak and now
he's like a top 10 contender in the UFC
and he could have been one of those
dudes that's right see this this this is
not these are just people that are in a
[__] terrible place and they're
trying to get out putting them in cages
like it just it's a bad look and it's an
even worse imagine you're that guy who
comes over from Ecuador and you're in
this cage and you see Pence he could
touch him you could touch him if that
cage was in there you could reach over
and touch him on the shoulder right
there the [__] guy who's second in
line to the the the most powerful Army
the world has ever known the the Trump's
the commander-in-chief that's number two
yeah and he's right there in front of a
cage and he doesn't seem to care like
play this it's weird and I don't know
how I want him to to look but he's not
like looking at the people he's kind of
like looking away he's kind of like
ignoring the people I mean I don't know
what you're supposed to do are you
supposed to look at them would that
would it fill you with sorrow and
despair would you not be able to uh
rationalize and disconnect yourself from
the humans that are suffering when you
think about all of us were basically the
products of a [__] enormous chain of
events not one thing but look at they
they have foil blankets man I mean this
is crazy [__] they're stacked in there
stacked on top of each other wearing
foil blankets yeah it's terrible that
and it's look at that guys think about
kids yes he's got a family back home no
no his kids got separated from him yeah
that too that's what he's thinking about
and you know the and again man it's like
I keep trying to uh get out of the like
I I keep trying to get out because I I
this is what I've realized because I
love flipping through I go from I will
jump back and forth from like Fox News
to CNN MSNBC I'll check out some Tucker
Carlson blast over to Rachel mat find
these like like M Polar Opposites and
what I feel like what's happening just
as a result of the entertainment that is
news is that we're getting a very non-
nuanced uh we're being told what we are
basically do you listen to the or watch
the hill no you should watch Rising the
hill it's uh Crystal and Sager and Sager
is a Republican and Crystal is a
Democrat and but both of them super
smart and really rational and they're
honest they're honest and they they're
nonpartisan and they break things down
based on their honest interpretation of
what's going on and it's so refreshing
these two right here crystal ball and
Sager and Getty they are [__]
fantastic and they I love the fact that
they're friends yet she's left he's
right it's not [__] they're not
frauds you think her real name is
Crystal Ball um if I my last name is
ball I'd name my daughter Crystal it's
dope come on you would not I call her
magic crystal
ball like I don't know man well cuz then
every cuz you do that and you're gonna
like I didn't even notice it until now
because I'm not neophobic I'm not name
my name is duning I am how do you think
I I I just I'm sensitive to names like
that CU if their real name is Crystal
Ball be a third grader named crystal
ball have fun well third grader you
might be able to get away with it but
10th grade you're going to get tortured
by the time girls reach 15 he crystal
balls you know it's like a never ending
you know anyway what I'm that to me it's
like the the propaganda it's propaganda
and uh the the reality of it is like I I
I'm trying to figure out what do we all
have in common it sounds like a Cheesy
thing and what we all have in common is
we want to be happy yeah when I talk to
my my my liberal friends they want to be
happy when I talk to my conservative
friends they want to Bey happy and then
you add to it now this is where [__]
gets weird a lot of people want to be a
hero and why wouldn't you a lot of
people want to help other people they
have a service mentality they would they
want to die for something good A lot of
people really do want to help and then
that's to me where the problem start is
because that's being subverted and the
way it's being subverted is you know
what sucks man when you're around
somebody who's telling you how you feel
yeah have you ever had that happen where
you're around someone they're like why
are you unhappy today and you're not
unhappy but if you're not careful you'll
be like maybe I'm unhappy and then you
then you become the unhappy thing and
they've like sucked you into a thing
you're not and so for me this is the
danger of the news is they kind of tell
us how we are how we feel they first of
all this ridiculous red blue [__]
it's like stop I mean every single
person I've ever met would I I don't
think I've ever met anybody who wouldn't
try to help someone who is drowning I
think most people I meet would are like
that and I think that transcends
politics but somehow they got got us
thinking we're all different and
separate and then on top of it the thing
that really bothers me and annoys me
obviously man I'm no [__] Trump fan
that guy's a lunatic and he's driving
people crazy but what bothers me he is
it's like can you pass that lder you're
right no for sure he's driving people
nuts and and it's just the way you said
it and and and and and what what bothers
me is that the response from like really
intelligent people who consider
themselves uh liberals is they're
shaming these people
they're shaming them they're saying oh
they're idiots they're rednecks they're
dumb they're peasants the stupid
peasants how could you like them it's
like how they liked this guy because
they thought that he was going to help
their families they were [__] they
were not doing great economically he
they bought into a thing and they
invested themselves in it and if they
are starting to like it's Dawning on
them that they succumb to another
American tradition which is the con
artist this is an American tradition
it's American
artist and it's American to get sucked
in by one happens to the best of us it's
happened to me at a Grateful Dead
concert we wanted to buy 100 hits of
[__] acid this son of a [__] got us
a sheet of acid convinced us to try to
sell it to make more money to get more
acid we left there with one mushroom
stem on the way back to Hendersonville
I've been conned I know what it's like
it's a very American thing but it's like
so there was no asset at all dude he's
no he we got we took our money to buy
acid and then he's like we could sell
this acid and buy more acid and then you
know we're like yeah let's do it and
then he sold the acid I guess and then
we were going to buy more the point is
like he started a business what he my
friend almost gave him his [__] car
like this was a very charismatic hippie
he was like looked exactly the way he'd
expect him a [__] hippie bandana big
hippie beard some people are good at
that and it's weird and they do weird
things like they talk a little too close
to you to make you uncomfortable yeah
they use uh what's it neurolinguistic
programming they like they like they
just get you and they know how to talk
you you know when I used to work at
Newport crey uh some I'd work the
register sometimes and we had lessons on
how to deal with Flim Flam artists
that's what they called them flimflam
artists so they would teach you so we
had to uh sit there and be taught like
how someone will [__] you up like soell
something will cost three bucks and
they'll give you a 20 and they'll say
hey uh can you give me a 10 and a five
and then the rest in quarters and you're
like what how much is that and then
before you know and he's saying
something else and talking over you and
you think you owe him $40 like you're
giving him more money he like I gave you
50 so you give me the 20 that 20 and
then what is it it was three bucks so
you owe me 47 so like before you know it
you're giving money away and you don't
understand what's happening especially
when you're a kid I was like I think I
was 16 when I was working there I was a
monkey basically a monkey right and you
know these people travel all over the
place and they do this to folks they
just trick them they pickpocket them
like watching David bla do car tricks
okay from as close as you are to me I
don't get it I don't know what he's
doing he can get me every time he's he's
going to trick me every time he's so
good at it and there's guys that are I
don't know if they're at that level but
there's guys at a level that you or I
can't perceive and they'll steal your
watch like there's guys who can get your
watch off yeah like they can get your
watch off I don't know how they do it
but it's a known thing it's a known
thing the guys know how to get your
watch off [__] guys I mean how many
videos on YouTube there's awesome videos
of like children doing this to people
you could see like kids like get trained
to do this it's like they it's hacking
our operating system essentially he
stuffed a card into my friend Jeff's
watch band and Jeff didn't even know it
was in there and he's like look it's
there and he's like what he looks at his
watchband he'll like pull it out and
it's the card he was looking for folded
up tucked into his watch P you're like
what what did you just do so if that
guy's a thief if he was like some like
oh is this someone stealing something
yeah there's a whole genre of YouTube
video oh boy look at that wow little
tiny kids y they're trained wow they're
trained to steal they practice Yeah they
practice to do it I mean this is just a
look we see this on the human realm and
we're like oh my God they're children
you see a coral reef and a little fish
come and take food from another fish
it's like just totally normal I mean
it's not even this is just part of being
in a hive you know did that guy just
steal that guy's watch is that what just
happened bro back that up that was crazy
look watch how this guy bumps into this
guy he takes his watch
watch
this is that what he did no no the guy
still had a watch on what did he steal I
don't know I think the bottles you'll
never know I'm I'm too high for this I'm
too high for this but i' I've never seen
anybody take someone's watch off but I
know it's real thing like guys can
actually take your watch off like I mean
like one with a strap where they do the
Buckle it's annoying for you to do yeah
dude I like to me this is a natural part
of the environment we're in how many
things camouflage themselves as other
things take energy out of a system using
the camouflage it's completely [__]
normal it's nature so you you get this
Trump and you get people who fell for it
and now those people are deeply invested
in that HP like magic trick which he did
and by the way this is another thing
it's like look you don't have to like
somebody like I don't like Charles
Manson yeah but man I do recognize like
how [__] entertaining he is you know
what I mean like that's a very
entertaining cult leader similarly with
Trump not a fan you know the moment he
said he implied you should shoot looters
all the look we can go on and on with
antib I'm not I'm not talking about that
I'm saying the problem is that that our
tactic As Americans is not supposed to
be we listen to the state and get our
cues about how to be good people from
the state our As Americans what we do is
we have like basic fundamental ideas
that are really [__] beautiful one of
them being that we like believe that
people have a right to be free and and
seek their own personal happiness that's
beautiful man that's not we shouldn't
have the state telling us different
versions of what that is we we have to
be intelligent and autonomous enough to
do that for ourselves and then from that
like really be a a United States and and
like what's happening now is these
[__] uh are are not unifying us
this is supposed to be the United States
of America that's what it's supposed to
be so if you're in a government official
here and you're doing a thing that's
making it all divided and [__] up and
you're telling lies and you're shaming
people for telling the truth it doesn't
matter if you're a Republican or a
Democrat whatever you are as as far as
I'm concerned anti-American which is
like man Americans and and [__] anybody
who gets mad at me for saying this
Americans are beautiful people we we
both tour we get to meet people all over
the [__] place and talk to them and
they're always generally wonderful yes
some of them will take your [__]
watch you know what I mean but still
still you know in general in general
that you you encounter when things were
going well see this is the thing that
shifts everything is co the reason why
everybody's ramped up I mean it's not no
small feet it's not just about getting
sick it's about everybody being scared
that they're going to lose loved ones or
they're going to die or they're going to
lose lung function you can't work so
you're worried about your income there's
so many people whose businesses are
eroding right before their eyes their
eyes I mean imagine if you own
commercial real estate now Jesus Christ
and you you you you start thinking of
the prospect of leasing a building that
you invested all your money in out to
some folks they're not going to have
offices like that anymore people are
going to do [__] from home there's a lot
of people that are actually more
productive working from home I know it's
it's a [__] up time so everybody's on
eight everybody's walking around on
eight trying to keep it together that's
right and so a guy like trump
exacerbates it cuz he doesn't ever come
out with a Unity speech yeah it's always
like a he's always the strong boss
you're fired I'm the man it's I mean
this is the message and it works with a
lot of people it's a good look it's it's
like comedy or music not not everything
works on everybody but there's a lot of
people that Vibe with his [__] real
cartoonish version of being the boss
right but it's not a bring everybody
together thing and that's this is what
we need we need the guy in the movie
that stands on top of the hill the guy
that says we have more ins similarity
than we do that we disagree with man
we're together we're friends most people
most of our issues we could work out
amicably we could talk most of our
issues the vast majority and we need to
not just dwell on those but Embrace
those like embrace all the things we
like we want safe schools for our kids
we want Safe Streets we we want a um
[__] Bridge maintenance so the
bridges don't collapse we want everybody
to be okay yeah we want no crime we want
we we don't want unjust prison we don't
want people being
unjustly accused and then sentenced to
life in jail and other people to work
forever to get them we don't want any of
that we don't want any prosecutors that
hide evidence that shows that a person
was innocent that's real today in 2020
they don't even get in trouble for it
yeah man it's right it's it's true and I
think that the only
the maybe this is naive I think we got
to get over our addiction to the person
on the hill we got to get over our
addiction to the idea that the way we
govern is the only way to govern that's
it and that's why when I see that what
was it called again a Chaz you know
again like yeah to me it's not to me
what I'm seeing there is at the very
least a radical experiment and a
potential now it's a temper tantrum by
some 20-year-old kids who hate
capitalism how old were the founding
fathers and that's a good question but
they didn't have YouTube I think they
would have formed a much better opinion
well the the whole and this is the other
part of it like so I I keep thinking
about and again man this is where my
case is going to start falling apart but
that's okay I don't mind if my case
falls apart the for me it's I keep
thinking like okay so what are they
telling us now how to feel they're
saying well either you're a socialist or
a capitalist or a communist or tell me
what kind of IST I am or what ISM I'm
into and I keep thinking like
man can't there isn't it possible with
all the technology we have that there's
a new ISM that that no one's that
doesn't have the first part of the word
attached to it good point so it's like
and and and so at the very least if you
meet someone who's like
in Passionate in a real way not in a
[__] way by the way man because like
there's a big difference between like
you you know right away when you run
into somebody who's trying to tell you
how to be it's horrible it's a even even
if it's in a light way it's such a it's
so drones some
like some people want you sick some
people want you destabilized and like
unbalanced some one one thing is for
sure people don't want you to know who
you are cuz if you know who you are they
can't tell you who you are but but you
know if you run into someone who's
legitimately UT a utopian here we go get
ready to lose [__] viewers right now
baby this is where people press stop on
Spotify go on to like listen to like my
favorite murder or whatever but I was at
Burning Man and stop stop stop stop stop
hey man I am sure burning man is like
everything else in the world there's a
lot of profound conversations and few of
them that want to make you just bury
your head in the sand definitely and and
and but one this guy came up to you just
getting these great chats and this guy
came up to me we're just yapping and he
said do you think world peace is
possible he wasn't being a missionary or
anything just asking just asking it's a
real question but it's so cliche that it
seems like a joke question that a [__]
would ask you isn't that funny like what
would you want more than that world
equality World Financial equality world
peace there's like four or five things
you would ever say like look that might
cure up a lot of [__] yeah that's right
and but to ask it is so cliche like
everybody Burning Man what well that's a
that's we're peace well you know and
that's other thing if like let's say
you're at the Venice boardwalk and some
son of a [__] dressed like Uncle Sam
comes and ask you that you're going to
like go the other direction like [__]
you like you're just GNA leave right
maybe if you get out of Nicaragua man
yeah yeah but but he was actually
somebody who's really into Buckminster
Fuller and I think that was something
Buckminster Fuller put out there which
is like this this question is very
important and you should you should ask
yourself this as an individual because
if you think world peace is possible
right uh even if you acknowledge that
maybe right now it's not possible but if
you can invent in your mind some
technology some or even if you can
invent in your mind like an X like an
algebra for a thing you don't have the
space for yet but it could be if there's
any sense in you at all that world piece
is possible then from that point forward
you should be part of whatever it is
that's going to make us have that
great utopian ideal that transcends
American borders and because the that's
the other problem is the American dream
thing it's confined It's Not The
American Dream It's the human dream the
human dream is the intuition we all have
that there's a way for us to be on the
planet together that doesn't involve
blowing each other up right and that's I
think it's possible I think it's
possible I just don't know how it would
be how to get there necessarily but I
think it's possible and one thing's for
sure whenever you get a trump or any
[__] pundit blowing out divisive [__]
into people's brains they are not draw
if there's like a scale one Sid's World
Peace one side's chaos they're dropping
they're dropping their their Pebbles on
the chaos part of the scale and it's
like you why why do you think they're
doing that cuz man let me tell you
there's a lot of money to be made in
[__] chaos man there's a lot of money
I mean isn't that what an engine is an
engine is kind of like controlled
explosions do you remember when Trump
talked openly once about the
military-industrial comp complex yeah
and he said they want to go to war yeah
and you're like what the problem is he
says so many other things that are
ridiculous I know if only he just said
that if only he just said that the
problem with him saying that is you can
go yeah yeah yeah but he also called
this chicky [__] the horse face like you
know
he and you go oh yeah that's not that
nice like he he had he had a he had a
thing there like a moment like an
isenhower moment not quite as eloquent
but when Eisenhower was on television
and he warned people about the
military-industrial complex as he was
leaving office that's to this day like
one of the most profound speeches I've
ever seen because it gives me a chill
because I think well this is black and
white from how many [__] years ago if
this [__] was going on then it's not
like it stopped going on didn't stop we
see one of the reasons why we're in such
a [__] up space politically is because
this is the first time where politics
have been really exposed to the General
Public by the internet like you you have
a different access to politics you never
had before you have real time things
breaking you find out like if someone
like Gavin Newsome said he was going to
take a pay cut he didn't Fox News
princess it goes W and you get all these
stories like oh would you have known
that before cell phones and the internet
you would have never known that he
didn't do that you would have to be a
person who's really into politics and
there's not that many of them most
people are busy so now politics relies
on scandals and Scandals are weasel
people through that's it so the thing
about scandals is not everybody's a good
person right and if you if you do a lot
of [__] up [__] but you own it the way
Trump did people didn't count on the
[__] vote cuz there's a lot of
[__] out there and finally they had
a king they're like this is our King
[__] you magga they wear the [__]
sunglasses and they talk [__] to Ted
Cruz at rallies those guys finally had a
king and that that's like we didn't
there was no King on the other side
there was no King the compassionate
intelligent King who actually made sense
well that's the sad part that's what we
don't have think how how depressing your
very astute observation is in the sense
that the idea was we weren't going to
have a [__] monarchy here yeah that
was the whole point and now we elect a
monarchy yeah yeah that's the whole
point man and it's like and again it's
like look if like if you start playing
the game that you're the smart person in
the room and that if people disagree
with you they must be dumb if people
have ideas than you they must be stupid
and then you start shaming them what can
you what all you're doing is creating
this like you're going to create a
reaction to that and the reaction is
going to be a celebration of every
single thing you're with your great vast
Elite intelligence to riding you know
and so I think you know that's the
problem is it's like I it's just there's
nothing worse than when like people who
are legitimately smart have read a bunch
of [__] books have got master's
degrees have not developed enough
compassion
to understand that just about every
single person on the planet wants to be
happy wants to have a full stomach
doesn't want to hurt anybody and would
run into a building on fire to save
somebody most everybody I would say I
would say at least 90% a large
percentage a large percentage and these
[__] are are shaming them and
telling them they're idiot or they're
stupid or this and that it's like [__]
you man you don't know what these people
came up through you don't know these
people were born into Like Houses filled
with [__] methamphetamin smoke M
whose parents were like you know
absolutely [__] insane and they still
managed to get out and get a job and
have a [__] life and pay taxes and
now your [__] ass is going to tell
these people who didn't have the [__]
trust fund that you had that got you
into the [__] ivy league university
they're [__] idiots shut the [__] up
stop they're not and then I'm shaming
those people that's the problem the idea
is like you're not shaming them you're
just honestly Illuminating their their
their current situation let's just let I
don't think it's shaming them yeah it's
time to like let go of the whole like
snoody thing it's time to also on the
other side it's time to let go of like
every single one of these people must be
like burning candles to mik in their
backyard thing too like let's let go of
the all those stories for a second I'm
not saying there aren't people burning
candles to mik I've never definely are
I've never met I've seen the Bohemian
Grove video is that mik yes that's mik
the owl God when Alex Jones and John
Ronson's no it's Molech they they were
talking about is it Molech is how youon
Al Al according to Alex uh John Ronson
and Alex Jones they snuck in Bohemian
Grove this was when everybody was saying
it was all [__] and I I say this
many times and I'll say it some more
give me that later you got it Fred Alex
Jones he's he's made some mistakes and
some big ones but he's also actually
exposed some real [__] and he owns up to
the mistakes he's made they're not good
he doesn't think they're
good the there's a thing about finding
conspiracies everywhere that's not good
for your brain I really believe this I
think that if you go looking for those
things and that's all you look for and
you look for them all the time you can
get real paranoid and real crazy and
then there's also a bunch of people that
are trying to stop you from doing that
because you do expose some crazy [__]
you know he was talking about Epstein a
long time ago I know a long time ago he
was saying there was a [__] Island
and and they take all these rich
politicians and and some celebrities and
they bang these kids and I was like come
on he was telling me this a long time
ago so he's also the one who told me
about Bohemian Grove well I actually
watched it from that's I think this tape
was actually made before I met him so he
went and snuck in to this place where
like former president go there's a
photograph of it's uh Ronald Reagan with
Herbert Walker Bush and a couple other
people all standing around and it's like
these are the people that used to hang
out at this place and they would put on
robes and they would worship an hour God
owl God and they would burn an effigy
and they're playing and Alex snuck in
and made video footage of this [__] and
then no one's denying that it's real
this really did happen they're so
they're in with these bankers and former
presidents and they're dressed like
Druids and and some guy brings over
something that it's an effigy that's
supposed to be a body a wrapped up
Effigy it's a bunch of sticks in BL in a
blanket but it's like shaped like a body
and they drop it on the fire and they're
all worshiping an owl God why is that
bad imagine if you saw those if that's
what your business is just finding those
things how crazy you think you get first
of all wait then you add in vodka and
head wounds wait wait wait hold on wait
go to the Vodka headwinds part what do
you Jones okay I got you lot of vodka he
had a bad head injury God damn it man
when I was in Liberal art school man
there's this great teacher who changed
my life Sam Scoville and he one of the
things he taught was so beautiful he
still teaches there one of the things he
taught was figure out a way to take in
all information and then filter out the
[__] that's not real and keep the real
stuff and like you know Alex Jones is
like let's yeah some of the stuff is
real take what's real and throw there's
a good chunk of it that's real like I
remember he was telling me that that
there's government's using chemicals to
turn frogs gay I was like what what are
you talking about he goes yes he goes
pesticides are turning frogs gay and I'm
like that can't be real no there really
is is that true yes there's pesticides
that change Frog's genders what yes yes
but some pesticide [__] with Frog's
genders that sucks maybe it doesn't I
mean depends on the Frog maybe it's
awesome for the FR maybe frog don't give
a [__] cuz they've never been taught
homophobia they don't care who they [__]
but there's a real thing that see you
find that it's it's a pesticide that has
some sort of an effect an unintended
effect on frogs genders dude that's
another thing that people don't talk
about pesticides that have been used in
like golf courses and like there's
people who live around those that's a
chemical dump yeah golf courses are F
pesticide atrazine can turn male frogs
into females cool so there's a [__]
pesticide that changes the gender or
should I say the sex is it the same
thing I have to sex and gender hey I'm
not getting sucked into that [__]
black hole Rogan you can keep that [__]
to yourself but hey I'll get sucked into
another black hole isn't that crazy
though well yeah before we get into the
that that stuff I want to say this real
quick okay is that camera on me friends
at the Bohemian Grove future friends I
should say I just want you to know I
don't know much about you I I know Alex
Jones you know probably on vodka drinks
I don't think he was then I think he was
sober he started drinking after all this
please don't [__] this up for me sorry
sorry so you had an infiltrator look I
went to a summer camp we have bonfires
we wore robes I mean not like maybe what
you do I just want to say hey come on
invite me please I won't tell anybody
anything I've heard you guys are pretty
awesome actually what I've heard is the
idea was to get a bunch of Hardcore
neocons together and then mix some
artist in in the hopes that like having
like brushing shoulders with artists
would in some way shape or form loosen
some people up a little bit and I've
also heard you have a tram that connects
campsites there to other campsites
meaning you just get in the tram and
suddenly you're hanging out with Dick
Cheney listen I won't tell anybody I got
a podcast I won't even tell Joe let me
in I'll worship
mik I won't worship mik if it means
hurting people but I don't understand
why people are upset about [__] by
the way they
that you [__] video why is what's
wrong with worshiping nothing this is
the so excited this is the thing that I
get confused about here it's like in our
country we've got people who are
Christian yes and that's beautiful thing
and I do love Jesus I was reading the
book of Mark today regarding the parable
of the S but that being said I don't
think it's fair necessarily to tell
people they can't worship an owl or burn
an effigy in front of an owl and some
kind of symbolic magical ritual that
represents the disintegration of your
negative energy or whatever it may be I
really don't know but that be you know
to me that's the other problem that's
happening right now is like Superstition
is R running rampant I'm friends with
lots of witches I know a few satanists
and I know a few people are under the
occult and I don't know a single one of
them that would tolerate child abuse I
don't know a single one that wouldn't
kill somebody some of them would kill
people if they thought they were hurting
kids not and make it so that nobody
found the body some of the Satanist know
they would kill some they would kill
someone probably I don't know for sure
I'm not trying to throw any Satanist
under the bus but I'm just saying like
this idea that we can't have alter
alternate Pagan religions in our country
without immediately being associated
with human sacrifice or child abuse I
think that goes against the American
Spirit it's like look because people
don't want to subscribe to your
particular like very popular Global
religion doesn't necessarily implicate
them in like something that is truly a
horror which is human trafficking so to
me this is the problem is like man we
got to be a little bit more nuanced in
our apprehend in our conceptualization
of these people again I don't know
what's going on at the [__] Bohemian
Grove but from what I've heard it's
basically a summer camp for billionaires
where they try to get artists in there
to like loosen them up a little bit
that's what I've heard I could be wrong
who told you this is this I honestly
can't [__] say
h h interesting look man I don't know
and I know and I've seen have you seen
the video of Bohemian Grove have you
seen it the the the the ritual in front
of the AL God have you seen it yeah dude
go come with me to Burning Man and you
will see that every every 50 feet sure
look I don't think it's that big of a
deal I really don't if it involves
hurting kids it's a big deal and if
these [__] are doing anything
that involves Human Sacrifice hurting
human beings in in in a in any
application of that of course then it's
the worst thing on Earth and I'm so
sorry that I said anything about it but
I don't think I don't think that's what
this is I mean obviously what we're
seeing is not that we don't know what
else happens but what you're seeing is
them burning sticks in front of this uh
owl God and it's like this crazy um
crazy uh Speech they're giv while it's
going on it's it's really weird hey can
we hear some of it the
speech I don't know where the speech is
in the video I found another video where
they like stabilize the footage the oh
it's like uh but I mean before before
this nobody really believed that
listen care and all the winds make carry
with th docks hail fellowship's Eternal
Flame once again Midsummer sets us
free and now they're they're lighting
the effigy on fire and everybody's
cheering
it looks fun Stanley cubrick had this uh
quote once to uh Nicole Kidman I think
it was they were working on Eyes Wide
Shut see if you can find what she said
about the
elites that he that he had said say I I
know I saved it I can find it if I have
chance to look at my laptop but it was
something
about him you know talking about the the
powers that run the world and that they
all have something on each other that's
how they all can stay together they all
compromise each other that's what Skull
and Bones was about like that's what all
that stuff is about so he had a much
more concise quote on that but when you
see something like that you go well
maybe it's like fun that they do it that
nobody knows they do it you know what
I'm saying yeah like maybe it's like one
of those rituals where you get together
your dad thinks it's hilarious and you
both put your hoods on you go out there
and you burn the owl or you burn the
sticks in front of the owl and what's
fun is that you're not supposed to be
doing it and it's a secret but nothing
really is happening that's also on the
table yeah it's possible but it it's
[__] weird man that was weird imagine
if there was no Catholic Church imagine
if you are a billionaire that's what
you're doing with your weekend but
imagine if there was no Catholic church
and there was one video of a mass right
we would be like what the [__] that's
[__] up imagine any religious ceremony
if there was only one version of it cuz
I I I'm not trying to reduce it to
summer camp fun or even like fraternity
games there's a who knows what it is
right we we just you can know what it is
yeah they'd have to tell us but we just
see something crazy but it's not evil I
mean what is it well it's for me it's a
question mark I I don't really know I
know that my just dress weird my my
tendency whenever I have a question mark
is to assign malevolence to it just out
of a basic kind of weakness in my own
bias like if I don't know what a thing
is like you know when you're waiting for
the doctor to call regarding some Scan
they just did on you you you know if you
if you have the slightest fear of death
or any kind of bias in you then that
space in between when you when maybe
we're overlooking this maybe it's like
their version of Renaissance Fair and
people just want to escape reality and
pretend that they live with mik the hour
God and throw a [__] Hood over your
head and yes please and peace be with
you yeah I mean it it could be some kind
of like Pagan celebration you know and
if you look back at like the history of
paganism or Hedonism or Terence McKenna
does such a great job talking about the
elu cidian Mysteries and the you know
all these like things that aren't really
quite as accessible as the main main
religions of the world all the religions
of the world they have this beautiful
quality in them depending on the
religion and generally one of the
qualities is so beautiful is a mechanism
of self forgiveness and a mechanism of
purification the a general assessment of
the human condition as being somewhat
depraved I how many like the puking in
iasa you're purging yourself from your
Darkness the confession booth in
Catholicism uh maybe you could say in
gnosticism like true nosis or in
Buddhism like connecting with like
actual reality versus your overlayed
reality or you know it goes on and on
this is all within each one is this idea
of like there's a way for us to
ritualistically uh create if you want to
be a pure scientific materialist a
beautiful placebo effect that gets you
to drop some of your neurotic qualities
or the very least reset your intention
to make the world a better place and
anything whatever that I don't care what
the [__] it is whatever it may be if
that's what it what it's all about is a
recognition like man you beat yourself
up every day you're so hard on yourself
you beat yourself up for all the [__]
you did in the past and and and we live
in a world right now where there's not
much tolerance there's not much
forgiveness and and and anything that
allows a a kind of like steam valve from
which all that [__] can get released so
from this day forward you're born again
you're brand new I don't care if it's an
owl man go if you think that's crazy
look at like Main Street Disneyland any
night that's some crazy [__] to watch
too and some people's entire lives I'm
not being like changed from like having
a great night anywhere so you know to me
it's like ritual is not scary to me
what's scary to me though I is uh any
that objectifies humans enslaves humans
uh uh hurts kids and so yeah Human
Sacrifice any of that stuff and if
that's what's really happening there I
truly don't know then I completely
apologize for any defense sticks it's
just sticks the question is was it
always just sticks did it used to be
people did they used to sacrifice a
person did they stop doing it at one
point in time one widely cited Nicole
Kidman interview was made up by the fake
news site news punch you sons of [__]
[__] God damn it they got me they got
you but again does it say what the quote
is yeah what is the quote he said the
Hollywood's run by pedophiles or
something like I found the Reddit page
where it was put up and God damn they
got me they glad I asked you hey you
want to see something real creepy can
Jamie may I ask you to look something up
look up the that there's a a video of a
van that was actually used for human
trafficking I saw that that [__] is
chilling terrify chilling and it's like
to me it's like man if we're gonna be
it is there anybody who is at the Helm
of the ship that's fighting those
[__] right now deserves medals
and I hope that they never stop what
they're doing I just want them to be
very precise in their attacks that's all
don't dilute your position by getting
caught up in something and again I am
not I'm already going to get attacked
for this saying like Doug it works for
the blah blah I don't I I don't I'm a
Buddhist and I I go to romdas Retreats
and burning man but and if they invited
me to the Bohemian Grove I go and if I
went there and I saw that I was going to
say if Stanley cuber can keep keep a
secret we can
too are you saying you would go to the
Grove with me
yes that' be awesome tell anybody but
you know if you and I were invited there
and we saw anything happening that was
anything to do with like what people I
would think it would be a trap and they
would be setting us up they would put on
like some sort of fake thing just to
make us look like fools that we talk
about it on our podcast do you know man
if we ever do a movie together that's
the movie like it should be all your
friends going to the bo get invited to
the Bohemian group exactly right like I
become friends with some guy who's like
a banker who really likes comedy yeah
right and then this guy tells you he
gets drunk one night like I I know the
Illuminati they're real the Bilderberg
Group it's real like what yeah man
Jackal Island it's a they made the
federal Institute it's not even from
America man and you're like what what
and then this guy starts un unraveling
the tale of America can I tell you
something crazy the Federal Reserve yeah
people in my family used to own parts of
Jackal Island okay tell the story of
Jackal Island cuz that's what I'm
talking about if people don't know it
well here's the problem I don't know the
story like I I I remember hearing some
[__] I have like two paragraphs in my
head memorized I remember hearing people
in my family had some claim on land
there and that they sold it and I since
then I was just kind of resentful
because it's like they sold it for
nothing and like if they'd held on to it
like you know I would be at the [__]
Bohemian
Grove and so Jackal Island supposed to
be the place where they invented the
Federal Reserve right I I went there's a
great hotel is that it Jamie what does
it say listen this all disclaimer figure
where to look we're all three of us are
morons yes okay this is not that's one
thing that drives me crazy there's one
of the things about silencing people
that are crazy
online I can tell when someone's crazy
and part of someone being crazy is you
see these crazy people and you go oh I
think they might be crazy and then you
look in you go yeah none of none of what
they're saying makes sense they actually
are crazy but damn that was pretty close
yeah dude you got to be the thing about
people saying things that other people
disagree with when they want to silence
those people is you don't think that
other people are smart as you you're
thinking that's going to work on other
people someone's saying that the Earth
is flat and there's lizard people that
control the sunrise if that was you
you'd go okay you know what I'm saying
it wouldn't work so why not let someone
say it so if someone says it it doesn't
work on you but what are you worried
about you're worried it's going to work
on somebody else that's what you're
worried about you worri it's going to
and that's the weird thing about Co
because it's the one thing where you're
not allowed to do that anymore because
if you do anything that goes against the
government by lines anything that goes
against what the World Health
Organization thinks you should do or CDC
thinks you should do you get kicked off
of YouTube you get silenced everybody
gets removed whether you're right or
wrong it's the one thing where you can't
talk crazy you can talk crazy about the
Earth being hollow you can talk about
being
that are made out of light that fly in
and out of our Consciousness and that's
responsible for all of our ideas and you
could talk about how there's an
application that's coming in 2023 it's
right now being vetted by the NSA to
make sure that we can use it so we can
communicate with the aliens you can have
all these whacko videos where you're
making [__] up and no one cares but if
you say that masks don't help and what
we need to do is uh get healthier
they'll remove you from YouTube well
that's the fire and a crowded theater
thing like you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater so so like the pro like
look the problem with it is to me is I
like have like gone through every single
stage of grief over YouTube is a bad um
analogy maybe a better analogy is you
can open up businesses as long as you do
it carefully I Used to Love YouTube man
I used to love it I still love it well
what I loved about it in the old days I
still love it I still go on every day
but what I loved about in the old days
is what you're saying no one's putting a
cork in the champagne bottles it wild it
was it was a museum of Madness and you
would and what was even better as the
algorithm was working in your favor so
it's like punch in Hollow Earth yes
that's going to take you all the way to
like some crazy deep [__] and never once
in all my Explorations on on the early
days of YouTube was I like this could be
real it was more like wow look at how
all the different versions of reality
that people are processing and and it
was a joy but I think what happened
probably is like people realize like God
like what we've got like you talk about
this ties bad the nightmare when and it
will happen when primates figure how to
like use friction to make fire you talk
about this yes and that's a nightmare
for the planet like you think the
[__] shit's bad now wait till the
chimps figure out guns yeah just fire
just fire just figure out how to make
their own fire think think of like the
beginning the when like if the Proto
homed shift into like figure out really
good point you know this is trouble
imagine think of how many people died in
the beginning of like discovering fire
oh my God how many experiments were done
with fire how many things were just set
on fire how many people just burn I can
eat it I bet you can eat it let me eat
it I'll get its energy in my body holy
[__] he melted his face off you know so
similarly like with with the internet we
have this F we have this new fire and
like people who are like in the conduits
of the fire are are are I think they're
they're having this really rotten come
to Jesus moment where they're like cuz I
think a lot of these especially if you
look in the Silicon Valley these people
are freaks the early day like the people
making technology they're nuts I seen
you that Steve Jobs thing with him in a
commune or whatever these people are
[__] crazy but I think they're
recognizing that like it it's like okay
the internet is the new Fire yeah and
and and so and they're starting to
understand that like because of them
because of their intentional
manipulative Cod voting because of their
deep study of BF Skinner and behaviorism
they've produced this hypers seductive
semi sentient information dispersal
device that is driving people who don't
have the immune system to data that
you're supposed to naturally get from
school crazy that's what's happening and
so people are going nuts because it's
like well add that with the addictive
quality of Technology those two things
together The Addictive quality just
looking at like your phone and getting
information off your phone and then add
it to all this stuff that you're saying
yeah man and and it's a crazy
combination and there I think Google and
YouTube and as much as like you know and
I do think censorship's [__] I would
hate to be in anybody's position there
because on one hand you're looking at
like a very liberal very beautiful idea
which is like everyone should be allowed
to say whatever they want to say and
then it's meeting like well but what
about these hyper charismatic seductive
people who like
Hitler you know what I mean like so now
you run into this terrible place of like
and also we know that there's people who
don't quite have the ability to discern
what's real from what's not but we allow
this is my beef we allow some of that
because we allow
evangelists I heard Robert Tien on one
of his shows yeah he goes every time you
write a check to me Satan gets a black
eye good dude it was in my act for a
while I was like where's my checkbook
you Satan you son of a [__] dude it's
imagine you could steal money that way
it's look man I I don't but you know
what I'm saying yeah I do know exactly
what you're saying and it's like this
type of con Artistry also cigarettes oh
you know it's like this type of con
Artistry generally it seems like there's
some kind of Grandfather claws on
specific styles of of of thievery and
murder yeah yeah cuz cigarettes like
they know they're killing people imagine
if you had bubble gum that killed a half
a million people a year just bubble it's
like bubble gum but just people just
dying stop selling that [__] what the
[__] are you doing what are you doing
you're see well people have a right to
chew their bubble gum a lot of people
like bubbles yeah that's right that's
all it was it's like you chewing bubbles
makes you happy and everybody's dying of
cancer and this company's making $500
billion dollar a year something like how
much do they make on cigarettes yeah how
much let's let's guess let's guess what
do you how much what do you think the an
by the way I want to say it before this
is a box of cigars okay Mike binder gave
me that and he gave me that one over
there another box of cigars I'm not
anti-tobacco in any way shape or form
I'm a pro- free choice person you
absolutely should be able to smoke
cigarettes and I think you absolutely
should be able to sell them because I
don't want to roll my own and if I want
a cigarette as a grown [__] man you
can I want to be able to have a
cigarette but cigarettes do kill a half
a million people in this country every
year yeah or they're going to die anyway
right cigarettes kill them early or they
die directly because of diseases that
you can get from smoking cigarettes and
their kids get sick dude the worst Man
kids that live in Greg fit Simmons he
has lung problems to this day because
his parents chain smoked and they lived
in massachus cold my mom did but she
quit when I was really young did when I
was like six I were you in the car with
her when she smoked I I must have been
with the windows up I don't well we
lived in New Jersey so it cold in the
winter I'm sure I was I don't think she
smoked in the car with her kids though
dude do you mind if I have a little more
of this [__] have a drink at all man
it's so good uh I I
remember Fletcher North Carolina middle
of winter you'd go down and wait for the
bus my friend Jimmy Fink I think it was
Jimmy Fink his mom would like let us get
in her car to wait for the bus it's
wonderful very sweet but also I think
and I'm sorry Jimmy if you're out there
I know we haven't talked in a long time
I still love you though but like and I'm
sorry if it's not you and I'm getting
confused here but the I just remember
she smoked and we like there was smoke
in the car my dad smoked I would ride in
the car with him on trips and he would
smoke and you'd breathe in the smoke and
like so so to me like where and again
like this is always the problem which is
like clearly we need regul there has to
be some regulatory principle in the
world if there are people who steal
watches there mean that means there's
going to be groups of people who get
together and talk about better ways to
steal watches if there's groups of
people get together talk about better
ways to steal watches and then we create
a way for them to form a thing called
like a corporation you know what I mean
you got you need to regulate that that's
why we need regulation so but then the
problem is is like who does the
regulating and what what's the incentive
for you to regulate is there a financial
incentive yeah The Regulators get paid
an exorbitant amount of money let's say
you and I start a vape pen company that
like is a nicotine vape pen and then
start pouring money into people who
against tobacco knowing if we can make
tobacco illegal but keep the vape pens
legal we're going to become the new
tobacco but here's the thing about vape
pens this is the real thing about VAP
pens some of them are not good for you
at all they're real bad for you and
there's a connection there're saying now
between covid and uh kids that Vape kids
that Vape dying of Co or getting serious
covid but it makes sense I have a friend
who's got a kid that sucks on one of
them things things all day long just
just Vapes constantly kids vape and
these kids that Vape all the time like
the oils that you're taking into your
lungs That's not healthy the idea that
it's not cigarettes so it's healthy no
it's there's a lot of evidence that
points to some of those companies that
make those oils they don't do it in a
way where you know there's like
different kinds of oils and they have
the different reactions to the Heat and
some of them are like am I saying this
right let's check on this what is the
problem with the different types of
Vapes because I think there was one type
of oil that they're using you because
they have to they have to somehow or
another mix the same with the marijuana
ones you have to mix this stuff with the
THC and it's some sort of chemical but
there's different you can do it
organically like I know they've done it
with
um uh coconut oil I know they've done it
with like things like that it's the same
way with hash man I think it's like the
the way people make hash varies and some
people there's a healthy way to make it
and the obviously the way using the most
chemicals is the cheapest and so there's
certain types of hash that you I think
are derive and again my friends out
there look I don't know but it's
something like butane someone told me
this at a at a marijuana store I can't
remember what but yeah man it's like
concern is the oil like what kind of oil
like I know there's one guy that was
selling them the with MCT oil okay here
it is authorities in the Food and Drug
Administration and Centers for Disease
Control and preven ition still aren't
sure what's causing the dangerous Trend
but theories range from issues with
vegetable oil and vape juice to the idea
that doctors are just now taking note of
a problem that's been percolating for a
long time so okay so that was a
speculation that people were using um
like if you try to cook okay and you try
to like sear a steak and you do it with
olive oil you're going to [__] it up
because olive oil is it's not like
something that you really um sear
something with like you put olive oil in
you don't you don't want to get it that
hot yeah olive oil is more something
that you'd like to sauté with but other
oils like avocado oil or um or beef fat
like that stuff is amazing because you
can get it really [__] hot and it has
a very very high uh temperature where it
turns to smoke right so it's like
healthier for you the idea so if you're
misting this stuff into your lungs you
don't want it burnt right right you want
something that's more so I would imagine
if you're using these cheap this is
again I'm a [__] I'm not a scientist
but we're doing science if you're using
a vape Vape pen with like some really
shitty canola oil and you're getting
that burnt spray inside your lungs like
that could be terrible for you terrible
you got some [__] GMO cornn syrup
[__] in your lungs yeah you know the
haunting thing man you go to a pharmacy
right and you watch as the pharmacist
dispenses the drugs how careful he is
right like they are like so careful in
their administration of these pills
because they know if like for one second
you give someone Xanax when they were
supposed to get penicillin killed
somebody right so you have to be very
careful but like meanwhile look at us
right now Joe did you do a test on that
bottle of booze are these I didn't even
I honestly it was embarrassing I'm like
I don't know how to light this blunt but
then like I'm smoking something called
dadrass I don't know what's in this [__]
I don't do any studies here I just
that's for people who love Steely Dan I
I do love Steely Dan do too they have
some great [__] songs you know what I
mean I'm saying like the general like in
in America and anywhere The General
sense is I'm going to eat it if you give
it to me especially if it's in a
colorful box and then you're like it
must be okay and and the problem is is
like sometimes it's not okay look at
thalomid man like you know look at like
the big moments in history when it was
shown like actually sometimes the stuff
we sell you is that theide
theide that's the stuff that gave kids
birth def facts yeah or what was that
radioactive [__] they painted on watches
oh my god dude we did a whole show where
talked about all the diseases that
people got from idium was that what it
was Jamie what was the radium radium
idium the they were using it for all
kinds of things and people's faces were
rotting off yeah literally they have
holes in their face they were painting
it on watches cuz it it would glow it
was cool looking but so so similarly
it's like they were using it for makeup
I think right yeah and here we have the
internet here we have the [__]
internet suddenly we have a hyper a way
to like super connect with every single
person on the planet but not just
connect with every person on the planet
we have an artificial intelligence based
on a neural network I don't understand
how it works suggesting who you should
connect with you know what I mean it's
like is the internet the thalidomide
technological thalidomide are we looking
at a I think so is that what we were
dealing with right now and like I think
we're on a spaceship and we haven't
quite figured out how to slow it down or
where the brakes are or how do you go
left or right yeah but the spaceship is
being propelled by thoughts and ideas
and social media and world events and
drugs and sex and politics and power and
control and it's all just hurling
through space and while while it's all
happened we haven't quite figured out
where the breaks are or what's the best
way to be harmonious with each other so
we're all in this constant battle for
control thinking that once we get in
control we're going to set this [__]
ship straight and everybody's going to
be cool we're going to be finally we're
going to get along because you're side
one but you're still going to have half
the [__] country that hates you half
the country that doesn't agree with you
half the country that has to like be
really tolerant in order to engage you
in any of your ideas and admit that
you're right right yeah and this is what
we're doing and it's not real it's not
real I don't think it's real I think a
lot of the people that have ideas in one
way if they could just talk to people in
in in in the realm of the area where
they have disagreement I bet they could
work it out I think the problem is more
people not talking than anything Joe
tell me about the spaceship idea some
more cuz I don't think you're saying
some like knowing you like I know you I
wonder if you're saying that
metaphorically or like if there's it is
metaphorically but it's also actual we
are on a spaceship whether we like it or
not we're spinning a thousand miles an
hour and we're driving through Infinity
at a pace that if you if it was small
and it passed by you you would go holy
[__] yeah what was it if it was if the
Earth was the size of a baseball and it
whipped by you in real time the way it's
moving through the universe you would be
like
[__] that's what the Earth's doing but
the Earth is huge yeah it's huge and yet
it's tiny and it's surrounded by things
that are enormous got a sun that's a
million times bigger than us just a
fireball in the sky that all life on
Earth depends on a very clear space
between Earth and the Sun a perfect
balance
perfect balance between this Unstoppable
heat and just keep the water melted
don't boil it man and we're hurling
through infinity and while we're doing
that we're trying to pick who gets to be
the leader to steal your tax money we're
trying to tell you you can't go to a
beauty shop CU I don't want you get in a
cough that's right we're trying to tell
people stay home stay home Trump's
trying to kill America y it's the wrong
approach like the approach they're
making the the approach they should make
it should be all about
positivity you know everybody who's
voting knows who Trump is everybody
knows about the riots everybody knows
about everybody knows all those things
talk about what you want to do yeah talk
about what you want to do don't talk
about how bad the orange guy is tell me
what you want to do and don't use woke
lingo don't you [__] do it don't you
do it tell me tell me for real don't
[__] me tell me what you can do to
fix this right just that tell me you
want to bring everybody together just
that everybody rightwing left you got to
make concessions we got to figure out
like where we meet in the middle there's
much more that we agree with than we
don't agree much more let's concentrate
on that stuff and let's be nice about
this other [__] yeah that's right that's
it that's look it sound like you know
what you're saying it it's beautiful and
the what's one of the qualities that's
beautiful about is is simple that I when
I saw I got to see the dolly llama speak
once and it's like wow you in person no
at a at a he was at a like an event
right but you were in the audience yeah
I was in the audience so he was there he
was there with his translator it was
beautiful man real like the vibe in the
in the room was so sweet and like you
know to go back to what we were talking
about earlier some people will tell you
a stupid thing like a thing on the side
of a cal box like uh I apologize for
that be kinder for oh I'm so sorry but
you know I could tell you Joe you know
what the world
needs love and it's I do like cliches
though sometimes sometimes they're
accurate depend on who it's coming who
the cliche is coming from right if
they're sincere so the doy Lama is on
stage and he says you can always be
kinder and it was like you could feel
this wave rushing out of him I mean it
was like the essence of Buddhism just
rushing out everyone simultaneously
thinking like yeah he's right and it
transcends politics
geopolitics and and that that is why
what you're saying is so beautiful
because it's the same thing which is
like you know like this planet we're so
lucky to be on a planet going that fast
and and and and like we're so lucky to
to get a chance a little peephole into
time we're not here that long I think
this Co thing gives us an opportunity to
realize how lucky we really are I do too
I do for the people that are struggling
right now financially or struggling with
their health it doesn't you know doesn't
register with you I'm and I'm sorry
about that but I think for the people
that aren't [__] by this there is a
moment where we get to realize like oh
okay we were uh taking this for granted
we thought we had all this thing wired
in we didn't have it wired I mean they
got rid of the Senate what what was the
the pandemic there was a pan the White
House decided like a year before Corona
decided to get rid of the pandemic what
was a response what was the actual no
like he got the whole based on it they
they they dissolved it just imagine
imagine if like there's an asteroid like
well when's it coming 40 years fire
everybody fire everyone we're [__]
we're [__] just fire everybody the
more tests the more sick people we have
stop the test just
Fu they did that for real know I know I
know they so so from that what did they
teach us they taught us that we have to
depend on each other right now not the
state well I think they should give
people the opportunity to do what they
want to do I really I say this too much
I say it at almost every show but you
can't tell people they can't work it
doesn't make any sense you should you're
not smart enough for you to say that you
that the only thing that matters is
whether or not these people expose
themselves to the virus at this point I
think that's ridiculous but can I tell
you the problem I'm sorry I'm sorry to
cut you off but they have to acknowledge
that something else matters they have to
acknowledge that the financial problems
that people are going through are almost
unsurmountable they have to acknowledge
that and that that destroys a lot of
people that creates a lot of depression
creates a lot of suicide creates a lot
of drug abuse creates a lot of turmoil
and a lot of mental health issues that's
a fact true so we we're we're taking
away people's sovereignty look man if
you want to that was another great
American tradition if you want to kill
yourself well you can do it with so many
other ways you're welcome to kill
yourself go BMX flipping nobody's going
to stop you from doing flips with your
motorbike that was the whole point I
mean that's like remember when
everything got safe like the whole point
there was a time when everything was
like Al Gonzo and the problem is you're
spreading it right so it's not just you
and your motorbike it's you crashing
your motorbike into a crowd that that's
one of the problems there's a lot of
that's a good way of looking at it
honestly yeah but the bigger to me the
bigger that is a problem and it's [__]
the bigger problem is okay so you own an
Applebees or whatever right and suddenly
the government's like okay everyone can
go back to work but no one solve the
problem you the owner of the Applebee's
calls the the general manager like hey
dude get the waiters weight staff back
we're open it up you're not going to be
there you're going to have the general
manager come in and you're going to have
the weight staff come in now the weight
staff have been living off of
unemployment benefits supplied by the
federal government that sometimes are
more than like what they were making at
the place that's not a bad thing but all
of a sudden what happened is prior to a
true reduction of this pandemic that can
kill you most of the time it doesn't but
you might be the one who steps in the
landmine all of a sudden they just
decided Well we got the the economy
needs to work so now your unemployment
benefits get cut off and you have to go
back to work but they haven't solved the
problem yet so you become the the the
person who has to Bear the weight of the
failed uh approach to the disease and
that's why it's [__] up to s yes
you're right man my friend runs the new
California Barber Shop in Echo Park
Brian he's one of my be he started off
as my barber he became my best friend
he's one of the the coolest people I
know and like I like it like one of the
reasons I want to leave La is cuz that
shop can't open that's where I used to
go to get my beard trimmed in my ha but
it wasn't just that it was it's a real
barber shop and it was you have these
great conversations you beat people he
like he's like gotten me like he's
gotten me into a sublet that I once when
I needed to be in La for a little bit
one of the sad things about being bald I
never really developed the relationship
with the barber shop and by the time I
shaved it my head it was too late that's
a good thing to do you can get like a
nice straight razor shape yeah you know
there's you don't go to a bar something
about that right it's like for girl with
girls it's acknowledged that a lot of
ladies like beauty salons they like to
get their nails done they like to get
their pedicures they enjoy it yeah I
really like yeah like that's all been
shut down here right right and like it
sucks because that that I I loved going
there and it's like but you know the the
the thing is like a lot of people it's
not time to go back to work because if
there is a true risk that from making
minimum wage you're going to get a
disease that probably won't kill you cuz
you're a waiter Applebee's you're
probably going to be okay you're taking
your vitamins but you might be living
with your aunt who has Alzheimer's
disease and you're going to [__] kill
her because you picked up a little bit
of it and the reason you're going to
kill her is because you had to go back
to work because your benefits got cut
off so it's like this is the this is why
it's a very complex [__] up problem
that really we we it's like yes do for
me a person who I'm doing great do I I
want everything open I want to go to
guitar guitar center is open but I don't
want to stand in line I want to go into
guitar I want everything to be the way
it was I'm probably going to be okay but
this is again it's like this is a
complex problem I don't buy into the
idea that the whole thing's a scam I
think we've got exactly what that
[__] not why did I say [__] too
much boo that a do he was actually the
opposite of an [__] on your show I'm
like calling a doctor an [__]
Remember The Joe Rogan questions
everything the theologist who told us
there's going to be another great
pandemic six years well we should I've
talked about this before but we should
tell people Duncan and I were in
Galveston Texas and we went to the
Center for Disease Control and went to
the very place where they experiment on
Ebola and all these crazy diseases that
kill you instantly and Duncan and I were
in this building and we were watching
like we watch through a window that
takes you there's like another window
behind that that's like this plexiglass
sealed room and they have like space
suits on and tubes and I'm like hold on
hold on so there's some [__] in there
that can kill everybody like 100% And
like it's right there and they were
doing tests on it and so these people
are wearing like space suits and they're
walking around with these
horrific World killing diseases yeah man
and remember we missed the flight yeah
we did we missed the flight we had to
get there we were just high as [__] at
the airport talking and the flight the
flight took off dunan and I lost total
track of time we were barbecued we did
we take edibles dude I don't remember we
did something we were so high we might
have took Ed we might have took my my
custom is to take an edible in the car
my custom that's because it takes time
to get to the airport and by the time
you get to the airport the absurdity of
it all just kicks in in Full Steam cuz
it's like I have no control at the
airport the airport is a place where you
just want to give up complete control
and when you're super duper duper High
that's a fun ride you know so you and I
were just sitting down talking about
life and that plane went we're like
where's the plane like the plane left
like what we didn't just miss the plane
by like 10 minutes like 40
minutes it was the ultimate dumb Stoner
Moment Like if we weren't on our way to
film a television show we would have
looked like the biggest losers we looked
like losers anyway but but we had fun
and we took one in the morning and we
got there with very little sleep we made
it but being in like the Galveston Texas
Centers for Disease Control with like
very this is different this is the um
this is dunan this is Duncan went to
some Preppers this is one that I really
Lov cuz I didn't get a chance to be with
you so I got to watch it you know like
from the clips and see what it was like
when you went didn't you get to be that
one I was doing something else we were
trying to film two things at the same
time I think that time you know what man
I was really like not annoyed but like
because I love doing the show but I'm
like of course he doesn't show up to
this [__] cuz like suddenly I
end up deep in a I'm deep in a cave
would have totally done it but I think
it was when like there was a bunch of
things that we were trying to film and
we were short on time so we couldn't do
things together but remember we did this
Skinwalker Ranch one together you were
so pissed he was so fake oh there was
the problem was when we got there right
when we got there we heard this
Preposterous story from this person who
threw a cigarette on the ground after
that's what set you off 100% yeah cuz
I'm like this is a [__] he threw a
cigarette on the ground in the forest
this is a [__] like we drove here for
and he's lying we we're here with a
[__] who's lying I'm like oh great
great I actually asked him to pick it up
I'm like come on man I remember that
moment dude and it but that to me it's
like you can't it's beautiful Utah
Forest you smoke a cigarette and you
throw it down you step on it like you're
not my kind of person Joe here's the
reason you're so American you really do
believe in a utopian ideal and Joe Rogan
questions everything for real both of us
this is what I realized ye years after
we both had a sense in our heart that we
might really find proof of something big
and we went into it with that attitude
we did but we were so high we believe
what we were saying dude that's the
funniest thing about it it's like you
know most people when they do these
shows they're not going into it thinking
like I'm actually going to uncover
something yeah of course they don't go
into it thinking they're going to un
cover something they go into it thinking
this is all a bunch of [__] and I'm
going to do so I'm going to be like or
maybe they think maybe it's real or
whatever but the main thing is they they
don't they talk they they pretend it's
real that's the thing they it's real T
it's real and we also went into it like
two guys who are more High during a show
you will not find yeah it's true you
will not find theti let me barbecued
looking for bigfoot I mean dude I was
barbecu we were so high dude and this
guy we don't need to blow this guy's
spot up he's poor fell look at me my
hipst are face oh boy listen people love
maybe he believes what he's saying maybe
maybe all that stuff that they were
telling us they really truly believe but
they were talking about like bulletproof
wolves that appear out of mist and all
this stuff to me that moment was when
the show went South and what was really
funny was like this the last thing the
Sci-Fi Network wanted was for you to
like actually like begin to like realize
that maybe we're not going to find UFOs
and they started getting unhappy I think
with the situation oh they did get
unhappy there was actually a
conversation when they're like is he
trying to debunk these things cuz they
have all these shows on like UFOs and
all these show on ghosts and then they
have this comedian [__] with his
[__] buddy and they're both high as
[__] and they're like this is so fake
like this is so but we wanted to
know we wanted to know we wanted to know
if it was real or if it was fake
remember the alien artifacts part do you
remember that part there was someone who
collected all these alien little bits of
dust and metal you don't remember it
probably I remember that because I was
already given up on that point I noticed
a p unfortunately and I feel real bad
but it was it was really a personal
thing because I was dealing with my own
nonsense my own incv my own inclination
to uh believe ridiculous stories even
today like with the Pentagon story about
them having recovered uh a craft not
made from this world like please don't
let it be a misquote I don't want to I
don't want to read the misquote man I
don't so I know that there's a real pull
to believing in [__] there's a real
pull to like manipulating the actual
facts of Roswell so that it appears the
government absolutely 100% colluded to
keep the alien crash from the general
public and there's no way it could be a
weather balloon I don't know if that's
right man because I know it in myself
because I see it in myself I see that
dirty little [__] that wants to
believe in Bigfoot that stupid [__]
they're like hey hey hey maybe it's a
bear maybe it's not a lost monkey
species but I want to believe so bad so
I don't think that's a dirty [__] but
this is me this is me I've worked on
this right this is something that I've
spent a lot of time thinking about
there's a lot of people out there that
just lie they're not thinking about
anything but they the same way they want
to believe too they want to believe in
UFOs they want to believe in Bigfoot
they want to believe in all these things
they want to believe yeah and it's not
their fault they this is they grew up in
a [__] up town and their their friends
were probably all drunk by the time they
were four and the whole thing's a mess
and here they are stuck in this
situation where they're just making [__]
up and here you and I are standing there
going I don't think this guy ever really
was kidnapped by Bigfoot and we we get
to hear these ridiculous stories and
there was too many of them man we
everybody we talked to had this I I like
real obvious psychological like Bend to
them there was always like everyone and
no one had a steady chassis no one who
you were talking to right yes remember
the [__] Bigfoot guy that said he
would chop his pinky off to find out if
Bigfoot was real he was a professor he
was a professor I forget we had him on
the podcast we we had the foot the
footprint seeing Dr M Dr meler right M
Meldrum yes thank you Jamie's the wizard
Dr Meldrum Dr Meldrum he said he would
cut his finger off to find out if
Bigfoot was real would you cut your
finger off to find no I don't care
listen I hope it's not real I hope it's
it's real I don't care either one would
be awesome what data set would you cut
your finger off I would cut my finger
off to know if there was a a intelligent
design to Creation on Earth I would give
them my the very tip of my pinky for
that but then what happens then you run
around with this information you can't
share with anybody and you're freaked
out all day well no then I try to
contact that thing in a more intense way
I mean like the the P the tip of the
pink is not a bad thing to get rid of
yeah for like knowing knowing like
whether there's like again you have to
like so weak first of all what what kind
of computer are you working with that
you're going to have to take your pinky
and like drop it in to get truth out of
it it's a stupid computer you shouldn't
trust it if you ever want to feel what
it's like to to be like three again make
your thumb wrestle your
pinky your pinky is like [__] you have
no power in your pinky your pinky is so
weak that's what it's like to be like a
three-year-old straining against your
older brother get off me get off me
[__] you got a pinky that's right
this a what a [__] little digit what
does that thing get used for just what
does it get used for again I dislocated
both of them you dislocated them you're
pinky they don't match up oh dude oh
damn oh that's weird so one oh B oh that
makes s and all sorts of sh you use it
for holding wine you need it to like
extend when you're
drinking yes look man very important I
think that out don't you like I heard my
pinky doing that
wrestling with my thumb like
legitimately it hurts now it's so weak
it's so weak I but I do so much with my
hands so many chinups there's some
reason for it so many kettle bell grips
and it's mostly these other fingers even
when you draw back a a bow my bow my uh
my release doesn't even have a pinky
thing I draw back with these fingers
this [__] ass just hangs around for the
ride you're so mean to your
pinky why do you do that I love my
pinkies I love them they're great I
don't want them miss them but think of
the name itself it's like it's weird how
weak it is compared to all the other
digits you have and they named it a
pinky like the whole thing is like mess
the whole thing does sound like it's it
is a a very like we the name pinky
itself is like you know I will [__] you
up with this finger this finger right
here is strong as [__] this finger gets
a hold of [__] this is a strong finger
this is a [__] finger that's not
hurting anybody they're all on the same
hand it listen everyone belongs on the
hand like we have to forget the pinky if
you were as strong physically as your
small
toe wow that's crazy that's life just
everything can [__] you up every pebble
is murderous every jumping upstairs the
wrong way you stub your toe you want to
die if you that's who you are you are as
strong as your little baby toe your
little baby toe has zero power grab your
little baby toe and like wrestle with it
real quick it has nothing a it's a baby
yeah they call it a baby toe cuz it's
like a it's not babies are stronger than
your baby toe yeah yeah well look a
[__] ass little limb that's yeah that
would that's the funny thing about the
human sentient projection into time is
like we're probably like the little toe
of the universe you know like we have
just enough realization to know that
we're something we're this hilarious
intersection of like you know meat and
what appear like a real feeling of like
you know I do feel like uh bias aside if
there isn't a part of you that hasn't
like really come to the conclusion that
there seems to be a part of you that
doesn't get touched by reality the some
Eternal part of you that has met time
and space uh I I I feel like most people
get that sense kids feel that they they
know that they just actually know it but
you know to me I think maybe what we are
in this little temporary whatever it may
be whether it's an aquarium whether it's
a training facility I think it's
probably a training facility you know
like I don't think it's that I think
it's a process and I think the process
has to be tumultuous CU if it's not
nothing gets done I think the struggles
have to exist because if there's only
Harmony and peace everybody gets
stagnant I think right there's there's a
steady push towards ultimate
technological innovation that's the
steadiest push if you look at the human
race in terms of like what it makes like
what does it do at the end of the day if
you have these bees and they have all
this different thing all these different
social things they do and all these
different things they do for covering
territory and ground and all these
different aspects of being a bee and
laying the larvae inside the honeycomb
but what do they do what do they they
make honey [__] that's what they do
they make honey what do we do we make
robots we make computers we make
technology and we make it better every
[__] year we don't make better laws
every year like no no no we don't revise
that [__] we got stuff written with
[__] ink from charcoal you know [__]
like in the archive somewhere
what we do is we make better [__] every
year we make better [__] and our goal is
just keep making better [__] and I'm
obsessed with better [__] I'm obsessed
with like cell phones and I'm obsessed I
love like unbox therapy or um any any of
those shows Marcus brownley when they
doing these unbox videos and talking
about the newest latest and greatest
technology and they're showing these 120
HZ screens and these [__] cameras
with 100x optical zoom like
amazing but what are we doing we're
moving ourselves closer and closer to
some kind of technological superiority
and along the way we're losing our
humanity and that's the weirdest most
ironic part of it along the way of we
we've never been in a a greater
technological era if you look in terms
of the things that are consumer
electronics that get released right now
whether it's laptops or iPhones or you
know Samsung Note 20s or whatever the
[__] they are these things are insane
right never been in a time like this
before this is like this is peaked also
when have we ever had a time where
there's riots in every city every city
all across the country and it's all a
lot of it is things that most people
agree with right you say especially if
you say something like black lives
matter I want let's have a vote how many
people don't agree with that statement
just forget about what the this
everybody want oh it's a Marxist thing
and these people they they want to
destroy the nuclear family I don't know
if they do or they don't but most people
I bet who are who are a part of that
movement don't even know what that means
they don't know all that [__] they just
don't want people to get killed by cops
that's it that's it and it's not like
Michael Chay has a great bit about it
where it says like that's not even
asking a lot like matters like black
lives matter just matters like and
people like man I don't
know it's this is the strangest time for
us socially because of covid this is the
strangest time because of the economy
the strangest time because Trump is
President and there's chaos and the guy
who's running against him is older than
him and you're like this is madness like
what is what is happening here and no
one knows when the [__] people are going
to be able to go back to work and
there's all this chaos and all this
anxiety it's all happening together at
once I know man I know that's what this
is you know this is what I love like I I
work my medit I work with a meditation
teacher David nickar he's he's brilliant
and one of the things he tells me and I
really this is an example of how cool he
is this is when all the New York Times
[__] came out about the aliens I call
him I'm like David New York Times aliens
and he's like wow wow and then his
response was
Duncan where do you think thoughts come
from do you think they
are born from
something that was his response to me
telling about aliens was a question
where do you think thoughts come from
are thoughts like born like the way well
it's a good question it's a great
question I still haven't figured it out
but I've asked if ideas were aliens I
think that if you think about a cell
phone right I mean obviously there's a
collaborative effort involving a lot of
people that understand all sorts of
different aspects of Technology But
ultimately it has to be an idea someone
has to have the idea to come up the
original Motorola phone the [__]
brick and then they had the idea to
innovate and keep getting better and
better and these ideas eventually lead
to this thing that can open your car
door turn your lights on your house you
can FaceTime your kids it's a crazy
crazy crazy thing and it's all coming
out of ideas where do they come from
that's the question the question is is
it an an inherent part of being a human
being because like all other aspects of
human beings we are not a single
organism we are a a biosphere the human
organism is essentially an ecosystem the
human organism has Untold
trillions of of of bacteria in our gut
right we have it on our skin we have all
sorts of weird life forms that we live
synergistically in this space as a
person why wouldn't we think ideas would
be a part of that yeah right they might
very well be a part of that and the
healthier your mind is the more you're
able to live with ideas the more you're
able to bounce ideas around like ideas
as a life form just like the health like
if you use antibacterial soap all over
your body all the time you get sick
right you get [__] rashes and [__]
because your body it kills all the good
bacteria
too yeah it's like man I I the I loved
the question because like one of my
favorite acid trips was I was like
listening to Beethoven oh wow oh man and
I like I like some I don't know how it
happened but like I was like I I like
had a little like a this beautiful girl
she was so beautiful and like I was at
her house we're listening to Beethoven I
was tripping and I started thinking and
it was just like romantic and cool and
then but then I started thinking like
somebody thought of this and then I
started
thinking but where did it where did it
come from like if they thought of it
what was it before they thought of it
like this didn't exist before Beethoven
yeah so where was it and and I remember
that as I was like thinking that on on
the best still to this day the best acid
I ever had what's the difference I'm not
much of an acid connoisseur what's the
difference between really good acid and
mediocre acid it apparently it has
something to do with a mechanism of
production right the way it's yeah yeah
which is like listen to like kid
Charlamagne by Steely Dan it's all about
uh it's all about one of the great uh
Oley one of the great LSD kist of our
time uh who and I met his wife and I
asked her this question like why is some
why is acid not as good as it used to be
in the 60s and her response was people
aren't perfectionists anymore
honey
that was literally there we will sell no
wine before it's time yeah it was like I
don't I don't I don't know but well
that's you mean that's a thing that we
want with whiskey like that's one of the
things about Buffalo Trace who bottles
this stuff yeah they uh they taste
everything they taste and if it's not
good they don't they're connoisseurs so
that we want so I understand that you
would want that with acid the problem is
that acid's illegal that's the real
problem the problem is have some [__]
space Daddy some dude who's at the the
top of the [__] Helm of this
spaceship as it hurls through Infinity
Dy they they don't want you they have to
be space daddy if it's the president of
the United States that's space daddy
right the president of the United States
is space Daddy he is the [__] leader
of the the greatest army the world's
ever known he's at the Helm of the
global Empire he that's space Daddy and
he's we're going through space so if we
are a spaceship the president of the
United States is space Dy Captain Kirk
he has to be right yeah
yeah well it's not the space daddy
that's made LSD illegal what's made LSD
illegal was an earlier space daddy 1970
space Daddy they tried to disband the
Civil Rights Movement Yeah by making
drugs like all schedule one drugs yeah
that space daddy did it but but good the
good news is like uh they're they're at
least at the very least they're they're
letting people like look at how what it
is and like how it affects the brain and
they're beginning to understand that
there like everything we all
knew there's no point getting resentful
about it but we all knew this we all
knew this and but we're all like it's
being validated thank God and it's very
sweet because it's a it's a healing drug
especially when used in and with therapy
you know and uh it's healing it's a very
powerful beautiful wonderful thing that
exists on the planet that anyone could
have access to especially if they like
stop this ridiculous prohibition and and
and lifted the prohibition I'm not
saying like don't prohibit heroin
prohibit heroin prohibit methamphetamin
but even
even any prohibition the the problem is
I don't want anybody doing it but I
shouldn't be able to tell you not to
that's the problem that really is the
problem the problem is I shouldn't be
able to tell you not to that's right and
and certainly like because it's too
slippery but you shouldn't be able to
like there shouldn't be a fiveyear
mandatory minimum for LSD I mean that's
Madness no that's Madness and it and it
really does heal people it's a healing
look you do your own like your research
look into it have you read chaos the Tom
O'Neal book no oh my god dude one of my
favorite podcasts over the last year I
did was with Tom O'Neal and he's Greg
Fitz Simmons's neighbor he was Greg fit
Simmons's neighbor for like 20 years in
Venice and the whole time he was Greg's
neighbor he was working on this book Now
Greg never brings someone to me never
never says dude you got to have this guy
on a as a guest ever so out of all these
years Greg's like dude this guy you need
to have on this guy researched Charles
Manson for 20 [__] years he was
originally just writing an article he
was writing an article but as he's
writing this article he starts
uncovering more and more crazy [__] and
he goes deeper and deeper into this war
20 [__] years later he finally puts
out this book and this book is basically
detailing a CIA LSD operation where
Charles Manson was getting dosed in
prison allegedly and there was he was
being treated at this free clinic in Hay
Ashbury that ran for more than 50 years
and closed 3 months after the book was
released they ran this [__] free
clinic where they were dosing hippies
and they were testing them they ran
operation midnight climax it was all
part of MK Ultra he's detailing step by
step all these people that were directly
involved in not just Charles Manson but
in [__] Jack Ruby and all these other
political figures in history and it's
like what in the [__] all these mind
control C A LSD experiments that were
real and Charles Manson was a part of
that allegedly and Charles Manson was
dosing up these hippies and not taking
it himself he was using the techniques
that they allegedly used on him for like
seven years while he was in federal
penitenti what a mess this is the
problem with like anytime power you got
to read this book man I look I've look
I've read a lot about the M this one
crazy this one's different it's just
specifically what they did to allow
Manson to run free and build these
murderous hippies and get them high on
LSD this was all a part of this thing to
sort of demonize the anti-war movement
there was all these different strategies
the an M yeah cuz you take LSD and War
seems ridiculous you take LSD and money
seems ridiculous you take LSD and
anything that doesn't have to do with
love seems insane and the problem is is
like you know and this is you know all
the Psychedelic [__] aside if you
just look at like basic Buddhism
101 I was in some of the prior to this
pandemic my favorite conversations were
in Uber man and I'm writing this Uber
and this Uber driver who's clearly a
Buddhist he's got a Buddhist a Buddhist
statue on his like dashboard and like so
we started talking about
Buddhism and we're talking about it and
he said the coolest thing I've ever
heard regarding Buddhism which is he's
like do you know how you look at
letters and they you think that they're
a
language what are you before
that it's so cool holy [__] yeah yeah
thank God there's people like that in
the world I know well that's a true
Buddhist that's a true missionary but
but in that in LSD will return you to
that state so it will drop you under all
of your apps that are running on the
operating system of your Consciousness
for a little bit some people hate that
because they've like so identified with
the apps that the moment they can't like
cling to the app that they become this
like you know thing before the language
which is why some people on a lot of
asset can't even they can't talk they
talk like babies yeah but but what's
happening is you're encountering like
original sentients prior to conditioning
and that's dangerous to uh um any kind
of power structure like if I'm trying to
implement a hierarchy I depend on your
Consciousness flowing into these
rivulets that are language morality
ethics the entire structure of whatever
I'm like trying to like tell you is the
way things are and if I can do that then
I can own you because suddenly your
morality isn't real morality your ethics
aren't real ethics your idea of what's
right isn't necessarily what's right
it's what's right for capitalism what's
right for communism what's right for
this or that if I can tell you if I can
make your moral compass point away from
service in any way shape or form I can
control you forever and so anything that
gets in the way of that is really like
generally like delegitimate I by power
structures I mean it makes sense well
the problem is you're dealing with we
there's a a combination of
morality and a game and the game is
trying to make money like when you have
numbers you know I'm reading this book
right now I'm listening to it on tape um
it's called Uh irresistible and I keep
forgetting this dude's name who uh who
wrote the book but I'm listening to it
on audio book it's uh Adam
alter and it's all about addictions and
it's all about particularly how
addictive games are insanely addictive
like games like Tetris and Candy Crush
insanely addictive where they've made
billions and billions of dollars on
Candy Crush it's crazy people can't put
it down like Farmland made [__]
unbelievable amounts of money There's
Something About Numbers like you see you
look at your bank account you go I've
got $155,000 in the bank I can't believe
this that's pretty [__] good I
remember when I was broke and then you
go you know what it would be great if I
had 50 I'd just like to get 20 this year
I'm just going to cut back on going out
to eat I'm going to do that I'm going to
put five away and then you're like you
know what I need to make more that's
what I need to do I need to make more
money I want to put in some overtime I'm
G to talk to the boss I'm gonna lick I'm
dedicated I don't give a [__] a lot of
people get tired I don't get tired dude
I am dedicated to this [__] job and I
want to move up in this company and the
boss is like yes come on aboard slave
man you're going to work for the
corporation 18 hours a day great you're
you're you're getting paid well don't
get me wrong you're not really a slave
but what you are is a slave to your own
idea of what success is
you got you're a slave to these the idea
that numbers equate success yeah you
don't notice man you don't notice you
don't notice you get used to everywhere
you live it's nice if you live in a
place that's safe after that you I'm
telling you you don't notice you know
what you notice you notice when your
friends are around you and you're
enjoying each other's company and you're
laughing and having fun you notice those
things you notice if you do something
and people enjoy it you notice if you
you have a good interaction action with
someone at a store like they go no you
and then you go no you and then you're
both smiling and laughing and
everybody's you're you're having that's
those are nice moments man we have those
we still have those like you let
somebody in front of you and they give
you the PE on you give them the thumbs
up and these moments are still here man
they're more than they're not it's not
like everybody just stabbing everybody
everywhere you look most of the
interactions that people have with each
other all over the place are positive
that's right it's a very small amount
the problem is these small amounts
making on [__] YouTube and then
that's all I can watch there you go I
just watch these [__] people in
Portland beat the [__] out of each other
and kick some guy in the head when he's
sitting on his he's sitting down when he
apparently drove too close to these
antifa guys and they made him get out of
the car and they're searching his
belongings this guy runs up behind him
and kicks him in the head and knocks him
unconscious horrible and I'm like God
damn it but it's not most people most of
the time and the problem is that's what
everybody's going to pay attention to
that's what everybody's going to share
on Facebook and Instagram I saw that
[__] video video in my timeline like
30 times but this is what I love about
humanity is like if you strip away the
story and you see a person getting
kicked in the head honestly man like I
don't care like in general like I don't
care what that guy is don't kick him in
the head here's the problem dude is a
natural inclination to want to fight the
opposite of your tribe yeah and when
you're 16 years old or however old that
kid well the kid who kicked that guy in
the head he looked young to me I could
have easily done that when I was 16
easily I was so dumb if I was in the
streets at 16 he was Dumb and we pulled
some guy out of his car that someone
said tried to run us over and the guy's
sitting there easily me or any of the
people I hung out with would have
punched that guy or kicked that guy
that's the compassion that's normal it's
normal the problem is the tribal war
that we have going on that's the problem
that's but what you just said that's the
truth that's the truth and it's
compassionate this this is a stupid kid
he was a [__] I think he worked at
the airport whatever the [__] he was
this is a stupid kid and and and what he
did is wrong he got caught up in the
wave of violence the mob mentality it's
normal we have to figure out listen man
here here's the thing we must discover
you're not first of all you're not going
to find this on the map I like going off
the map but there's not a map for this
so that's deliberating to me we got to
get off the map number one we got to get
off the map like first everyone this is
what's so crazy people are really
legitimately tuning into like the like
human trafficking in the United States
it's a big business it's one of the
biggest businesses actually human
trafficking yeah I was reading a post
today that somebody sent me and I don't
know if it's verified or real or
whatever where a girl was saying that
she was headed to a a bathroom at a uh
gas station somewhere and uh someone she
noticed that someone was had their
camera turned around so they like had
the selfie camera on where they're on
FaceTime and they pointed to this lady
and they said what about her she she
heard her say what about her do you like
her and the girl looked at them and and
the lady turned and looked at her and
she ran back to her car got in their car
and the guy who was with them went and
ran up to the side of the car like she
thinks they were trying to kidnap her
100% they were and that that happens
that happens that happens that's a real
business this is not like this is not a
a [__] story this is not a magazine
article where people are you know
someone wrote some fiction this is right
and the funny thing not funny but what
what's ironic about the sudden horror at
human trafficking is a lot of the very
same people who are fighting against
this thing that they're they're
realizing is happening in the country
simultaneously don't want to look back
into the history of the United States
which was 100% based on human
trafficking 100% our country 's
Foundation is human trafficking they
[__] kidnapped black people and made
them work for free and somewhere in
between that horror and now people have
gotten this delusion that that stopped
it didn't stop our country is was
literally founded George Washington did
you know this was the number one slave
holder in uh Virginia wherever the [__]
he was he was the number one slave
supposedly his wooden teeth thing it was
slave teeth yeah he was the number one
slaveholder did he have wooden gums is
that what it was I don't the whole
wooden tee thing was a replacement of
the truth which is this [__] was
a human trafficker so people try to like
they try to revise so the idea is like
you know let's look at this look at this
Washington's Dentures were likely
sourced from the teeth of slaves sourced
there you go they're going to say
sourced that wasn't sourc they were
ripped out of the [__] mouth of human
hostages don't say sourced I Source
avocados to my [__] Mexican
restaurant I don't Source teeth
[__] why would you use that
language why would you use that language
yeah it's not Source go back to that
Jamie can I read the rest of it um
records at Mount Vernon show that he
bought teeth from slaves bought them but
that's
Records who knows if the slaves actually
got the money the poor enslaved had been
selling teeth as a means of making money
since the Middle Ages which were sold
Dentures or implants to those of
financial means either way man so so you
know Jeffrey Epstein J Jeffrey Epstein
Source teeth from some of the young
girls he was [__] and it was actually
common for the young girls to sell their
teeth for money like it's it that that
right there that right there is the root
of the [__] problem which is like
this country George Washington was a
human trafficker who had in his mouth
the teeth of people that were kidnapped
he was making work for free this makes
dmer look like a [__] Boy Scout can
you imagine if look at this
quote according to George Washington's
Ledger on May 8th
1784 he paid 62 shillings to Negroes for
nine teeth on account of Dr Le Moine so
he paid six pounds two Shillings I don't
know how much that is who cares for nine
teeth
so this
says does this say he's paying it to the
slaves it actually says they don't know
if they were slaves or not probably paid
it to the doctor to extract it Jesus
Christ but it wasn't what but so there
were free black men that lived in
America but how what was the percentage
versus slaves and free men who cares the
main thing is this [__] who's in
statues everywhere was a kidnapper who
like took teeth out of people's mouths
and put it in his own mouth that's
[__] up and so like Well everybody's
[__] up in our all of our all of our
holidays like Columbus was one of the
worst people of all time yeah so this
whole like when people are defending the
statues it's like shut the [__] up but
here's the thing man should you allow
people to just pull down the statues
really yep what do you think because do
you think here's what I think what if
there were Jeffrey dmer statues all over
La no you make a good point but what
maybe we should educate people on why
you feel so strongly about like the
George Washington statute or even the
Thomas Jefferson statue a lot of people
are arguing that Thomas Jefferson that
you know he he's a piece of [__] and we
shouldn't respect him
either how do you do you think that all
those statues should come down or do you
think it's more of an imperative for us
to understand
that in the world of 1776 or in the
world of whenever when did Washington
get here
what was George Washington's first years
in
America I'm not in any way shape or form
giving anyone a free pass on owning
slaves I don't think anybody that that's
all what I'm saying anybody who thinks
that about but what I am saying is I
think human
beings up until he was born in Virginia
oh he was born in America George
Wasington one of the first Real
Americans Jeffrey D one of [__] it I'm
getting a George Washington tattoo Joe
I'm in I'm in what's wrong with you he's
American no look can I the statue
question this is what I think okay
either take the statue down or put
around it the number of slaves he had
build statues for all the slaves he had
so if George Washington had 4,000 slaves
there needs to be a field of slave
statues around the George Washington
statue that you have to walk through to
get to to the George Washington statue
or just pull it down CU you know what
it's easier to pull it down no no no no
no you're right though have the slaves
and have some of them missing teeth
because they sold it to him because they
need we'd have to find out if you really
bought teeth from slaves or if it's just
regular folks needed money just have the
whole story there like that's all just
have the whole story so people realize
what's what you're saying is perfect
like if you're going to have a guy who
victimized I mean everybody did it back
then everybody of wealth did it it was a
normal thing to do to have people that
you owned as crazy as that sounds to us
dude I think that the world before mass
communication before the post office and
certainly before any kind of uh boat
travel when when everyone was just
either on foot or on horses was
[Music]
undeniably impossible for us to
understand because they were so Savage
there was very few rules people were
just dying of syphilis and every other
[__] disease that came around the
bend whether it was the flu or the
plague there was no sanitation everyone
was a rapist it was just a a a a wild
barely human thing that occasionally
paint cool things and write things down
and compose music but lived in a Savage
environment that's almost unrecognizable
for us today I don't look I and again
man like I'm presenting a Counterpoint
to you that I I don't want people to
pray upon me for the Counterpoint saying
oh woke Doug it had a baby got all woke
but like but I do want to present a
CounterPoint in the in in with the
intention of like let's look at like
that the maybe that is actually part of
the conditioning which is like if if
like so if your country is based on
human trafficking which to this day is
happening well this country is based on
human trafficking this country is based
on and it's also based on human
sacrifice in the it's also based on us
killing the people that were here first
that's right and we've been at War for
92% of our history and many of those
Wars are based on nothing so you know
people are up in arms about the Bohemian
Grove but it's like give me a [__]
break look atam that's human sacrifice
there was money to be made from killing
people and they made money so we have a
country that's based on human
trafficking and Human Sacrifice nobody
wants to talk about it the idea is the
exact same thing that all abusers do to
people they've abused they want you to
number one forget it and if you start
remembering it they tell you you're
crazy or that you're [__] up so the
idea is that like the world prior to the
United States was a Savage World Savage
Africa was not Savage these were very
Advanced people but because like the
Europeans were were Savage we brutal
people they went in there and [__]
just started chopping people up these
are people who had a natural innate
trust for other humans and they were
like put your hand out slap go get some
gold or I'll cut your other one off
that's what they did when they came here
to North America right it was Hills Have
Eyes level so The Hills Have Eyes roll
into all indigenous cultures they're in
tuned with the earth when [__] gets
weird they move look I'm not but but
here's the thing I've been spending the
last six months deeply engrossed in
Native American books and they weren't
that nice not at all dude they ate each
other the Nez purse were like practicing
cannibals yeah the nzp Indians were
practicing cannibals listen man the
commes killed everybody they were bral
they killed everybody they killed each
other they killed Native Americans they
would their main thing was raiding
they'd raid tribes and steal and kill
and murder and rape the idea I've heard
and this may not be I I didn't look into
it and I I apologize to the people who
told me about this idea because I wish
i' I'd researched it more but I'm going
to put it out there is that Africa was a
was a really ancient culture that was
dude Africa is where Egypt is
EXA that's people don't recognize people
were sending people there to get
educated before slavery even
started before they burned the Library
of Alexandria that was the place where
everybody would go to learn things yes
and so we [__] went in there and just
re Havoc not us it wasn't us we can't
say we I'm sorry from North Carolina
love that I burped right I was born in
New Jersey we can't say we we made you
made a very profound point and I burped
no but we didn't do it no I don't I
don't I don't mean we I don't mean we
and I'm not saying like I'm directly
connected I'm just saying like for me
it's like the anytime I get around any
situation where someone is making it so
I can't say the truth right I get really
annoyed yes yes which is why you're
comic it freaks me out yes and it freaks
me out and so the reason that the whole
like the whatever the particular
movement is like when Trump is it like
the Mount Rushmore and that's Lota right
that's like sacred land that's like
sacred land but like they went in there
and they chopped up a mountain with a
bunch of SLA like slave owner faces and
Trump's like it's the best mountain on
Earth it's like it look better before
you put the human traffickers on it
right how about the [__] hilarity of
him suggesting that his face should be
on it just to R people up yeah there's
some part of you as a comic that has to
appreciate that I'm sorry Joe I'm going
to admit that's true
when I when I when I saw that he was
suggesting that his name should be on
Mount Everest I or not at Mount Everest
Mount Rushmore I was I was thinking
immediately like oh my God he's he's
he's moving them into Checkmate dude
look at my [__] Twitter I've been
like seven different personalities
designed to rile people up over the last
month that's all you do with this q and
on thing Jamie was hoping you would come
in as your q and on
character it's fine look no but like
does that should that person be
president no but listen but that's
hilarious when in this madness with all
this crazy there's no such thing as
gender world for a guy to come around
and say I'm going to put my face on
Mount Rushmore like this this part of
that that I like well listen I'm to be
honest I'm not a fan of his lack of
empathy that's what beautiful that's
what's beautiful about you is you're not
afraid to admit something that I think
is really important to admit which is
like dude there are like there are
there's a Continuum of reality and
there's swaths of that Continuum that
are amazing like I don't know if you've
ever been in in a situation where like
maybe you're in a kind of like
relationship that's not great but
there's a piece of that relationship
that is so [__] hot and so sexy and
so beautiful in the midst of all the
madness that it almost like makes the
madness makes sense right that's a
that's a or or certainly like there's
certain like sub subance as I embibe
that if you look at what they do to my
body it's like terrible but like that
sliver of whatever it is is great so
anyway what I love that you're not
afraid of doing is like putting out
there like look
man it's not like people are one thing
but here's the thing too I'm not a
willing victim of gaslighting you can't
you can't do that to me right I'm not
interested you know I don't need
anything from you I'm not interested in
you gaslighting me I know when someone's
putting on a show I had an email from a
guy who I like who told me to stop
talking about Joe Biden because all the
problems are because he has a stutter
and I'm like listen man when you're
74 or however old he is he's older than
that right the wheels come off man on
everybody right I I don't feel as sharp
at 53 as I did at 33 how about that yeah
the reality is there's days if I'm not
on top of my [__] game I get real
Spacey yeah what happens in 25 years
come on man are we pretending that we
live forever you we need young vibrant
robust people with a lot of
energy who but who are also Advanced
thinkers and right now they don't have
any one of those people in the race we
got craziness in the race well no no you
know man like the thing with Biden is
like forget about B like the pro like
I'm voting for [__] Biden you going
suck my dick I'm voting for Biden do we
have to do that are you going to do it
anyway not suck your dick and why can't
I get a [__] on top of it seems
greedy it would be nice look I'm sorry
to be aggressive man this this liquor
like it's bringing out something bad
that's what I love about whiskey
Whiskey's been responsible for some of
my favorite conversations look man shout
out to Buffalo Trace I like the reality
of the situation is like Biden I I don't
like his policy regarding drugs and I'm
very resentful of a lot of the things
he's done and I'm also very resentful of
the fact that that that's what I'm like
being that's the the binary that I'm
being forced to like contend with here
that's the resentment right is that we
only have these two sanction choices and
if you're a good person who doesn't want
people to die in the streets you you
have to vote blue that's it period
that's it in the initial phases of it
when I was trying to like I was hoping
Bernie would be the [__] front runner
and I'm like I [__] Bernie up dude
Bernie got attached to some jokes what
do you mean I Bernie came on my podcast
and he I I I did a very lukewarm
endorsement of Bernie like I can't do
stand up right now so I'll just tell you
this Bernie did this very lukewarm I I
did a lukew I said I'll probably vote I
had my friend Barry Weiss on from The
New York Times and she said who are you
gonna vote for I said I'll probably vote
for Bernie I said he makes sense I like
what he stands for the guy's been Rock
Solid his whole life he's always
believing like we it would be good to
have a change where someone gets into
office we go this guy really believes in
Justice he's not greedy he's not
beholding the corporations well they ran
with that and then all these people that
were in competition with Bernie started
pulling [__] that I've said on the
podcast drunk high as [__] stand up
comedy put it in cont put it in in
quotes I remember that and uh there was
one of them I read this article that was
like on a real a real newspaper
um where uh in quotes it said he
believes that lesbians lack the lower
back muscles to [__] a woman correctly
what this is a piece of my act it was a
bit it was a bit about a conversation
that I had at a bar I was with a friend
of mine at a bar and there's this lady
who's really aggressive who's making out
with her girlfriend and she yells over
it at us she goes sorry boys she only
likes girls and I got my own dick she
says this to us yeah so I go where is it
and she goes it's a strap on and I said
having a strap on thinking it's a dick
is like having a lighter and thinking
you're a dragon plus everyone knows that
lesbians lack the proper lower black
muscles to [__] a woman correctly it was
like I was in this sparring match this
verbal sparring match with this crazy
lady that's what I said you can't just
take that part out and put it in quotes
and say what really believe that
lesbians lack the proper lower back
muscles to be in a loving relationship
with another woman who's also a lesbian
that's not what I said [__] I can't
trust you on anything how am I going to
trust you with Russia or climate change
or anything will you lie about jokes
right because you they didn't want a guy
who wasn't beholden to the system so
there was two people that I was
interested in Tulsi gabard who's a she's
been a congresswoman for six years I
love her she's she served overseas twice
Rock Solid she's a real leader and they
didn't want to have nothing to do with
her you know T plant the Hari krishna's
sing to good I hope they get in let's
give it a chance May they're right they
seen those harras I I I I mean I'm like
really eating my ass here cuz like there
was a period where I'm like you know
what [__] this I'm not going to let the
[__] Democratic party shove this
[__] who's like was like Pro all
these what happens if he dies kamla
becomes president and then does she have
to get a new vice president who does she
get as a vice pres to get a vice
president she get AOC cuz you don't have
to be a certain you don't have to be a
certain age to be vice president AOC I
don't give a [__] what anybody says
about her she's wonderful I love her
she's awesome eat me alive I don't care
look at me who cares I I think she's
awesome I love her so much and and I'm
going to get [__] for it too but I think
the errors that she makes she makes
because she has this idea that she's
trying to do good I really believe that
she's also 30 yeah how [__] dumb were
you when you were 30 you know one of the
things about Bridget fety who's
hilarious Bridget fety is amazing what
what happened here have to be 35 to be
vice president just like sorry hang in
there in the wings baby will vote for
you pick you up in term two I will vote
for you I think she's trying to do good
but Bridget fety who's one of my
favorite people to to talk to she said
that when she read a diary that she
wrote or a journal that she wrote when
she was 24 she's like Jesus Christ I was
AOC and now she's like much more of a
Centrist in fact like she's like always
mocking woke [__] you know and she's
like but I was like fullon woke when I
was 24 get it it's a thing of a person
being a good person who's compassionate
who wants to do good for people who
thinks they're moving in the right
direction but the problem is it's not in
align with the understanding that we
have currently of psychology and of how
people behave and of of laws and the the
the idea of punishment and crime like
you have to have some of that stuff you
have to have incentives for people to do
well but you also have to have
disincentives for them they have to be
punished if they commit crimes you have
to have Law and Order but you have to
have compassion you have to have good
will but you have to have you have to
have law you have you have to model it
on good parenting man it's like yes
that's
what that's where it's and and also good
Community I think parenting is one
aspect of your your ability to develop
growing up you like neighbors are
important too man friends absolutely
uncles all those people are important in
your life the aunts you know everybody
your grandparents there they're import
there's a lot of [__] going on there
input coming into a person I just love
like thinking like what's outside of
propaganda parenting it isn't outside of
propaganda but you can look like as a
parent I can see like look it doesn't
matter what my ideals are regarding
regulation Forest is not going to be
allowed yeah to go into the pool unless
I'm there with him 100% he'll die he'll
die so there's like real like there's
like a a true like to me there's a an
eternal sort of path in in like looking
at what good parenting is across cultur
cultures and you realize like you know
you're an idiot if you think that people
in the vast number of humans on Earth if
you think that people in that vast
number aren't insane like what
percentage are insane like well you're
insane everybody's insane what isane
that's the problem like what by what is
that metric you know a [__] yard is 3
ft saying I'm talking like like people
who are like registered sex offenders or
you know what I mean like that that like
pathos like true narcissist true
sociopaths like we live in a world where
from time to time but it's still a
spectrum right cuz like what if
someone's saying but they're a gambling
addict and they keep losing all their
families money every year on poker games
right we got to figure out a way to help
them without simultaneously creating
tyranny have you [__] with ibaan no I
don't want it man I'm terrified of that
[__] I haven't [__] with iasa I smoke
DMT from time to time but I'm scared of
a 6-h hour DMT trip much less IA gain
freak have you done IA gain no I don't
have any like uh physical addictions
that I'm trying to kick or real uh
personal addictions I've kind of got
those things dialed in in terms of my
workout and you know work schedule and
Family schedule it's pretty good right
now I got a good Harmony I got a good
Rhythm and I'm going to keep that up
yeah but um people that I know that have
really needed it or people that got hurt
and then they got uh prescribed pain
pills and the pain pill
is what got them I know quite a few
people that have turned to the Ia gain
two good friends that have turned to the
Ia gain and it knocked them right off uh
of the addiction and right back on path
and it's really disturbing to me because
it's not it it doesn't seem to be
killing people and it's not legal and uh
I think going forward in this country
we're going to have to come to grips
with a bunch of [__] one of the things
with is uh we've got and this is not a
bad thing okay if any company should
is allowed to donate to a political
candidate any company a [__] you know
any company Chocolate Company a company
that buy makes cars if then a drug
company probably should too if they're
allowed to sell drugs maybe they should
be allowed to to to to give money to
corporations or give money rather to
politicians that are running for
government why not why everybody can do
it who's to say they can't and the
[__] guys who make cars can when
they're polluting the air okay who knows
but at the end of the day we have to go
yo there's a lot of people getting
hooked on these pills yeah there's a lot
of people ruining their lives in these
pills and we're turning a blind eye
because there's a lot of money involved
in these pills and it's weird it's weird
it's weird like the cigarette thing it's
if we're so worried about 170,000 people
dying of covid why aren't we worried
about half a million dying from
cigarettes why aren't we worried about
all the people that not just dying but
losing their [__] their Sanity on
opioids how many people in this country
are hooked on [__] pain pills is it I
mean do we even know the real number cuz
how many people are functional where
they're hooked on it but they're just
like taking one or two a day and they're
just going to work every day and they
just stay in this steady Haze of [__]
working for [__] uh you know HTS rent
a car and they just deal and they got a
prescription so it's all good doctor
says hair Brave New World baby Brave New
World this is uh all this these are all
the things that I think of and I this is
it gives me a this is the perspective
that I have in this day and age right
now as I'm talking to you a place of
humility because I I I'm more aware now
than any other time in my life that no
one is in control of this thing and that
we all have to just stop thinking that
Daddy's going to rescue us that's right
CU there is no Daddy garcetti's not your
daddy Gavin Newsome's not your daddy
Donald Trump's not your daddy Nancy
Pelosi is not your mama none of these
things the these are just people and we
have to look at this in an objective
first of all anyone who's famous anyone
I don't care if you're Donald Trump or
Nancy Pelosi those are famous people
everybody knows their name everybody
knows what they look like that's a wild
way to live that's a wild crazy way to
live yeah that's a crazy way to live and
then you're out there also dictating
what people can and can't do and you're
also dictating where the taxes go you're
Auto you're not the idea is like by
becoming famous you become antithetical
to the very thing that you're
representing so how can you represent it
anymore if you have you I'm not saying
you can't but I'm saying that's a that's
a different ride that's a different
that's a different ride than a regular
person yeah if you're if you're a famous
person and you're all of a sudden at the
the Helm of an Empire that's dropping
drone bombs on people [__] you woo
shouldn't the greatest government be a
government that has an idea of
eventually there'll be no more
government there should be but then you
have [__] like 9/11 you go what happened
we get attacked if if we know but did we
I don't know I don't know what happened
what happened I don't know who trained
those people who designed that a lot of
things happen afterwards that people
will say did those things that happen
afterwards happen because and this is my
belief my belief is that all the things
that happened after 911 in terms of like
uh the Patriot Act and all these other
things they happened because people were
taking advantage of an opening where
they recognized that a lot of people
were scared and then they started
implementing these ideas that they would
love to do during peace time but they
would be accepted that's my the dogs of
war but this is my interpretation some
people are under the impression that
they actually orchestrated the event and
then afterwards implementing these new
rules and everybody went along with it
because the event they orchestrated now
I'm not saying I know that that's not
the case and this is what's the scariest
[__] thing to admit when you know
about operation Northwoods you know that
the government 1963 was literally
planning on blowing up a jet airliner
and blaming it on Cuba they were going
to arm Cuban friendlies and attack
Guantanamo Bay they're going to do
whatever they could to get us into a war
with Cuba this was signed by The Joint
Chiefs of Staff they're like I like it I
like deception I like what you're going
to do you're going to kill people woo
let's go to war baby go to war if they
did that in what was it 62 or
63 who who knows how that's evolved
right why why wouldn't that evolve
everything evolv evolves okay technology
evolves her understanding of uh bi
biology evolves everything evolves
everything evolves tell you know what
evolved what evolved was not the
technique what evolved was the story the
technique seems to be the same you look
at the news that Putin
opponent he [__] Keels over in an
airplane moaning all you had to drink
was tea the Kremlin apparently says we
wish him a speedy recovery and
everyone's like what the [__] and it's
like wait actually the use of poison and
imperialism is a pretty classic basic
technique like not just in Game of
Thrones but like in general if you're an
imperialist and your interest is like
power you you use whatever technique you
have to use to doesn't that technique
and using it in that way point to this
thing that we're really worried about
what we're really worried about is there
this there's this underlying narrative
that's going on where these Elites are
battling it out and these Warlords these
evil sociopaths that run the world are
battling it out all the well they don't
think they but they don't do it out they
don't just have a guy just [__] blow
his brains out on the airplane and then
just jump right off on the tarmac and
then he gets rescued by the Russian
police and then nobody says anything
about it ever no they do it in a weird
sneaky way where it's like there's some
plausible deniability involved right
well they for number one they don't
think they're evil Putin doesn't wake up
in the morning and look in the mirror
and go I'm an evil Jackal what are the
henchmen of the Apocalypse Putin
probably wakes up in the morning I
imagine he stretches he looks at his
phone he's got texts from his friends
he's like that [__] [__] that
[__] and then he like and then more
than likely he probably exercises and
then he go and he I bet a lot of times
Putin wakes up in the morning he's like
I don't want to go to work I bet a lot
of times he's like God damn it I just
want to [__] off all day then he has to
go to work he's stuck being Putin Trump
wakes up in the morning same problem
he's like this sucks he's drinking diet
coke watching Fox News promise you TW
out crazy [__] he wakes up in the
morning like takes whatever the [__]
drug he's on what do you think he's
taking dude I don't know want some of it
if he had a guess he's on some kind of
he's on amphetamin I would say I don't
know what it is but some sort of diet
pill was it ever confirmed that that
whole thing where they said they found
the very R Dwayne Reed Pharmacy in New
York City where he had been taking going
beat up somebody for being on drugs
listen to me man he's 74 he wins okay if
you can make that much money while
you're on amphetamines and you don't die
then they're right the doctors are right
the doctor likes it's safe he's like are
you sure I want to make money I want to
keep going I don't want to sleep like
just take this [__] you don't have to
sleep and he just keeps going he rattles
off [__] campaign speeches and hops
in a helicopter and flies a thousand
miles away find me a 70-year-old not on
drugs and I will give you a
$100
give me a [__] break you're 70 you're
going to die in like 20 you're going to
die like if when I'm 7 oh my mouth is
going to be like a baby bird underneath
any drugs that any wants to put in of
course we we're both high now yeah drugs
are fine like I don't care if Trump is
on drugs or Putin's on drugs or
whoever's on drugs it's like the point
is like the these the problem is that
like we like to imagine like Trump wakes
up in the morning and it's like let me
destroy this country Trump wakes up in
the morning in a haze he takes some
weird drugs he tries to remember what
he's doing I promise you every morning
he thinks to himself why the [__] did I
listen to my kid I guarantee it was this
kid he's like Dad you got to run for
president no he's like no no no no no no
you don't think you think he want I
don't think he wants to be president no
no
no it was Obama talking [__] about him
100% 100% when when Obama was doing that
dinner you know that uh that's that uh
that thing that they do every year where
they have comedians go what's it called
again Jamie the Press roast White House
correspondence Center yeah White House
correspondence Center and Donald Donald
Trump's in the audience and Barack
Obama's going deep and he's hitting it
with some bombs it was good it was good
and one of the things he hits him with
is here's one thing I am that you'll
never be president of the United States
and everybody goes oh it's like you know
that Meme with the kid in the hoodie
with the glasses and he's just standing
there all the other kids are running
around going oh he summ a demon can we
hear some of this or we get in trouble
it was a brutal resist is that like uh
public domain or anything I don't know
do you think he wrote it do you think he
wrote it I don't think he wrote it oh
sure he would write that because Trump
was a part of the birther moment but
here's the thing honestly
legitimately I hope he was born in Kenya
I hope they pulled it off cuz I don't
care cuz my grandparents are born in
Italy I don't give a [__]
I don't need you to be born this patch
of dirt you know why CU I'm not a
[__] idiot I don't think you should
have to be born on a patch of dirt look
should you be have to be born in uh
[__] Calabasas in order to be the
president of uh noou or whatever that's
a bad example but you have to live it's
a restaurant a sushi restaurant Malu do
you have to live like in the town like
what what are you saying the all the
patch of dirt is significant where was
you expelled out of the vagina I I moved
here when I was 13 minutes old is that
okay what if I what if I my mom shat me
out in the middle of a plane on the way
across the Pacific am I American who
cares it's stupid it's dumb it's [__]
dumb well it's that's like geospatial
centrism I hope he's born in Kenya I
hope I hope he admits it I hope he says
oh and by the way I was born in Kenya oh
[__] if Obama wanted to you know you
have that everybody has like one friend
like please come out come out of the
closet please please no one will no one
will care this is there's never been a
better time if OB I'm not saying Obama
was born in Kenya I believe everything
he says I believe he was born in Hawaii
but part of me wishes he was actually
born in Kenya and he waits until after
the election and if Biden wins he just
gets to the m by the way I was born in
Kenya oh and the whole audience just
goes B the Earth turns into a son
everything would erupt man I got to pee
I got to pee go pee but what are you
going to do when I go pee Jamie has
editing equipment oh right he's the
wizard don't take headphones off
headphones Don't Run Away you WRA behind
the back that was close I don't want it
to end we're not we don't have to end
okay great great there was one thing
that I wanted to make
sure um when we decided to go to Spotify
one the one of the first things I
thought of is Duncan trussle has to be
episode number one that was like a
legitimate thing I thought because
there's something about my relationship
with Duncan it's very unique like he
brings things out of me he he puts me in
a the when you're around certain friends
they put you in a state of mind that you
don't go into when you're not with them
when I'm with Joey Diaz one of the
things I love about Joey Diaz I'm always
smiling when I'm with Joey Diaz first of
all cuz he knows I love him I've I've
loved him forever we've been friends for
every every time I see him I hug him him
so because he knows I love him when
we're around he just starts talking [__]
he he gets loose cuz he knows that I'm
his number one
fan and
uh another person like that is Duncan
when I'm around Duncan there's something
like we do to each other like we're like
some sort of a weird epoxy where you mix
it together where he puts my mind in a
place that it doesn't ordinarily go to
automat like I think I genuinely believe
there's ideas that I form when I'm
talking to Duncan like ideas pop in my
head when I'm talking to him that they
don't get there anywhere else and it's
it kind of goes in with what we're
talking about about that other guy's
idea of uh thoughts and and my my
concept of ideas that maybe they're a
life form maybe they're just like eoli
that lives in your gut or the Flora
that's on your skin and that they
different people have different
combinations of those things just like
some people people you just don't Vibe
with them you talk to them you just want
to get away from them as quick as
possible you like oh this person's so
annoying and you can't help it for
whatever reason it's like they say that
women firmon wise like women can smell a
man's clothes and they can sort of I
don't know if this is true but I read
that they can accurately depict if they
smell a man's clothes whether or not
they uh should be attracted to that man
whether or not they're
genetically they they match up well with
that man but that gets [__] up when
they're on birth control yeah that's
when they're on birth control it gets
confused yeah it's well it's it's in sex
of daon but it was a real study and
there's a real uh concern about that
that people are you know you we're
losing some of our senses dude I was in
a relationship with a woman who got off
birth control and stop wanting to [__]
me and I remember like hearing that and
like being able to refer to the moment
that she seemed to be really into me but
then she got out of birth control and
suddenly her like real intuition was
like you don't want to make babies with
this guy this guy's [__] up and she
stopped She Stopped it was real like I
remember the moment it happened it was
so bizarre it was like it it was great
I'm glad by the way I'm glad cuz like
the baby that we made is so beautiful
and like have you heard this [__] about
the egg picks the sperm have you heard
about this how the egg does this is the
new research it's like you know as dudes
were always like well we make the come
and there's a sperm that makes it to the
end of the race and that's the one that
makes the baby so in our minds we're
like it's our it's like a sperm that won
a marathon gets into the egg as a reward
for winning the marathon but now the
idea is the egg actually is like the
sperm are running to the finish line and
the Egg sends out chemicals to
destabilize certain sperm and picks the
one that fits best with the the the the
whatever the plan of the egg is look at
that human eggs use chemical signals to
attract sperm humans spend a lot of time
and energy choosing their partner new
study by researchers from Stockholm
University and Manchester University NHS
Foundation trust shows that choosing
your partner continues even after sex
human eggs can choose sperm it's the
goddest baby dudes it's like the last
[__] Bastion we had was this idea
that we had this athletic little bit of
our come that made it it's really the
mother egg that picks it off come come
to me come to me and the rest back to
Mama it sends out signals to destroy
certain sperm trying to make that made
it all that way chosy eggs May pick
sperm for their genes defying Mel's law
we're we're done but then again the
sperm that get there those are still at
the front of the pack yeah like in Price
is Right they're the on most likely the
egg you know the eggs get like look I
want the best SPM but the best one's
going to be the one that's there first
anyway it's maybe it's both things it's
good it's sweet it's it's sweet it's
kind of both things right yeah but the
final decision is the egg [__] ass lazy
sperm that just bounces off the head of
the rugged sperm and like winds up plop
wow can't believe you chose me she like
I didn't [__] now I have a nerd and the
the egg gets really pissed because it's
not a precise mechanism there's a lot of
chaos going on to encourage you know
entropy and to encage Innovation that
they figure out how to better the better
uh version of the species to get into
the egg but sometimes there's a head
butt and then the dumb Dum goes right in
head first and bang you got a kid that's
not that bright you don't want that kid
but then that being said so those kids
are supposed to get eaten by Coyotes on
one level it's great because it says
actually the goddess chooses everything
but then on another level you've got
Hitler exactly so that Hitler's mom's
egg had a bunch of other sperm that were
like we're not doing a genocide and
what's the connection with what we
talked about before with
Hitler
amphetamines yeah Hitler was all about
they would inject Coke in him and
testosterone in him there's a legendary
story about how melini wanted to talk to
Hitler about pulling out of the war and
Hitler showed up shot up with cocaine
and testosterone and
just yeah I don't even musini know what
the [__] he was saying but he sweated on
him until musolini relented dude I don't
know if that's true McKenna used to talk
about alcohol in this way like the idea
like we survived alcohol just like the
well he talked about alcohol being the
differentiation between the ancient
psychedelic cultures they like uh chop
tall hi that worship the cattle which
like shat on the ground the mushrooms
grow from and they had all this mushroom
iconography to when they started
preserving things and preserving things
in Honey which meant fermented honey
which meant meat which meant alcohol and
then they switched to an alcohol-based
society when they couldn't grow the
mushrooms anymore because of climate
change or because they were moving and
moving in different directions this is
what I think happened this is where I
disagree with McKenna what I think first
of all how confident are you not that
confident the fact that you say I
disagree with McKenna I was about to
apologize to Dennis McKenna and say I
acknowledge I'm a complete dope well he
he disagrees with his brother sometimes
yeah but he disagrees in Le and
ethnobotanist disagrees with a scientist
not in the way some [__] guy somebody
literally goes at night goes to Red a
conspiracy and disagrees who literally
on a show called Joe Rogan questions
everything we investigated UFO materials
I'm sure like Stephen Hawking disagreed
with Albert Einstein you went to a
bunker to talk to a dude who's going to
start a cult and you're like hey you
guys grow
tomatoes no like I'm
I'm I remember coming back I'm like what
was that guy like like he was a really
nice
guy I'm like well kind a nice guy digs a
hole the side of a [__] mountain and
Parks his SUV this guy's crazy bro it's
so stupid to say I disagree with with
with like one of the great mods and I
acknowledge that uh but but uh you know
to me like this is where this is what I
picture happening so okay we're storing
our mushrooms in jars of alcohol right
we're storing our mushrooms in jars of
alcohol and the rich people the elites
eat the mushrooms they all trip out in
their little orgiastic [__] awesome
thing and then who's left the people
whose job it is to put the mushrooms and
the alcohol and what's left these jars
they have a little bit of booze in them
and some mushroom residue they drink it
and then they start you know like that
would be the beginning of like getting
[__] up on alcohol I I I guess what
I'm saying is like I I imagine that like
really like if you look at like okay
mushrooms or LSD or any psychedelic it
teaches you you're a we not an i you're
a we not a me and and and and booze what
does it teach you you're a me when
you're all pissed off on
booze 100% of the time you're not angry
because you're like worried about the
conditions of the world you're usually
angry cuz someone like what's funnier
than when you like insult an alcoholic
how many times You' been around like a
do have you ever heard of Alcoholics
feelings we you say to them hey you're
an alcoholic and you see that look in
their face where they recognize that
you're telling the truth yeah then it
really hurts yeah they get mad at you
yeah yeah dude I I like the alcoholic
outrage is one of the most like
desperately sad things to witness
there's nothing worse than a drunk whose
feelings are hurt because usually their
feelings are hurt because because you
told the truth too yeah yeah they don't
want the truth and so cuz their their
condition depends on lies so well it's a
weird um like one of the things about
alcohol it's like it sort of Narrows
reality yeah you know like if you think
of one of the things that I really
really enjoy about Edibles there's a
thing that I enjoy when I get so
paranoid and so freaked out that I don't
think I'm going to make it and then I
come down from that and I get to this
place of humility and that's one of my
favorite places to be as a person when
I'm coming down from like a horrendous
edible high and then all a sudden I'm
like real thankful that it's over I just
want to be friends with people yeah like
there there's that space and it it it
sort of bro like the world broadens your
danger broadens your humility your
Humanity your vulnerability
broadens and then it comes back to a
manageable level and you recognize that
it could be so far worse than what
you're experiencing currently and it's
just your perspective that's [__]
things up cuz right now with you and me
right here no people have ever been more
comfortable in the history of humanity
no we're both in love we both have
children we're both drunk and high we're
both love each other we're both making
each other laugh anybody in this
position that looks at things
incorrectly but like our our problem is
always perspective our problem is always
not
recognizing how good we have it when we
have it that's right dude this is like
there's a Buddhist teacher Jack corfield
who says tend to the part of the garden
you can touch and also choim
choe in one of his books one of the
things he said was look it could he and
he meant it it could be there's an ism
that's good there's an ism that's the
right way to be like it could be
socialism communism who knows Capital he
didn't say that but there could be an
ism that works right because we we can't
we can't accept the fact the isms of the
past are the only ones that are ever
going to be available that's crazy there
might be a utopian ideal that is
applicable to than now or just better
but what he said what I love about what
he said is it doesn't matter if you
can't find peace in your own home yes if
when you're in your own home there's
disharmony if you're in your own home
people are unhappy in your own home
people are freaked out then why would
you even think about socialism Capital
capitalism or communism when the when
the when the pixel of re of society is
the house the household
and if within that pixel there's
division then of course in the world
that division would be like made into
some monstrous thing so well even down
to the core to the singular you as a
human who are you okay yes do you have
your [__] together or no sometimes yes
sometimes no sometimes yes sometimes no
and everybody wants to point at people
who don't go look at you you don't have
your [__] together Duncan I know I know
you got three qus of your [__] together
that's not helping me get my [__]
together that with your white privilege
but I'm trying to be better I believe
you but you must be punished I'm not
sure for how long well that's aggression
silence I want Silence from you for an
extended period of time on the side give
the further the silence the more you're
going to appease people you can wait 10
years no one like four people be upset
look man 10 months all like to me like
it's like the whole that that whole ball
of wax man is like dude like after once
I started like the thing is like when
all this [__] happened and as a comedian
I was like really afraid to get into
like even like a little bit of studying
the [__] people are upset about cuz like
no like comedian in their right mind
wants to be identified with like some
woke ass comedian because it's
embarrassing but then when I started
looking into it and then I found out
about the George Washington [__] the
George Washington [__] is super creepy
creepy because there's no way if those
teeth were valuable that people weren't
murdered for their teeth that's it like
there's no way people weren't like just
held down and they got their teeth
stolen or they were told that they were
going to get money and they weren't and
they were many of them were have been
raped but here's the thing is there real
value in getting outraged at [__] that
happened hundreds of years ago or is it
is it a an acknowledgment of first of
all the fact that we all agree we do
better that's what the turmoil the
turmoil exists all of it social economic
the turmoil exists because we haven't
really come to grips with whether or not
we can all get together and be cool with
each other all the time yeah so there's
always some sort of turmoil and when you
look at turmoil in terms of like whether
it's Financial turmoil or social turmoil
we're always trying to figure out like
who's being the
[__] right don't you feel like that
like when you what do you mean when you
see anything that's happening like when
you see um when when when you when you
see uh a government getting overthrown
when you see War you always like who is
being the [__] any kind of turmoil
you mean you try to find the perpetrator
of
the difficulty right what's causing it
and is it possible that most of this
[__] could be avoided and what's
stopping most of it from being avoided
when you look at any kind of any kind of
government like any kind of country in
invade anytime a country invades another
country anytime bombs are being dropped
from drones like what can be done to
avoid this that's right what can be done
dude I man I I started this [__]
pandemic philosophy Club is what we call
it with like my friends Marcus and
Brandon what's up we don't even do a
podcast every Friday we just get
together and talk and uh they like
midnight gospel that's how I got lucky
enough to meet them Midnight gospel is
an amazing show dude can I just say
before we get going I'm really proud of
you really really proud of you cuz it
represents you as an artist more than
like almost anything any of my friends
who've ever done has done cuz you're so
weird and it's so weird but it's so
funny and it's so amazing it's amazing
they let us make it I can't believe they
let us make it praise Odin for Netflix
praise Odin praise Odin but what they've
done is amazing but what you've done is
somehow or another
encapsulate what some of the things I
love about you how weird you are how uh
you're not like anybody else when you
came here today one of the things I said
to you I go dude I go you're the only
guy that like I like listening to your
ads that's sweet Joe I do thanks your
[__] expressvpn ad is a hilarious ad
it took so long I didn't even know if it
was an ad just some crazy but you're the
best I you you are the the best that
I've ever seen at reading ads out of all
the people that I've ever heard who read
ads your ads are the most entertaining
you're very sweet Joe and I'm not going
to get in a a [__] competition
with you but I wouldn't be here if not
for you and that's the truth and I'll
never stop saying it and I will never
stop being grateful to you for but I
wouldn't I wouldn't be me if it wasn't
for my friendship with you either swe
it's true it's appr we all benefit each
other from yeah but I'm I don't mean to
cut you off I'm so sorry by the way I
had a a little bit of boost so forgive
my like impetuousness that I would like
suddenly interrupt you but you do have a
history of finding like young comedians
who are like and you do like help us a
lot and we are eternally grateful to you
and I don't care if you don't
acknowledge it you won't acknowledge it
because if you did you're afraid you'll
go crazy it's not that I want I'll I'll
tell you from my perspective it's not
that I'll go crazy it's that I have to
do it there's no ifans or butts it's a
path it's like if you're going down if
you're on a [__] uh one one of those
uh water slides and you're going flying
down you're just going that way if
you're a good person and you love and
you love Comedians and you have friends
and you want to see them happy and you
want to see them successful and you know
they're good and you know it benefits
not just them but you to elevate them
I'm like hey check out Annie Letterman
hey check out everybody whoever it is
it's like I want them to know that my
relationship with them anybody who's
listening to this podcast or anybody
listens to my standup or watches it it's
genuine that's who I am so if I find
someone who's awesome I want you know
about it I don't want to get paid for it
if I find a great band I start talking
about it on Instagram I find a great
application I tell people it's cool I
have the obligation this I didn't know
if I did or but I didn't I don't I don't
think I'm in a position that everybody's
in it's a weird spot and might I say I'm
so glad that Annie Letterman is someone
that you your attention is she is so
funny she's so funny her podcast is so
[__] funny I'm sure it is but dude
her and Whitney dude this is what
happened we were at The Comedy Store the
other night Mike binder Mike binder is
doing his uh his whole uh uh Showtime
documentary thing so we're all on the
roof it was fun man I got to chat with
Paul Rodriguez very cool dude I've
really never got a lot of time spending
uh talking to Paul rodrig before he's
really cool man he's really he had some
good good uh good stories about uh South
America and Latin America and Mexico
where comedians who actually got jailed
yeah really interesting [__] and Bill
bur was hilarious and Annie Letterman
was on fire and then there was Whitney
Cummings and Jay Leno and we had a good
[__] time man it was a real and Mike
binder it was a really good [__] time
it really was it was
um it was it first of all it reminded
me how much I love that place like I
walked in there I was like God
damn I got so emotional when I walked
through the door but when I had Whitney
and Annie together and they're talking
[__] to each other I'm like these girls
are so funny and they love each other
they're really good friends and and and
I said Whitney was scheduled to be on
the podcast and then I said to her I
said do you care if Annie comes I want
Annie to come but it's up to you she's
like [__] Yeah so I brought Annie in too
and the two of them together dude
they're Savages that's that's the future
of female comedy and the future of
podcasting because there's all these
like like that's a popular thing now
like guys we [__] they they're killing
it and then there's the call her daddy
that CHS killing it like they're on a
different vibration than you Duncan
Trussell but there a really popular sort
of segment yeah and these two girls
together two hilarious standup Comics
talking [__] together on a podcast I'm
like you guys have to do it but they're
also like you got to admit like they're
Gonzo like the Hunter Thompson thing
like they're full Gonzo both of them are
like terrifying in their own way like
you know what I mean like when you
encounter either of them I have to help
them right you have to have to help them
do a podcast it has to be Annie and
Whitney because the A's make you find it
quicker the world deserves it but like I
remember going to do any when I to be
Annie and Whitney when I went to do
Annie Letterman's podcast I won't give
anything away any what happened I'm not
I can't say it on it's not legal but
like I remember like leaving there being
like wow holy [__] like I remember
leaving there just thinking like H not
just that not whatever I'm saying right
now I'm saying like realizing
like I I've always loved chatting with
Annie letan we have great conversations
but I remember like getting into her
where she lived and looking around and
realizing like well she's formed some
kind of cult I don't know what it is
she's really funny man she's so funny
and and like that like just that moment
of like wow like you're you're
like both of them well that it's the
thing is is like like this uh
acknowledgement first of all you your
your podcast has a cult following and
you've hit this like weird place and I
think you feel very similar to the way I
do that when you find someone who's
extraordinary you want to let everybody
else know exact we we both have that we
all of us have that Joey has that Ari
has that Ari is one of the be if you're
AR's friend and you have a special
coming out Ari will promote the [__] out
of you he's amazing at that he did it
for Joe list he's done it for Mark
Norman he's helped get guys on my
podcast and I blow them up because if
you're friends with r you're friends
with me but we're all like that Diaz red
band's like that Tony hinch Cliff's like
that everybody will tell you all the
people around them that are killing it
and I think that's real important man I
think it's an important thing to get out
there there's a there's a frequency
there's a frequency that we're all
sending out and it's a frequency of
camaraderie you know of uh it doesn't
matter if you're wrong sometimes s or
just like sometimes you [__] up like
we're all like trying to go the right
direction you know when we're talking
about that dumb sperm that clashes heads
with the alpha sperm and just
accidentally slides in that [__] is
going to happen that's right all these
things are going to but we we have to
move forward in the spirit of
camaraderie and this is like the big
test let's can we for a second just draw
I don't care it's so cheesy and everyone
you've heard everyone's heard you talk
about the C store let's just spit a
second go with The Comedy Store man
because like for me and this is the
truth and like you know I was talking to
Ari he's like you never I'm like I I was
going up like twice a week but even if I
wasn't he said you never went no for a
second cuz he did you worked there dude
that's how we became friends I know but
from Ari saw me in a really dark period
where I was like not showing up for
spots and he rightfully judges me for
that but like it's okay I get was that
when you were living with me that was
after I was living with you I went
through a dark period I didn't take I
took it for GR granted and I deserve no
but I whatever is dunin you just always
been complicated that's it's not it's
not you're complicated you know I was
having a conversation with someone and
they were saying like uh it's okay to
have a loose chassis but you got to stay
on the road yeah I I try to stay on the
road man but I love The Comedy Store I
love it with all my heart dude when when
you and I became friends we should tell
people you and I became friends cuz I
would call into the comedy store and I
say hey I'm here uh Thursday Friday and
Saturday
and you be like cool man hey did you
[__] see this thing that they're
saying is happening in Nepal where all
these people are getting together and
they're all seeing these like we' have
these crazy conversations that go for
hours You' you You' put me on hold you
would take another call and then we
would talk about [__] Terrence
McKenna and Graham Hancock the best dude
we had we would get baked on the phone
where Duncan Trussell was a comedy store
employee and I was I was at home and and
we would get high and we would just
start talking about aliens it was the
best it was the best man that place is a
temple for real dude but you and I
became pen like phone Pals we but that's
how we got to be friends and like here
we are right now the funny thing is the
conversation we're having is no
different than the conversation we had
when I was working there but I was
saying to Jamie when you left and went
to pee the the people bring things out
of people and it's something that I
don't think people like to admit but
sometimes people bring bad things out of
people and sometimes people bring good
things out of people and when I'm with
you I'm different than when I'm not with
you yeah man I don't like I I really
don't want this conversation to end like
I'm not going to get all sapience in the
you fly to Austin occasionally I'll fly
any you want man I'll come I'll come
anytime you want but like it won't to me
it's like this is my solution to all
this I'm just going to fly people out
and put them up and pay for their food
it'll be great get them massages it'll
be great man but like all that being
said like we just I just don't I don't
think anyone can understand what it's
like unless they've been there to get
off stage at The Comedy
Store and you have a good set maybe but
you're working on a joke and you get off
stage and suddenly Whitney Cummings
who's like a very rightfully successful
brilliantly funny person stops you and
says hey what do you think about this
addition to your
punchline you know what I mean like
those moments are so so like so like cuz
CU in that moment there isn't like a
hierarchy like in that moment there
isn't like look I made like shows for
Network TV Dude one of my proudest
moments as a comic I was at the Improv
and this was like
200 [__] three or some [__] like that
and uh Louis CK sits in the back of the
room and takes notes and then we get off
stage and he actually asked me before he
goes do you mind if I watch and like
give you some like like give you some
notes I dude I'd [__] love that yeah
and then afterwards he had a bunch of
really funny suggest questions I don't
remember if I wind up using any of them
but it was just so fun so fun to hear
him and I talk about like bits and the
fact that he would like sit down and
watch these bits that's it that was the
that's the so to me like you know and I
like I would always tell Aaron my my
wife I would always say like you know
there's no Comedy Store anywhere else
like I I want to go I want to be here I
don't think it's impossible to make that
somewhere else this is the whole reason
why I'm interested in moving to Texas I
don't believe that we have to be
Tethered to this machine that makes
things that we don't do right this
machine makes music this machine makes
movies and it makes TV shows and we
don't do any of those things we're in a
totally different business and I don't
think we have to be connected to any
sort of Legacy entertainment structure
it doesn't make any sense and it's they
just trying to siphon money off of you
right it's just like they they're not
they're missing the point like I want to
tell the truth I don't want to just sell
things I want I want I want to say what
I'm thinking right now whether it's good
or bad or angry or sad or remorseful I
want to be able to say it anytime I want
to say it and this is not acceptable in
the the the the regular old school
Legacy medium that that that people are
thinking of as as mainstream media and
it was mainstream media like 20 years
ago or 30 years ago but what we're you
and I are doing right now is writing on
a [__] cave wall compared to what's
coming what you and I are doing right
now compared to what the [__] is going
to happen when Elon Musk starts
producing this whole neural link yeah
and then they they they develop some
sort of [__] uh satellite Network
where everyone's connected and reading
each other's minds all over the globe
dude this is cave wall scratch tickets
[__] I know and to me we playing
ticktock toe by the fire but this is
what's this is to me like the poignant
thing about like Neolithic structures is
like you see the Neolithic structure and
you know like [__] man people spent a
long time building that and in this in
the process of building that they became
friends and they shared stories and it
was really beautiful but now all we see
is some old eroded [__] that we don't
know anything about right yeah so to me
what's beautiful is like you are
absolutely right this thing we're doing
right now it's it doesn't matter if like
what we're doing is like moris code it's
going to be go it doesn't matter if it's
a million years but it won't be a
million years it be it won't be that
long before our conversation seem dated
but you know what we're doing also we're
doing the same thing that Beethoven was
doing where they were making music at a
time where you couldn't record it so you
had to write it down yeah we're doing
this some clunky ver like if you could
listen imagine if you could listen to
the actual orchestra that was playing
like Beethoven's Fifth Symphony sh
that's crazy you imagine
bro also being in
context never having heard the doors
never having heard hendri people cough
yeah right never having heard any of
that only being in that era wow and
sitting in the
audience be crazy is that b toan's fifth
did I make that up Jamie act like no no
I don't terrible impression it was like
who am I but think of how power being
there in the moment when it was first
released yeah and no one could record
anything and now you had write it you
had to write it down in some weird they
had to develop a language for music say
what it was yeah I mean you could be a
badass guitarist in 2020 and not have
any idea how to read music yeah that's
right right that's right you could like
watch videos and just decide I'm just
going to go full Stevie Rance some
people don't want to
know yeah they want to be able to just
free oh what's the earliest recording of
that is this hooked on can you play that
or we get in trouble see what Happ you
can't play
it that is it that's it right that's be
toan's fifth I mean bro imagine being
alive back then when you never heard any
[__] like that dude I was sitting in the
audience do you remember when Notorious
BIG IG big big IG biggie you remember
when Biggie came out with
hypnotized no do you remember how old
were you I don't know the year I don't
know hypnotized seems like 95 because I
was on uh I was on news
radio and uh I remember driving to work
what year 97 97 yeah so okay I was on
news radio from 94 to 99 so I was on
news radio and I remember driving to
work and hearing that going whoa they
just crack through some new level yeah
biggy biggy Biggie can't you see
sometimes your words they hypnotize me
great song oh my God but it was just
there was something about it where I was
like oh somebody figured out a new level
of the video game yeah they SP a ton of
money on of course you did dude you
don't understand what it was like back
then no internet you would see him on
MTV with piles of cash there was no
account ility that's so cool like this
is the like one like there's a a a
concept in Buddhism which is like if you
want to really has even started yet
that's
all just helicopters and [__] how many
helicopters do you need look at him look
at him biggy man do you know how many
[__] amazing songs we missed out on
because Biggie and Tupac didn't get
together and smoke pot how [__] that
have a couple of drinks like somebody
had them tricked that they were enemies
imagine if Biggie and Tupac was just
like me and Stan hope or Like Comics
Like Comics who just like like what the
[__] are we we we should love each other
we're the only ones that are like how
many goddamn MC's are there how many
rappers are there how many stand-ups are
there there's so few we should be so
happy we run it we
can't that's that kind of talk will get
you killed because that's the last
Bastion of the thing that wants to keep
us limited man it's like that's the idea
is like but even them man I'm telling
you for them they need to listen up
I know you want to have control but
sometimes not having control is better
like here's the thing in archery let me
tell you something about
archery there's a thing about archery
where it's very few people can what they
call command shoot what that means is
when you draw back the bow and you have
your finger on the trigger you just
decide when the arrow is going to go
okay sure most people don't do it that
way and most people who do these big
tournaments like even the Olympics they
teach them to have a surprise release
it's a psychological trick where you're
using a certain type of release where
either you have your finger on a trigger
and you don't push your finger you just
let your back muscles pull it because
they're crude muscles or you use what's
called a hinge you slowly pull in the
hinge and the the arrow goes but you
don't know when it's going to go whereas
a trigger you know exactly where it's
going to go but there's something about
knowing exactly where it's going to go
where you just [__] you tense up you
twitch and it's hard it's hard
you just goally if you're in a
tournament you're in the Olympics medal
round so very few people in the Olympics
allow their brain to decide when the
shot goes isn't that interesting yeah
yeah that's beautiful I get what you're
saying too there there's a the mind of
no mind the the ability to get out of
your own way and for Archers the best
way to do this is either in the hinge
release or a release with a thumb where
you pull through with your back muscles
and it makes the the thumb trigger go
off so cool this thing is dangerous this
thing's dangerous cuz you could be
develop what's called Target panic and
there's people that never like my friend
cam Haynes he's a freak of nature he's
never developed Target panic and he
shoots like this he sees things he
shoots at them and he's perfect he shoot
140 yards Boop pop balloons and [__] but
he also runs a marathon a day he's like
a freak of nature he's a very rare human
but you can't Bank it on those people
you got to think about the rest of the
folks for the rest of the folks the
whole idea is like getting rid of
anxiety
and what's anxiety anxiety is pulling a
trigger if you're in a gold medal round
I just hit that bull side this is it
America wins and you just Flinch there's
just a little a little thing that
happens to you that you don't want to
happen and your arrow just goes 4 in shy
mark it [__] love it yeah that's the so
that is the so like and I'm sorry every
every podcast I do with you I talk about
Buddhism but I don't care I want you to
talk about Buddhism thank you so like
what I love about it is like so
everybody gets caught up in the first
two ideas and Buddhism the first being
life is
unsatisfactory the second being the
reason life is unsatisfactory is because
you think it's a way that is not now
this gets translated in a lot of let's
break that down life is unsatisfactory
and the reason you think life is
unsatisfactory is because well life so
the the best way to put it would be have
you ever been with someone in traffic in
LA
and they're angry me okay but when have
you ever myself right but that's
literally the way traffic is in La yes
yet somehow like because you drove that
day into traffic you got into your head
this would be the one day in La where
there wouldn't be traffic no honestly I
keep it together but I do I do I
recognize that it's knocking on the door
it's like come on be a [__] freak out
yeah I really do keep it together but
that this is also the real argument for
micro doing because if you could just
micro do there would be so much less
negative interactions with people
whether it's on the highway or anywhere
no one's going to no one who's micro
doing on siloc cybin is going to yell at
you from across the street put your
[__] mask on no they're not going to
do that you're going to let them be
themselves but I want to be I want to be
the person that makes people smile I I
don't want to be the person that makes
people mad I don't either and and this
is something I'm like consciously
thinking about more and more as I get
older I I want I want us to do better I
like really do this is one of the
reasons why I have this idea of like
starting over in
Texas I have this idea of like this
connecting from all these old hubs and
this idea of what we're doing when we're
putting out content into the world I
don't believe it I don't believe it has
to be from a media center I don't
believe it has to be from New York or La
I don't believe it and I I think I want
to prove to myself that it doesn't have
to I want to go one of the reasons why I
wanted to go to Texas is cuz it's like
almost like there's a there's a certain
mockery to live in in Texas you know
listen especially for someone like me I
wouldn't want to be you like you you you
everything you do is too study didn't
and like I like like I like being free
of that magnifying lens but you know to
me like whenever I'm thinking about uh
like you know it's fun to think about
what's the root problem here the root
problem seems to be centralization it's
like wherever centralization rears its
head problems emerge the root problem is
compassion what do you mean the root
problem is compassion that we don't make
our decisions based on compassion we
make them based on beneficial markers of
improvement whether it's Financial
Improvement or land grabs or that's the
problem the problem is that we we we
have these things in our head where this
is what's the most most important and
this is what's not as important like
love is important but if you see two
people that are you know they're in love
but you don't like either one of them
you do you feel like that's the same
kind of love as two people you admire
that're together yeah right like how
many people who do you know like all
right I'll give you one I do lared
Hamilton and Gabrielle ree I'm friends
with those two people they're super
athletes she was a super athlete in
volleyball and he's like one of the the
greatest big wave surf the world's ever
known I'm friends with them and when I
talk to them if I talk to them either on
like we do a little fa we do a little
FaceTime the other day and and I get out
of it I go that I want to be somebody
who makes me feel or or I want to be
somebody who makes somebody feel the way
I feel when I talk to them that's cool
when I talk to those people I'm like
these are superior people like lared
Hamilton's a weird dude but he's also
like a superior human Who does these
crazy pool workouts with like 70 lb
dumbbells he gets in the [__] sa at
250° and rides an aird bike with oven Ms
on Jesus yeah they're freaks he wears
oven mitts cuz it burns his hand yes 250
250 you eat at some point he was like I
got to put on oven mitts but he doesn't
get out of
soda and I I said to myself when I got
off the phone with them the other day um
they're really nice people they're
really really they're genuine people and
this is one of the things that happens
and it's a weird thing that happens when
you become uh more and more famous you
get more and more comfortable talking to
other famous people you know see talk
talk to famous people and you realize oh
they have a hard time talking to people
because other people think they're weird
yeah so they have to find famous people
that are also nice right and so that's
how I feel about them so I get off the
phone with them and I'm like like you
can be you could be Gabriella AR and you
can be lared Hamilton and still come out
and be a really cool friendly
inspirational genuine person I'm like I
want to make somebody else feel the way
those people make me feel yeah man and
that's what I felt like I love that
that's the best thing we can do for each
other that's the answer and that's like
if if anything has ever coming out of
this podcast that's been good it's that
it's given people a perspective where
there's a potential where that maybe
they're limited ideas of what they're
capable of in terms of their own
personal happiness or their own success
and whatever their chosen Endeavor is
maybe it's not really limited maybe they
can just shift their Consciousness and
through effort and focus they can change
their Destiny maybe it's true well you
know the reason I say centralization is
because like the first a very natural
reaction to being associated with a body
would be that you would centralize on
the identity that you're in you know if
I step on your if I stomp on your foot
you're going to feel pain so why
wouldn't you centralize on this identity
that you're in so and again like right
now with the science we have it can't
show us what I think it will eventually
show that our sentience isn't limited
the to the body that we're a field of
Consciousness that's kind of getting
associated with like particular like
Quantum clouds of meat that we and they
interface with other sensient bodies in
a way that makes them unique to the
relationship between that person like I
bet you're different with your wife than
you are with anybody you've ever met
well that that is true and yes but
that's also like one of the great like
right now one of the big Ideas it's such
a cool idea too is like on stage
offstage so uh how are you acting when
you think you're on stage in other words
like when you're in front of like this
is the best part about Co there's no on
stage anymore exactly that's it but it's
the only good thing about Co for me well
there there's a actually I'll tell you
some other great things about Co it
taught us out that we can tell a
commutant businesses still work and that
CH transforms the landscape but like the
the the onstage offstage idea or or the
way like choim chime puts it is some
people at the end of the day they go
home and they sit on the couch and they
go and but they only let themselves do
that at the very end of the the day of
work because they've produced in their
mind a situation where this is me
relaxing and this is me working right
here I am with my family here I am with
my co-workers here I so this
differentiation produces a kind of
neurotic kind of uh like split
personality uh way of being which is
like really all those you don't need to
wait to get home to sit on the couch to
go that's where you're at now like
that's actually every single thing but
the story you're telling yourself
produces moments where this is a
relaxing time and this is a non-relaxing
time but it's just a story Joe that
that's the idea and like compassion is
like I think the the beginning of
recognizing like you know how many
people have you met I'm sure and I know
my life changed when I went to the
doctor with my swollen [__] testicle
that by the way before I went to the
doctor I would look at myself in the
mirror and think man if there were
symmetrical I would feel awesome like it
felt good to have a big ball there was
like I literally was like God damn it if
they were you were happy about the one
big ball it looked powerful I'm not
going to lie man have you ever seen Joey
Diaz's balls yeah like that like the way
Preposterous he feels like that every
day they don't even make sense so like
for a few months I Jamie have you seen
Joey's balls see if you can pull up the
picture of Joey on stage where he's
naked with a with a uh he had a um can't
show I know I know but just for me he
had a uh a safety pin and a towel around
his neck like a cape and this is for my
1999 Warner brother's CD called I'm
going to be dead someday we took these
crazy pictures in the main room at The
Comedy Store dude I was there you were
there for those The Matador outfit I was
like there was some drama about it that
you guys snuck in and took the pictures
were you working you work was a talent
coordinator you guys snuck in took the
pictures you didn't no we didn't snuck
in we had a we talked to whoever the
[__] it was was it was it Scot day or
tomm I'm sorry I feel like I was there
when I happed I could be wrong but I
remember the Matador pictures Warner
Brothers did it maybe I'm wrong made
calls no I remember thead door picture
was real I'm sorry but I remember a
moment that I was I think I was a talent
coordinator where suddenly Joey there's
pictures of Joey Diaz in a matador
outfit they the funniest thing you ever
seen But mity caught wind of it that's
what I remember is there was some drama
around the situation like the pictures
themselves were like not just funny they
were like kind of artistic they look
cool there's a picture of Joey and he
please someone find this
it's in I think I have the CD so I have
it if it's on the C it's on the CD so I
have it cuz I I you know when I'm moving
I'm going through my [__] and one of the
things I found is those old uh I'm going
to be dead someday CDs that's 99 I
became Joey Diaz uh associate and best
friend around 96 that's when I metad at
him so like could that when I was there
I just remember there was some drama no
you might have been there if you were
there in 99 I I you start working I
don't remember I don't remember the
exact day and again like I don't
remember I just remember there was some
drama around I think it was before your
time man I want to feel like it's before
your time dude it could easily be that
mity caught wind of the pictures late or
something you know it like it could
easily I just remember there was some
drama attached to the that lady was so
nice to me she loved you man she loved
Joey too she Lov both of us she had the
the the the funnest thing with like her
idea of us together she loved that we
were together that we were friends she
she was a wild she was a wild lady she
was wild dude that was a real Guru like
MIT Shore was an actual Guru yeah listen
man I I tell everybody if there's one
human being that's the most important
human being in comedy ever that wasn't a
comedian it's MSY Shore that's why she's
on the wall of this room she was a I'm
taking her with me man not only that the
movers don't take her I take her M mi's
coming with me on the plane yeah man she
was real listen that's coming with me on
the plane no [__] yeah like the
reason why that's up on the wall after
the movers have gone is that's coming
with
me that's mity yeah she gave me my my
future no she was wild she was a wild
she was a crazy lady she's a perfect
person to run The Comedy Store well no
she had to be that way you know you
could you can't make you can't have the
if you go through there's photos in the
album where you can see Joey with his uh
with a cape he had this uh
I oh godamn I know I can I know I have
it I know I have it somewhere I'll find
it it's on one of my folders you know
what was in her when you walk into her
house Joey Diaz Cape balls looking you
know you know what was in her house on
dhini when you walk into her house that
so on her house when you walk in the
first thing you see
is what do you call it when people sew
and they make art with sew crochet a
crocheted picture and on it it said
dying is easy comedy is
hard that's the first thing you said
eyes are yeah yeah and it like and it's
true and like that that was what
beautiful about her is she understood
how hard comedy was I told you the story
of her getting robbed right I told you
that story which story is that tell me
so like here's how cool she
was and I I can't remember the name of
the comic but she was giving him spots I
can't remember the name of the comic
this was in the early when it's better
you don't tell it's better I don't say
so this [__] needed money and he
robbed the van she was in the van like
apparently she he he like at
gunpoint took the cash earnings of the
of the
club at gunpoint like took the money
from her and she knew who it was somehow
she could tell somehow from The Mask he
didn't do good she just knew right and I
remember her saying like yeah he uh he
robbed me at gunpoint but he's funny but
he's
funny he that was her but that was her
like can you imag like if you really
think about it you get robbed at
gunpoint by a
comedian and you still give him stage
time
what the [__] is that well that's a
that's a guru that's a guru that's not a
h that's not a normal person anymore
that becomes like that I I've never had
that sort of an relationship with any
human ever you know I I sought her out
when I was living in Boston really yes
you knew about her dude when I was an
open micer okay I had gotten obsessed
with comedy for 6 months before I could
ever do it open mic night cuz I
erroneously assumed that you had to be
21 to be able to get on stage it turns
out you can be younger but you just
can't drink they watch you but you can
be a 19-year-old do stand up I didn't
know so August 27th
1988 when I turned 21 I went on stage
and when when I went on stage I remember
thinking I remember like really clearly
thinking like how weird is this job
there's a there's a bunch of people out
there that can just talk and they can
make a living yeah how weird is this job
what did you think the first time you
ever went on stage and you talked into a
microphone hello hi my name is Duncan
Trussell so
weird like when you look back at those
times like how do you feel you feel like
it's not even you I met that lady when I
met Mitsy Shore and when NY Shore passed
me at The Comedy Store I remember
thinking when I was in 1988 in Boston
that there was this Mecca there was this
place you had to go where Richard Pryor
filmed live at the sunset trip and Sam
Kennison used to stand up yeah and
[__] hoe Mandel went up and Rodney
Dangerfield and David
Letterman godamn I got to get to The
Comedy Store that's all they wanted to
do I didn't want to get anywhere else
there was one part of me that wanted to
go to Houston cuz I had heard that like
Sam kenneson did these wild shows in
Houston I want to go to Houston but the
the big thing for me was I got to get to
the store and when I got passed by that
lady dude you know it's one of the
reasons why I feel so compelled to help
people on this podcast it's cuz I feel
like when that lady passed me I was like
holy [__] like I'm a real comedian now
like I don't have to be scared I just
have to keep working I I got pasted
yeah by the Godmother the real godmother
yeah and like you worked for that lady
that's right you were there all the time
man I know can't go back she she made
us she she created an environment that
accelerated comedy yeah man she pushed
comedy cuz she kept it together but like
at the [__] highest RP like a 9,000
RPMs of the engines
going
she kept it together she let these
Comics be wild remember you remember
when Ari slapped Bobby Lee of course I
remember do you know that's when he
started getting
spots is that true yeah you know how I
know cuz I was jealous I was a talent
Ari like like I remember Ari's gradually
unraveling into his comedic self and
like I remember like Ari smacks Bobby
Lee I don't remember there's a fight
between Ari and Bobby Lee and I remember
as the talent coordinator that was when
Mitzy
start he's now a comic somewhere in that
like in that like throwing off of
rationality and that I don't know what
it was man like in you know you the
here's the most important part of mity
she was a woman she was a woman and she
encouraged chaos she wasn't in remotely
concerned with
safety she wanted wild people man she
wanted dude she wanted me to be wild
that's what she wanted she wanted wild
comedy she wanted Kennison she wanted
prior she wanted everyone that came in
between Damon way yeah man she wanted
she wanted wild she wanted Martin
Lawrence she wanted wild she yeah she
wasn't domestic MIT she was feral mity
was a feral lady Mitzy was a human I
mean that what we call human now people
think of as pharoh or what people no I
mean I mean but when I say pharoh I mean
exceptional she was wild she didn't have
anybody else's rules holding her back no
she didn't and she didn't [__] care
she didn't care she didn't care about
money she [__] you that's the most
important thing about her is like having
a club on the Sunset Strip and not
making decisions based on money yeah cuz
let me tell you man as a talent
coordinator there were plenty of times
where people wanted to film some [__] in
the main room where they wanted to pay a
lot of money and she' be like no get it
no tell them the [__] well we should
talk about that cuz that was like one of
the things about that club was that like
you could never film anything there no
that was one of the most amazing things
about Ari filming his special there it
was a really cool thing he did it was
also like an acknowledgement that the
world had changed and that was one of
the reasons why I was willing to come
back it's cuz Ari filmed his [__] yeah
in the O well she would have I I really
do believe she would have approved that
avenge sure but somebody would have got
involved they would have [__] it up
she would have made him jump through
some hoops it wouldn't have been that
easy like she would have made him do
some crazy and she's right here's the
thing she's right you know I didn't I
didn't cash any of my checks you
probably know
that oh I remember I don't like when I
was working at the store I just wouldn't
cash my checks and then at the they
would go hey we have like all this money
that you I just like can I donate it to
the sound system you bought the sound
system there I did that too but that was
that was extra that was on top of that
cuz the sound system was [__] up and
then you bought it and honestly mity
didn't want you to do that because like
that was the thing like she re she was
smart enough to know if I let a comedian
buy the sound system I can't like
honestly give them spots like so she I
knew that was the case but I was like at
this point she's giving me spots every
[__] weekend I just want to help out
let's not stop playing games like come
on you know what I'm doing I'm out here
doing my best stand up I can this we got
a [__] up speaker system let's fix it
I put I put a DAT system in there I put
a mini disc and I wanted to have it set
up so anybody could like if you had a
mini disc remember the mini disc days of
course dude it was so important before
smartphones to be able to record your
shows yeah it's so big and you don't
record and listen to all of them but the
option to be able to do that is so huge
even if you're not diligent you still
gain like 10 20 20% of like a tightening
of your act dude The Comedy Store at
that time for lack of a better word was
an art cult yeah that's what it was it
was a cult and like it was a cult that
was like for sure ba like all cult
systems are based on like a strong
charismatic central leader it was mity
but you know what as a man I was uh
happy to relent to MSY well yeah thing
but there was a thing for me as like
this macho man it was important it was
important to relent to mity you had to
but it wasn't just that I had to I
wanted to to
show respect to show that I I got it to
show that I know what you did yeah man
like that lady man when I was in [__]
Boston in ' 88 I would hear about
her she loved comedy one lady did this
like yeah she was married to a comedian
but it didn't work out and she's paully
Shore's mom and I would hear these
stories and I'd be like that's crazy
this one lady just figured it out and
she was wild and she liked the party and
she like man and she was just a wild
lady but she was brutal with you she
didn't like your comedy she would just
tell you you were done she would just
tell you if she thought you weren't
funny you were done dude she put her
hand on my wrist
she goes you're really funny and I'll
never forget
that it was like
1994 I was like oh my
god well she wouldn't hand that out
lightly man that was the thing is like
she was like that I've been around it
like so it's so weird I I'm so lucky
because I got to be around like Romos
and Mitsy Shore and like they're similar
in a way man yes they are similar yeah
the there's a there's a lot of
difference don't like this idea of what
we think of as perspect
perspective yeah
dude 1994 when I was six years into
comedy her putting her hand on my wrist
and telling me I'm really funny changed
my life look the to me the thing that
like will never be captured is that it's
not just that here you have this like
tiny woman who is tiny tiny
but it's not just that you have this
being I would be so careful when I would
hug her right remember hugging mity yeah
yeah well she was a gangster I mean that
was all like the thing about mity was
like no like imagine like the the best
thing to think of is like think of your
most like Outlaw
comedian then imagine a person who built
a saloon within which those comedians
could be grown to be more of an outlaw
there was no Kennison without MSY Shore
that's right but then the most to me
like with mity if you were G and she
would never allow this she'd already if
she heard me saying any of this [__]
she'd be like get
fired but like if you were going to
write a mity Bible that and you wanted
to like base the whole Bible on one
thing it was something she told me so
many times as a talent coordinator and I
liked to in fantasize she thought I was
funny but as a talent coordinator
something she told me over and over and
over again regarding
comedians
was
you don't need them they need
you that was her like core thing which
is like the moment that a comedian
starts thinking that they need the
system then they degrade themselves they
have to understand that their comedic
ability and who they are as that Persona
which she would say is like they're
iconic class she meant like you're not
going to find anyone like this ever
again and that's who she was trying to
find she would say therefore you it's
supply and demand which is like there is
nothing like you but there's a lot of
things like them so if you think that
you need them you will degrade yourself
as an artist that was her main core
truth which is don't get caught up in
the thing they're going to try to teach
you which is you need them you don't
need the manager you don't need the
agent you don't need the studio you
don't need anything cuz you're are funny
you're the [__] nuclear isotope
generating energy and if you get lost in
this Insanity that you require the
system to be great not only do you grade
yourself you to great in art but you
know this is one of the things about
recognizing what MIT Shore did and a lot
of Bud fredman a lot of people who own
clubs Rody Dangerfield yeah is it's not
just about the ideas and getting the
ideas out in a way the audience can
Digest
it's setting up a club it's bringing
people in it's setting a standard where
people know hey man David Letterman came
out of here Robin Williams came out of
here yeah okay Bill Hicks came out Bill
Hicks was a [__] door man here Sam
Kennison came out of here okay this is
the [__] Comedy Store there's a
standard and that's a factor too man you
can't let the
artists completely be in control because
one charismatic artist with a lot of
[__] song and dance moves can trick
people into thinking things that aren't
necessarily accurate because of Charisma
that's true man like that's she figured
that out though yeah and we need another
one of her man I mean like the thing
you're never going to get another mity
but we we can carry on her Legacy we we
we all learned from her you know and I
think she was uniquely
qualified to run the comedy store
because she wasn't a comic she had no no
desire to be a comic but she was married
to a comic and she knew exactly what
Comics were her son was a comic yeah she
knew exactly what Comics were and she
wasn't stupid she was smart and she was
she but she also didn't give a [__] like
there's a there's a rare group of people
that legitimately don't give a [__] if
Mitsy Shore was alive today if we could
somehow or another like go back in time
and grab Mitsy Shore from 1974 and bring
her to 2020 she would she would just be
running [__] she would just be running
[__] first of all she would have like a
hundred girls under contract for like
only fans
accounts she would just run people I'll
tell you the one time that part that
part's not true the only fans the only
fans I it's conjecture but I'll tell you
the one you have a problem with only
fans the porn site it's not a porn site
though it's like girls can do whatever
they
want I don't have a problem with sex
like I like I have a problem with my own
inability to like regulate my desire to
come but
like I can't get mad at the world for
that like that's had a conversation with
some with someone and they were saying
well also she has an only fan site I'm
like H if I had big tits I'd be like
getting paid for those big tits I'm so
tired of these sex negative [__] man
they ramped up when the lockdown though
cuz it became of course it should easy
job for a lot of people if I was 22 and
I had big tits
and I like to do squats and I was
sitting around thinking do I do I want
to work at Burger King or do I want to
shake my ass for 10 bucks a month for
35,000 guys
yeah it doesn't have to just be that
though either it's not just a porn St
you can do whatever you it's patreon for
you know this is madness so only
fans you can just do yoga but Joe in
like a dimension where like being funny
is getting people to come
you would be like the top porn star in
that Dimension it just that's a weird
one right like getting people to come is
so specific that's what's a big deal it
doesn't matter it shouldn't be a big
deal but yet it is like if you find out
that somebody came it's not a big deal
it shouldn't be but it is it is right
now cuz we're lunatics like we hate life
like we're in a exactly yeah we're we're
we're we're we're so death Centric that
like the anything that's the source of
life which is a hand job a blow job
[__] we look at that as like being
depraved you know well it's it's really
just some sort of weird Canyon ladder in
between two [__] Cliffs between this
and what is going to be available for
people in just a few years there's going
to be virtual sex you got to have Riley
Reed on man she's so great like I had
her on my fck you have her on and I'll
take my pants off what I'm going to do
is I she's so funny goggles on this this
is the future goggles you put goggles on
you lay back you're in another world
well yeah I mean that's heaven but like
but is
it yes no what's wrong with coming
because there's 1% of your brain that
knows it's [__] why there's no real
girl and they don't really like you and
your jokes suck and you kind of smell
and you didn't brush your teeth that
good yeah yeah but she's like I love
part of you no the girl oh no no no no
no if the girl really did love that part
of you that would be extraordinary see
that's the beauty of alcohol alcohol is
you're hanging out with a girl who's got
a like Hello Kitty tattoo in between
your thumb and forefinger and you guys
are drinking you're having a good time
and you're like I love you and she's
like I love you too and you just give
each other a hug it doesn't even have to
be sexual that's where alcohol comes in
where where what do you mean what do you
mean I'm following you in the the Hello
Kitty the where does that alcohol come
in that's where alcohol comes in and
like it allows you to take chances and
hope that the other person doesn't have
ulterior motives where you both release
your Ambitions and run let's go to Vegas
and get married I don't even know you
let's go
crazy how crazy is that we think
fucking's bad it's not that we think
fucking's
bad it's that we worry you [__] too many
people you got tricked too many times
you're like one of those people at one
of those David bla Street shows and
you're like it's got to be the queen of
hearts trust me isn't that wild it's
like it's the great it's one of the
great things it really is one of the
great things like think of like anytime
like you know why why because we're
concentrated more on Innovation and
progress in terms of numbers like but
earning
money and uh getting new projects pass
through they take precedent over every
everything else so sick it's weird but
it's just a it's a weird game this is
what I'm getting out of this book
irresistible it's like there's things
that we have in our head where we're
we're we have
these they're wrong we have these ideas
of what we need in order to be
sufficient like here's we're operating
from the wrong principles wait I'm sorry
Joe I got a I've been holding for like
10 minutes I'm sorry I don't want it to
end man we don't have to end go P this
is the first show ever on Spotify I
can't believe I get to be here I gotta
go I I looked on your
your go I wasn't even in the Jesus go PE
no voting he's there's no
voting God that isn't he funny I wasn't
even in the voting Duncan
Trussell I wanted you to be guest number
number one it's
important guess number
two Miley Cyrus that's right second one
number two yeah that's what I
said number two I said guess number two
yeah you don't even listen we're like an
old married couple Jamie it sound I said
guest number two I'm drunk I'm high
guest number two is Miley Cyrus guest
number
three Mike mother [__] Tyson how
about
that Jamie are you concerned at all
about moving to
Texas no that's what I like about you
it's one of many
things but you're ready to roll like I
should just tell the people at home I
brought it up with Jamie I'm like I'm
thinking about moving to
Texas Jamie
goes
okay
is that accurate yeah I mean that's
gonna
happen something was coming some change
something was happen what did you think
was going to happen what was worst case
scenario like
Montana I no I didn't think that was GNA
no I don't know I just didn't want you
to not want to do
it I wasn't worried about it good I'm
happy there's uh you know it's hard feel
like I'm prolonging this out of an neuro
longing anything this is fun Jamie and I
just had a Love Fest oh that's great I
do feel like I'm I was asking Jamie if
there's ever a time where I was telling
him we're moving to Texas where he was
like oh like I don't want to do that but
he's like no but when I brought it up
I'm like do you what do you think and
he's like okay like that's cool I do
feel like I'm stretching it out it's
like man it mean man this is the first
episode on Spotify I I love it's
supposed to be you it's supposed to be
you it's beautiful but also there's a
piece of me that I think we can work
things out together I really do I think
you and me together have a unique
perspective and I'm not [__] I agree
and I don't think it's I'm not taking
ownership and you shouldn't either it's
the the two of us together I know
there's a weird thing that happens I
feel it man like look it's my favorite
thing which is why I don't want it to
end which is why I'm like I like to like
look man I'm a Bo I know I'm going to
die what does that mean though when you
say you're a a Buddhist shouldn't we
have a new thing you said like communism
socialism I love it Joe I love it can't
we have a new one I think we can but I
do want to like the reason I'm going to
speak up for Buddhism in general and I
agree with you and what I love about
Buddhism so much is that man what's
great about it is it invites you to
reject it it says to you the first part
of it is like reject this if you can
like if you can find a flaw in the thing
reject it and and also if you can find a
like legitimate rejection then we will
add that to the like what Buddhism it's
of Buddhism yes so that's what I love
about it because it's more of a process
that's that's perfect yeah it's perfect
and it has to be that way it has to be
that way if you're thinking about how to
progress with ideas yeah man you have to
be able to say hey bring me a counter
idea that makes more sense and I'll
reconsider it but it's what we were
talking about earlier people are married
to their goddamn ideas it's sad it's
it's it's not just sad it is sad for
sure but it's also it's bad for all of
us and it's it's one of those things
that we should recognize just like you
know like uh negative feedback like oh
I'm so fat oh I'm such a [__] loser
everybody admits that that is not good
for you and it actually hinders process
and I progress I think that it hinders
progress as well I think we have to look
at things in a more positive way that's
so weird dude I like it I was there's
this teacher Jack cornfield he's so
smart he's a Buddhist teacher and I
remember like in the early days of the
ramdas Retreats I would do these
podcasts with him and I remember being
like I want to get in
shape I feel like I'm fat and what he
said to me was get in shape because you
love yourself not because you hate
yourself don't get in shape because
because you are uh angry at who you are
right now get in shape because you think
you deserve
to be in shape that's cute that sounds
like gu never been fat listen to me
[__] hey he's not a [__] competition's
real
[__] sometimes you just got to
get in shape cuz you don't look at fat
shaming works this what people don't
like to admit that that shame makes you
[__] lose weight cuz you don't want
to feel bad and then you feel good
because you lost all the weight I have
to stick up for Jack cornfield because
he is one of the great teachers I'll
stick up for him too and you would love
him and you would you would love I love
him if he's friends with you I love him
thank you Joe but I do have to stick up
for him but just just like an example of
how badass this person is do you want to
move to Texas no I can't I'm going I I'm
not saying are you
sure I don't want to be local I have an
idea I think you and I together can fix
a lot of
[__] what's the plan man you and me do
like a weekly podcast one a week Joe and
Duncan I love it live from Austin I love
it but it's not going to happen in
Austin why not oh we'll Zoom for a while
until you come to your senses listen man
we'll do it off camera this conversation
I love this conversation though listen
man I'm not bullshitting I'm not
bullshitting I would do just about
anything for you Joe I would do just
about anything for you I know you would
I would now look I got to stick up for
this teacher though and I'm we can zoom
it we can zoom it hold on what teacher
Jack cornfield Joe bu guy
yeah I love you man I love you too but
you got to understand this is like a
person has deeply impacted me and and
like he was a monk and I know him as a
friend and like he's a monk okay in the
sense that he went here's what's cool
about him he went to he became a
monastic terab and Buddhist and he like
took a vow of silence for like two years
so for two years he didn't talk is it
possible he didn't have anything good to
say oh no no
man Jack corfield
look look listen I I really like he
really like I'm sorry I don't mean to be
sentimental about somebody joking I know
you're joking when did he die he's alive
Joe sorry sorry sorry you said
sentimental I panicked I mean
sentimental only in that like I wouldn't
want to do anything that would like
negatively impact like a real can we get
him on a show first you me and Jack
cornfield you would love it you how
about that our first episode that
convinces you to move to Austin Texas I
would I would come to Austin Texas to
Jack no what if I bought you a house
would you live in it Joe I love that you
would buy me a house but I wouldn't
move is that it's cool about us like one
of the cool things about us is you could
say I will buy you a house that's not
why I would want to be with you for the
house or I know I know man and I
understand but like for me it's like I
will off camera I will talk to you about
the reason we made the decision oh
listen you made an amazing decision your
decision is way better than mine but I
don't I'm jealous I don't want be local
like to me like I get it let's do a zoom
show let's do a zoom show or let's you
and I have known each other for so long
we could do both or either exactly we
could do Zoom shows we could do live
shows I just think like the the right
now the best thing for the world is not
to imagine that you have to be in any
given GPS coordinate I think that yeah
the best thing for the world is to begin
to realize like we don't need to be
Tethered to a a a a particular locality
like this is the problem is like it's
it's a bit of the problem but it's also
in recognizing that it is an actual like
it's a thing that you factor into the
world that you see but how relevant is
it to day-to-day operations right that's
what I'm talking about like that's the
to me like the gift of Co has been
like people have begun to realize like
keep your circle small Google is doing
fine and no one's going to Google to go
to work
Twitter is doing fine no one's going to
the Twitter building to work
Netflix are they do they have jobs dude
people are all working remotely no one's
going to Netflix Oh what you're saying
is that the businesses are doing well
but no one's going to the the actual
business they don't have to why do they
have to exactly dude that that to me
that is the if you want to like start
really like restructuring Society let's
start with a Superstition that you need
to be in in in like a like proximity of
another person's body God damn that
kills New York City yeah it kills La too
it kills La it kills La that's why I
want you to come to Austin dude I will
be at whenever you want I'll come to
Austin D no come bring your baby ah he
would love I can't wait for you to meet
little Forest he's so brilliant but but
my point is look man my point is like we
can't be centralized like look you're
going to be in Austin I'm going to be in
a certain place I don't want to say yet
it's a bunker outside of Nevada
somewhere near Baro where the bats take
over we're going to fight against
centralization so that we don't have to
get chained to shitty cities like that's
the whole point is like look if anything
happens after Co that's beautiful it
will be that all the commuters say to
their bosses wait a minute for the last
six months I've been zooming in for
these [__] conferences and your
business is doing just as well as it did
when I was driving an hour to get there
an hour back and then the moment that
happens we break the back of addiction
to being in a metropolis now we have a
global Society now it's not just that
you have to have some person who's like
living in an Angelino it's like you
could have someone from any part of the
planet centralization seems to be the
fundamental problem in the sense that it
was it worked we needed to centralize
prior to the internet but now we don't
need to centralize no one it's better
for everybody if we take into account
every idea
it's better for everybody if we take
into account all the dumb ideas and
smart ideas and let them battle it out
yeah let's find out who's right yeah and
you got to be real careful people who
think that they're right and the other
people are wrong it's what we were
talking about earlier that bums me out
the most about the Democratic
Convention is it I would just like
forget about whatever you don't like
about Trump tell me what you're GNA
do don't tell me how bad the orange man
is tell me what you're going to do yeah
how you going to fix it how you going to
fix it yeah what are you going to do
what are you going to do about Flint
Michigan's water what are you going to
do about the [__] Earth is heating up
what are you going to do about there no
fish where's the fish what are you going
to do yeah
nobody has an idea they just want to
talk [__] and make sure everybody's
trans I would rather them talk [__] and
make sure everyone's
trans then be like what's happening now
which is I don't mean that trans people
I'm with you I know look you're here's
what's funny to me about your whole like
push back against the trans Community
it's not it's only push back against
trans people competing as females and
fighting that's it and other Athletics a
little bit but fighting in a big way to
me the part of it that's like
interesting is I know you well enough to
know that if and you prove me wrong here
but if there was a
technology they could turn a guy into a
woman no they could not just turn a guy
into a woman which is very funny because
right now that's what we're doing and it
makes sense because it's like right now
what we know is men and women right so
that's where we're at so right now as
far as our understanding of what can a
human be if you want to break it into a
binary we've got men and women right but
that's pretty limited to me you know
what I me and I get wanting to be a
woman and I think that you Joe Rogan if
there was a technology that could
instantly turn you into a woman yeah you
wouldn't hesitate to turn i' like to
feel a dick inside me yeah exactly
that's what I'm saying me as a woman
yeah and I don't think it made me gay no
exactly doesn't make you gay trust me if
someone who's felt many dicks inside of
them doesn't make you I'm just kidding
if you could be a woman and actually be
attracted to a male for 18 hours and
you're in love imagine a second imagine
if you have an Oculus
Rift and uh yeah they make you go
through a bunch of waivers and they say
Duncan um if you
do take the next step signed what
happens is you become a woman who
actually feels the way a woman feels
when she's attracted to a man a
guy with a dick like a battering ram let
me try he just going to send it home see
what happens and you can't wait you want
to feel him come inside your upper rib
cavity like want to feel
it sign me up yeah who cares the point
is like you would do some men the
weakest Among Us would be scared of that
experience right they'd be scared that
that experience weakens them and turns
them into something that they they they
dismiss but how hilarious is it that
they sorry Joe no no it's it's their own
issue no it's the the the experience
that literally made them exist on the
planet they feel like if they were to
feel it it would be something against
who they are which is insanity in the
sense that the very see the very feeling
of a [__] blowing come inside your body
you switch spots with your woman imagine
if the only way a woman was willing
marry you is if you become the wife and
she becomes the husband and you switch
Consciousness it Duncan I love you I
love you too
Priscilla I want to know what it feels
like to be you yeah I want to be with
you yeah but I want I want to be you for
four years yeah let's swap identities
foure contract yeah we're all of your
secrets get downloaded into your wife's
brain let's swap he likes feet that's
not a
secret imagine
though that no that's the idea is like
the point is like right now we're like
terrestrialization funny to me about
like Lindsey Graham I love Lindsey
Graham he's such a [__] [__] but I
I feel for I feel a weird connection to
him he's such a [__] [__] but like
Lindsey Graham I have the feeling that
if suddenly there was like the ability
to travel through space he would leave
the planet within seconds he would just
be gone the lindsy gramy was like here's
what I think about religious guy no he's
a politician Lindsey Graham is this like
like piggish is any
religion
he's like poor Lindsey grah man he's
like he like got he has a weak
chin I have a weak [__] chin man yeah
D I shave my beard no listen bro that
guy no Lindsey Graham look I know
Lindsey Graham he like got sucked into a
dark
Vortex he's a sweetheart Underneath It
All and also he's like he's like a gay
dude you know he's like a gay dude who
like has but what I'm saying is like
what is he saying what he's a gay dude
that has like a lindsy Graham causes
problems because he a gay dude that what
he like is a he's a he's a suppressive
being that like is like aligns with
closet no not a closeted thing it's not
the gay dude is in the part the the it
doesn't matter if Lindsey Graham's gay
that's all what I'm saying you brought
it up so it must matter no what I'm
saying is like his [__] came out about
him being gay and like then he had to
fight it or like there was like some I
felt bad for in that regard I feel bad
about but don't you think for him even
like it would be if he just said said
I'm gay yeah be the best or I'm
not like that's that's the argument
against these two ideas if you could
turn into a woman and get [__] like
you just said would you be
gay it's good question bro no you would
just be a woman who got [__] but like
somehow if like you're if you've decided
to centralize on your masculine identity
and someone [__] you now you're gay the
whole like conceptualization of gayness
and straightness it's just monkey talk
is the problem the word itself the
problem is a binary it's like the
definition who like it's a trait it's a
binary dude it's like look I don't know
I like whatever the [__] it is that you
think is like limiting your ability to
experience pleasure on the earth is
Satan and it's like if that thing is
telling you that you're a dude and this
is the only way you can feel Joy but on
the like simultaneously you're like
hanging out with a guy who's like the
same gender as you and your fall in love
with him and then you're you're
pretending you're not because because
like some devil voice in your mind is
telling you that's Satan man that's evil
that's [__] evil it's dark it's dark
and I'm not like deriding Lindsey
Graham's sexual proclivities I'm just
saying you know he's not actively gay I
don't know that all I'm saying is like
when I why you shaming him I'm not
shaming lindsy gr I feel like you are no
I'm not I'm saying if I feel like it' be
nice if you admit your privilege I hope
Lindsey grandma is listening to this cuz
I'm not insulting you my friend you
could hear from my voice that I'm not
insulting you I'm just saying H darkness
my old no Joe I'm telling you if lindsy
grah could fly off the planet he would
that's what I think I would he fly off
the planet with a man's mouth on his
penis who
wouldn't I would do that in a second I
don't care who it is if that I don't
care if it was what fueled the spaceship
or didn't that would be
amazing why wouldn't you do that
who how awesome would that be imagine if
it was the mountain from Game of
Thrones that guy's blowing you as you
fly through
space and your orgasm extends to
Eternity yeah the whole like gay
straight thing really falls apart Pink
Floyd I wish you were here s of Silence
I was trying to work it in there but
can't find the but you the gay stay
thing falls apart if we stop being
terrestrial like the moment you're not
on the planet anymore it's all planetary
based memes man it's like the moment
we're like released from the gravity
well all the stuff that seems so
important to dumb asses which is like
what you you [__] you would put your
mouth on a penis you must be crazy
imagine if it felt amazing imagine like
man never blow a [__] guy and you get
that dick in your mouth and the moment
that sperm hits your tongue it's like
Pop Rocks yeahp pop and your brain goes
oh you and I man we will suckle on a we
will suckle on a
mucus thing that's like a like this
vag we'll do that we pride we pride
ourselves on it we pride our water park
slide that's what I love so much about
Christina Pit's Instagram she does these
like [__] hilarious Tik Tock clips
that she recovers from Tik Tock and
there's a whole genre of Tik Tok of
these creepy [__] perves who are like
showing how they lick [__] and like the
whole Tik Tok is based on them like
going it's so [__] up but it's like a
guy will in the masculine sense will go
down on a girl yet the concept of having
a dick in your mouth is considered to be
like [__] up like you must be like a
complete like you something about you is
weak you know and I think we're going to
have to contend with that as what's this
uh that's the dude what's he doing he
does like how like he like watch just
you got to watch him man what he do I
don't know I just I just checked her
this guy does like like eating [__] Tik
toks that's what he's doing yeah watch
watch just watch this one doesn't do he
like he like eases into
it her by the way her Instagram the Tik
Tok she does like she should do a whole
show based on her like she she like
curates the most [__] up Tik toks
you've ever seen isn't that important
like Tik Tok whether it's Tik Tock or
Instagram or any of these things isn't
that important just random one I do that
it kind of is right it kind like
lowering the boundaries like uh dropping
down the boundaries for people to be
able to enter into the world of
expressing whatever weirdo idea they
have or a video of them doing back flips
onto a [__] whale whatever they're
doing yeah yeah it's the B I I like I
don't like Tik Tok in the sense that
like my wife she's into Tik Tok and I
don't like it because she's always
looking at Tik Tok and then I'll be like
really you're looking at Tik Tok and
she'll be like you're on Twitter all day
long you should get off Twitter you
should read this book I hate Twitter
this book irresistible it's a mindblower
man it really is because it it lets you
realize that as much as we're at each
other's throats right now I don't know
how much of it is our fault
and I think we could have been a lot
better off if someone decided instead of
trying to make money that they would
recognize that this uh strategy of uh
whether it's social media likes or
Twitter you know Twitter Twitter or
Facebook or whether it's showing you the
things you get angry about and you
comment on on Facebook or YouTube like
whatever we're doing like ultimately
we're changing the path the way people
think we're way more valuable than we
like to think we are way more and I
think people that have a voice whether
it's you or I or Ari or bird or Tom or
anybody who has a podcast in particular
because if you have a podcast at the
very least no one's telling you what you
can't talk about no one's Duncan I I
love that segment but when you're
talking about people like not conforming
and trying to figure themselves out
people think you're nonbinary or somehow
or another you're like you're like
you're not woke
sorry I'll repeat what I said I'm sorry
I'll revise we're in the middle of a
storm Duncan yeah well we what the main
thing the most important thing I think
in the storm and it's easy to forget is
is that like you and I and everybody we
run across I've yet to meet somebody
who's a real monster man there's a few
but even them they just need hug they're
also very unique when you run across
it's very unique and like the anytime I
feel like this is where I'm like I'm
attuned to this anytime I get the sense
someone's wanting me not to express
myself that's where I get really locked
in and really like and I get the whole
like anti-woke thing because nobody
wants some [__] liberal Baptist piece
of [__] to tell them how to be but you
know man like the moment I'm on my
Instagram
I did a black lives matter thing that's
the only time anybody told me to shut up
no one told me to shut up before that
but the moment I did a thing that was in
alignment with like black lives matter
there was all of a sudden like this
weird similarity of people hitting me up
being like you you [__] woke me there
was a lot of of blowback from that and
and also when when you say a lot like
how
many enough that like like I noticed it
and right but if you tuned
in at a hug part like 30 messages how
many messages no not 30 just enough
where I really 10 I'm going to say like
five 15 15 enough where like I realize
how many Instagram followers do you have
I don't remember dude I can look it up
right now like not 200,000 or something
I a lot of people man no but but I know
what you're saying but it was like I
realized that like my
thinking regarding being like even
remotely an a political activist was
being shaped by my fear that a tiny
percentage of my audience would reject
me and that's what I'm saying it's like
I was letting my ship get steered not by
my own Intuition or Not by my my own
sense of like [__] man like that [__]
George Floyd video that's unforgivable
that just [__] up but you know it's
it's it's both it's
unforgivable any man that would do that
to another man like that man needs help
I I bet he didn't think he was going to
kill that guy but he tortured that guy
for 8 minutes and 46 seconds it's like
that guy needs he needs uh he needs a
DMT trip he needs something he needs to
recognize who he is killer he it's also
Duncan I
think I think we're asking people to do
things they're not really qualified to
do they don't have the tools to handle
it they don't have the infrastructure to
handle the load of pressure that comes
in I just feel like all these people
that and then right now we're we're so
anti- cop it's like it's over the top
well look man what I love about you is
that you're like not afraid to say a
thing like that and like I think if
we're going to go if we're going to move
forward right now we need cops but no if
we're going to move forward what what we
need is not just cops we need passion
like that that the what if we're going
to move forward what we need is it's
like look man you're you're right this
country was completely founded on human
trafficking you're right that uh your
your idea that like the the way like uh
if you're if you have a a particular
complexion in this country [__] is
immediately against you you're
completely right about that you're right
like the thing is is like this is the
problem is like and I think this is an
important question
for everybody to ask themselves is how
do you act when you're right that's how
that's how you can really tell a person
you know what I think honestly I think
we are looking for change the way we see
change in oursel like we see a potential
for changing oursel we see something
wrong we go I got to correct that and
then we think that Society can do that
too but Society is like a battleship
it's like a 500 M long Steel struct
structure that has
[Applause]
to planes land on it it it's yeah that's
it that's it that's a good description
it's got to turn so and then people like
[__] you we don't like people from
[__] muslim
countries yeah right [__] you trans
women are real women yeah right and it's
this battle to try to like navigate this
enormous metal structure through the
[__] ocean right that's where we're
at that's where we're at that's why you
got to do a podcast with me Duncan
anytime I'll do anything for you man got
to work this out we can work it out I
mean the answer Jamie I'm not wrong
right no but the answer is compassion
Joe lot ways to do it no this is what
I'm thinking you and I have a very
unique frequency yeah let's do it this
is why it's important because when you
and I get together and I I firmly
believe you and I can do this every
godamn week I love it especially if we
only saw each other once a week it's the
best I'll fly you in I'll F come to
Austin once Zoom we can zoom we can do
whatever I'll fly to North
Carolina I'm not going there I'm going
to Colorado baby I met chuba yeah man
like I I love it Joe I I mean I to me
like you know that's what I think so
great about the fact that you got to be
the person that you are that you got to
be the the spotlight got to be on you as
it is and the reason it's on you and the
reason I take such I really like not
much offends me man but when people
start attacking you I do like I have to
fight against my offense because I know
you and so when people are [__] at
Arms against you I feel really depressed
because I know you and I and you like
you are one of the most Progressive
people I've ever met and so when you
when people start falling upon you uh
because you have like [__] nerds like
Ben
Shapiro which by the way you shouldn't
have that guy anymore he's a d come on
come on those conversations are
important I think what's beautiful about
what you're doing is you're opening I
would not open up the the by the way Ben
Shapiro Underneath It All I know that
you and I would probably have fun but I
know that right now where you're at in
your Incarnation you're a [__] dork
and the you know what I mean like he's a
DK he's a d but what's so confusing nice
guy but what that's what's confusing
about him is cuz you you look at his
like you look at him and you're like
he's all like beating up what's her face
about the thing and that embarrassing
thing the the the music video he's like
and they were doing fornication did you
see me and Alli makovsky talking about
wet ass [__] oh God like like that
thing Shapiro's do it's so embarrassing
Joe and like that dude is like an
embarrassment but the what I I don't
think what people admit when they look
at Ben Shapiro it's like there's a piece
of you that's like I I'd have fun with
him like it' be fun to drink with him
he's probably cool but he's like right
now I don't think he drinks but he's a
nice guy he's a what whatever it is he
he's a good person I'm not bullshitting
I look again I think our job right now
is not to alienate we have to like
involve and that's why I have him on
that's that's why I know you're doing it
Joe he's a I'm telling you right now Ben
chapiro is a nice man he's a nice man I
see him I hug him every time I see him
and I don't hug him to be fake I hug him
cuz I genuinely love that guy I think
he's a nice guy look I think some of the
stuff he's propagating and his like
philosophies is like legitimately
deranged bro he's wearing an
outfit it's a costume he's got I mean
he Ben shapir could never take off the
yamaka shave his head tattoo his chest
with an
eagle right wear a
bikini he's got an outfit I just want
but it's not his fault I'm telling you
we all come from a different spot we if
if life is a race it's not like
everybody's on the same starting line
like people are on starting lines
they're like a mile behind your they're
so far away they're all different and
they here's the thing even if people are
wrong about many things or even I'll
explain this better even if you disagree
with the way people feel about so many
different things it doesn't mean you
can't be their friend it doesn't and I'm
telling you we got it wrong sweet here's
what's important what's important is
whoever that person is they got to be
sincere
now as soon as you feel like someone's a
grifter yeah you got to cast them out
right you got to cast them out cuz they
got to figure that out on their own and
they got to apologize that's cool man
you got listen you can be wrong but you
have to be honest and if you're just
bullshitting then I can't hang out with
you dudey let me ask you Shapiro is not
bullshitting I don't think he's
bullshitting I just think he's like a
little like Antiquated in his IDE look
man I I like I'm not like the whole Ben
shapir thing like that's of all your
guests is the one he a great guy man if
you met him if you and I and him went to
a steak dinner we'd have a great
conversation I I hung out with him at
the um the what's that steakhous the bo
boa boa in Hollywood down the store from
the store on Sunset I had a great time
with him he's a good man I don't care I
I like genuinely like him a lot when he
texts me benir texts me I look at my pH
on my bench I like that guy I like him I
look as far as I'm concerned if you're
going to create what I think could be
created by Humanity we have to create
the engine not of rejection but of
acceptance which meaning that like if
you got a charismatic fin shapir Avatar
in the video game in the simulation that
we're in there's a way to reabsorb him
into reality that isn't like the way
people currently see him if he's willing
to relinquish his ideology and he has a
very strict religious ideology yeah he's
stuck in this little thing but I think
that's helped him that little thing look
if you figure out a way to do something
that helps you past most of the people
that you're competing against But
ultimately hinders you against the
people the people who learn your lessons
plus other lessons and aren't hampered
by ideology and they pass you like you
have to there's a moment where you have
to figure out when you're going to let
go he seems to have a very like clear
mind that's what's cool about him he
seems to like have a very insightful
mind I like that I just feel like
something about him it like smacks of
like the Nazi intellectuals yes it does
but he's Jewish and here's the thing I
love when people get mad at me that I
talk to them I'm like listen just listen
to what we're saying listen he's not a
bad guy he might not agree with him but
me and him are having really really good
conversations about why I feel like you
can't tell an 18-year-old kid just pull
your pants up and don't shoot anybody
yeah we're having these like really
nuanced conversations and he's allowing
me because he knows I like him so you're
like the Bohemian GFF but it's no he
knows I like him like Ben chapiro and I
don't agree on many things but he knows
if I see him I go what's up man how you
doing I hug him and it's genuine I
really care about him that's the whole
point that's the whole point so if we
care if he and I are sitting like right
here and we talk about stuff he knows
that if I don't agree with him I it's I
doesn't change my feelings about whether
or not I'll hug him or I love him that's
it that's it yes that's the problem
we're all facing we're all facing this
problem where we identify with ideas
whereas I think I think we can just do
our best to make good with where we
stand right now as a human and when we
encounter other humans let's take IDE
ideas and put them in front of us and
Let's cross our arms and let's go over
these ideas without any attachment
that's where it gets hard because most
of us don't have enough personal
satisfaction and our own accomplishments
to relinquish this idea that our ideas
are not ours that our ideas are just
it's just a mathematical problem it's a
[__] Rubik's Cube it's a it's a
[__] game of Clue like who knows who
did it is it Charlotte in the [__]
library with a
a rope we don't know so this thing that
we're doing as people
today is we're scared and one of the
things that happened when people are
scared is they pull back you pull back
you you you you put up fences you wall
off you protect your tribe your tribe
gathers you decide what you can say what
you can't say and decide who's the enemy
and who's who's good and who's bad and
and everybody walls off and my thoughts
are are that's a trap and that is just
something that we've been involved with
forever from the beginning of time from
single- cell organisms to small mammals
to human beings we've been involved in
this weird trap of competing against
each other in the wrong way competing
against each other in a way where
ultimately somebody gets victimized I
think the best competition is keeping
the other competition alive competing
against each other while helping each
other and everybody gets by everybody
gets better and even people who are not
doing well you tell them why they're not
doing well that will force you to do
better right all of the people that
trying to take your position if there's
a ladder you say this is why you [__]
up and then you'll do better cuz they'll
do better and then everybody does better
yeah there's no stagnation I get it it's
just like the pro like you're in a
you're in a like brutal position you're
in a really brutal position like and no
matter matter what I don't see how you
can resist it like the problem with your
your position is you have this like
powerful voice that's the problem is
like you're you're a signal booster and
like I also got a NASA suit and I can
hold my piss for four hours son how do
you how have you not pissed but but but
but to me like the the bizarre like the
difficult situation you're in is like
you get Ben
Shapiro you signal boost that whatever
that is I don't know what he is by the
way he's not a bad guy I'm not I'm not
I'm not trying to attack you your
[__] like whatever the thing you did
with like attacking the music video was
[__] that was an embarrassment that was
a mess that was a mess it was a mess I
get it it was really sex negative it was
so stupid he seemed like such a nerd a
dork like and also anybody who's going
to like do that you like feel like they
they negate whatever their philosophical
ideas by attacking the think gives a
[__] however he's doing the exact same
thing that Trump does when he gets
attention
he's saying something about something
that's culturally relevant and he's
taking a contrary position and he's
generating likes he's generating
interest right he's like a a he's a he's
a salesperson for negativity if I was
his best friend and Ben and I were
sitting around he's like you think
you're supposed to like okay okay yeah
you probably should cuz like ultimately
people going to [__] with you but my my
position is is it's better if you have
vulnerabilities yeah if if there's
something you've done that's really
stupid it's probably better for you when
you [__] on things yeah and I think
that's a good argument for coming out
against wet ass [__] that what's wrong
with wet ass [__] by the way nothing
nothing but a guy like Ben Shapiro he
shouldn't be right too many times part
part of his
charm is his failure part of his charm
is he casually he's got a say some [__]
that only a [__] dude with a yamaka
says it's not that he's a bad person
yaka there's a lot of jewi J's Jewish
listen listen I love Ari but he doesn't
wear a yamaka okay you're saying the
yamaka means fundamentalism wear you
don't have to wear it so now we're in
space we're flying you've gone from
rejecting here's us as a golf
Bo flying through the universe C your
impossible look man I don't I didn't
want to get I don't care about [__] B
shapir I don't care thank God you're the
first episode on Spotify I don't care
about leg four hours in who cares plus
four I don't care about Ben shapir I
don't care he should he's a nice guy who
that's my No he cares listen if I hug
Ben Shapiro I really hug him I love that
guy he's a sweetie I'm sure he's a
sweetie I meet him he's a nice guy look
man it doesn't matter like here's a
deeper Point man I and I don't mean to
do this every time I'm on but you
have such a such a crazy power that if
you're not careful folks
from deep dark Wells of perspective are
going to infiltrate your
[__] dude have you watched that great
documentary on uh the like white Aryan
folks man it's [__] up like this dude
why you got to go there give me that
lighter
here you go like yeah you you look at
like these people are very organized man
it's like they're organized is what I'm
saying and like I'm and again I'm not
saying Ben shapir as this person he
wears a Yama he's Jewish what I don't
know much about him I don't care I don't
care listen to me listen to me all those
people that are
organized they come hang out with us
give me a hug you don't want to give
them a hug relax why just relax all
those people are just people man like a
white supremacist they were lost they
imagine if you gave a white supremacist
5 Meo
DMT and let him sit on a couch one of
them brown suede
couches they take three big hits and
then as the first one as they're
exhaling
yeah
yeah yeah
and they get sucked into the center of
the universe and they realize there is
no Center cuz there is no boundaries
it's all connected you're in a soup
you're in an infinite soup of ideas and
biology and thoughts and prayers and
Love and Hope and happiness and jealousy
and anal sex and it's all
together who with cartoons and pop music
and
cheeseburgers
who just a bunch of different
experiences all [__] stitched
together and some sort you're saying
there's a Redemptive
possibility and then the then the aliens
land yeah look man this is the way I see
it I don't know man who gives a [__]
like really it's like you know the the
the the reality of it is is like we are
in a very bizarre Peri period in time
which is that you and I we became
friends on the phone having these same
conversations and now you say a thing
that flies in the phase of the of the
particular like default reality of our
time and you start trending on Twitter
you know like that's like some of our
communic like the way I know you right
now is like you trending on Twitter
where I'm like what the [__] happened
but the jokes on them because I don't
read Twitter you don't go on Twitter at
all I don't read it I post things like
today I posted Ali Letterman made some
masks it's just poster masks Joe it's
just weird because it's like you're like
a but it's not me it's what they think I
am it's who they decide to am yeah but
you have to watch out cuz people are
going to like try to exploit you that's
the main thing is like people
recognizing what you are who have
political agendas will infiltrate your
[__] and then start blowing out their
radioactivity into the world right
that's a fear radium like face rotten
[__] yeah yeah exactly like they'll get
in they'll get in there and then like
all of a sudden like you accidentally
start exing [__] that's like that that
you know you don't agree I know you
don't agree with like Ben Shapiro listen
it's not that I don't agree with Ben
Shapiro and I definitely don't on many
things and he and I talked about it it's
said I don't want to abandon him oh
that's that's cool I don't I don't think
he's worthy of Abandonment CU I think
he's a good person right and I think
many of the things he said says he says
cuzz he's rewarded for saying
controversial things on the internet
many times make sense and you know a
logical way if you don't take into
account all the different situations
that lead to a person becoming who they
are in 2020 right slavery and Jim Crow
laws and all these different things we
all have to deal with but I think he's a
good person I really do I think many of
times like the things we say were half
defensive and and and and and half
promotional you're saying things cuzz
you think that people are going to react
in a certain way you don't necessarily
mean it and you also say things because
you've seen the contrary to that poorly
worded and you decide you don't agree
with that and so you want to counter it
but I think the problem is in ideal
ideologies more than anything is if I'm
really being objective I always feel
like our problem is purely in ideologies
because we just get committed to one
side or the other and ideas to one side
you're right or you're wrong and I think
if we could just divorce oursel from
ideas and divorce oursel from all
ideologies and just look at something
like honest like you come to me and I
come to you and I go hey man what's up I
go what are your intentions my my
intentions is to live a harmonious life
with my neighbors and I said might as
well okay good beautiful and you hug
each other and you go what do we have to
do about tax
man if we lived in a community where I
felt like hey if I pay more in taxes
people will have their kids in a better
school and uh the water will be pure and
you know there there be less crime I
would [__] 100% sign up for that but
I don't think the people that are taking
that [__] thing and running with it
know what they're doing that's right
that's the problem you believe in the
idea of democracy you just don't believe
in the organ
ganizational facility that's like
administering democracy been to the red
line of human
beings I know where people fall apart I
know the red line I know when the RPM's
hit I know when people [__] out and I
know I'm not going to [__] out and if
you're going to [__] out I know I know
you're if you're bitching out and you're
also making you're making laws right
what are you saying what what are you
doing what's going on who are you why
are you deciding what people do we
shouldn't have any figureheads it's
dangerous Alpha chimps are dangerous
take it from me a person with a big
platform you shouldn't listen to me you
shouldn't listen to you you shouldn't
listen to Bert ker shouldn't listen to
Tom sagor Ari Safir AR Shir or Joey Diaz
or name all the people you love to
listen to Sam Harris don't listen to
them meaning listen to their show
but apply to whatever they say your own
objective opinion but how weird is it
that people will focus that you have Ben
Ben Shapiro on this podcast but they
don't they don't Focus that you have
Bernie Sanders on how weird is it but
they do they do Focus but what I'm
saying is like people in the left will
say you're a monster that you would have
Ben Shapiro on and they've completely
forget that you gave one of the great
potential socialist presidents of our
time of platform that you supported they
forget that and Andrew Yang and tulsy G
to me that's of my favorite that's the
part that drives me nuts is it's like
why do they forget
that I'm a
Savage that's why what do you mean I'm a
Savage I'm a [__] cage fighting
commentator I do I commentate for UFC I
do stand-up comedy I do wild comedy I'm
a wild person it's a different thing I
understand it's just a we we have to
stop trying to push people down in order
to push ourselves ahead and if we just
all look at it like look there's things
about all sorts of aspects of society
that I don't agree with that smart
people disagree with right I don't know
if they're right I don't know if I'm
right I don't know I would like to talk
forever to people that are vegans like
my friend John Joseph he's the singer
the the the crom
mags he's a [__] interesting dude man
you know
and he he's a he's been a vegan forever
and he's like a super [__] strong guy
like mentally physically just
triathlons I want people to think
different than me I want them to right I
want bad [__] to have a
completely separate ideas of how the
world should or shouldn't work what is
wrong or isn't wrong what's right or
isn't right what's privilege what's
[__] I want everybody to come to the
table clean I want everybody to come to
the table warm I want everybody to hug I
really do and I think we're all scared
and I think it [__] up everybody and if
everybody who wants progress doesn't
want people to feel good about running
into each other and talking things
through we're going into this thing with
the wrong energy
the right energy is going into this
thing going
listen I didn't ask to be born you
didn't either here we are 2020 trying to
figure the world out but let's just
admit the the idea of wrestling between
gay and straight black and white male
and female those are so dumb I don't
want to do that I don't want to do that
I want I want to be I want to talk to
honest and dis honest I want to talk to
secure and insecure I want to talk to
loving and hateful I want to hug people
that needed I want to figure out a way
where we can get through this in a
better State than we were five years ago
10 years ago let's get through this with
food and water and realize we didn't
need a [__] MX platinum
card I don't want a [__] I I don't
want it I don't want go go home you're
going to be president no I don't want to
be president no it doesn't matter I
don't want any president that's what I
want I want no president they're going
to run this in your anti- campaign but
you're going to I could see it happening
man we should postpone the election try
to find a better way to do this no do
the [__] election get Biden in there
get a non lunatic in there what we need
is
um romantic tension between a 24y old
like super
super liberal super attractive woman and
like a
32-year-old Navy
SEAL who's also married and no one
cheats on anybody but they have the
sexual tension and they keep it together
and they work their way through veganism
what the [__]
and what are you talking about I'm
trying to [__] fix the world Duncan
I'm trying to tell you that all the
things that we see pros and cons pluses
and minuses is yeah
man I'm just trying to figure out like
we got to the election and suddenly it's
this erotic romance between this 24y old
that's so much better than a [__] guy
with fake hair and some dead man weakend
at Bernie with a cop shoving her hand up
his ass and walking him to the aisle
here's the thing that I don't understand
in sports somebody in any [__] sport
if they're not doing great that night
the coach pulls them off and puts
someone better in here's the thing
Duncan Trussell no one wants that
spot the replacement no one why who
wants to be
president I would love to be
[Laughter]
president the [__] the [__] the
[__] look at your face
oh oh my God
Jamie I don't want to go through an
election but like I would like that
listen elections are so archaic that's
[__] wood stoves yeah but I would
love to be president being president
would be so fun would it be here's the
best part you could exonerate all your
friends that is the the most ridiculous
thing about being president you can the
best you can just decide you're out I'm
gonna pardon out by the way he's a bad
guy but he's a good guy and here's a
really important thing the Trump
Administration just let out one of the
great LSD chemists of our time who's
that I can't remember his name it's so
sad if you look it up don't say it don't
say it don't say it no you should say
blew up that guy spot that was throwing
cigarettes on the ground in Utah no look
he deserves to be his name deserves to
be spoken you know who contacted me
recently who
do you remember the nuro soup story
William Leonard
peard do you remember uh I'm so drunk me
too do you remember neuros soup yeah
yeah she was a girl who was on YouTube
and her and I I I went back with her
this is an interesting thing she had a a
a detailed account of how she put DMT up
her [__] she dated William Leonard
peard yeah yeah that's the guy that had
the LSD lab in the middle of the bunker
and the DMT accelerator pedal he
contacted me okay and from prison
I don't know I just got an email and um
it's not my main account but I was like
hm maybe that's real but that lady um
she had a whole YouTube series about
different ways she took drugs yeah and
one of them was she took DMT up her
[__] woo it was a bad trip she had a
bad trip yeah
but part of me was like that
girl
DMT up the ass that's a rare human
that's a great night a rare human looks
at that DMT nugget that little cocoa pop
whatever it
is Honeycomb Cheerios I want to I want
that in my life I want to be around
someone who's like I that's so free put
it up your [__] would you even
consider it yes really I would put DMT
up my ass I've thought about it after I
heard about it it's a good way to let
the UN Universe no you give
[Laughter]
up it's the end it's a video game it's a
part of the video game where you're like
done dud come move to Texas please North
Carolina [__] where the [__] you're
moving why do we have to be localized
you want to live in Tennessee I want no
I look we don't have to be locked into
any place bought you a
house we don't have to be locked into a
place Joe I appreciate you and by the
way I know you I want to fix things I
know that you buy houses of your friends
I want to fix things so sweet you would
say that but look we don't have to be
spatially disconnected I think we can
fix things Duncan we can all you're
already look man you're already fixing
things I think you can help me I would I
will help you any way better with you
I'm better with you than without you
listen man I'm better with you than
without you that's real that's real it's
true you and I both talked about this
not just on podcast I think but even
like on just phone calls but that when
we do podcast I feel like you bring me
to a place that I don't really get
without you yeah we're friends really I
really feel like that because I've known
you so long like I remember when you had
this breakup and we lived together and
you called me up like I don't know what
to do I'm like [__] man come live with
me yeah I was so happy I was one of the
comics that you evolved and when and
also like in that that moment where I
was living with you it wasn't like some
kind of like National Lampoon Vacation
thing you were like really serious with
me and you were not serious all the time
we had a few like really serious talks
and in those serious talks you like help
me realize that like I had to stop being
so flippant with my life and it was
really good and you weren't [__]
around it was cool and it was very sweet
and I'll never forget it man and and uh
well you know what I wanted to say to
you th this is this was what when you
see someone who is at a bump in the
road many things can happen right yeah
and for you I wanted you to know that
like you can most certainly get upset
along the way at different or you can be
almost almost immune to all the bumps in
the road it's really how you decide and
if you decide you're this [__] Peter
Pan character and just like float
through this like there's ways that
you're lucky in ways that other people
that live in Afghanistan and the Congo
will never understand never understand
now man you weren't letting me do that
but you and I when we were hanging out
together I was like I was like I
remember the moment you called me there
wasn't even a half a second between you
say I was like Yay Duncan's going to
live with me
y that's sweet man and I wanted you to
get in the tank and and I got yeah oh
that's great man I love it and like I
I'm not trying to like your perception
of it may even be different from mine
but like one qu one thing that happened
I have a few memories of that incredible
gift that you gave me one of the
memories is riding up to your house I
don't even know how you got into my car
that you would be in my Mini Cooper
which was red at the time I remember
that we're driving up to visit you we're
listening to Elliot Smith I'm playing
Elliot Smith yes he's talking about
[__] morose things and you I this so
I remember like and I've been listening
to that nonstop so we're riding up this
hell to your mansion and listening to
Elliot Smith in my mini C so this is
like I this is before your podcast but
before you had become like what you are
now just imagine folks listening riding
in a Mini Cooper with Jo Joe Rogan and
our cherry red byy Cooper trying to play
Elliot Smith for him CU it's really been
moving you I'm not playing it for you
cuz like any other reason than this is
what I've been tuned into for like a
long time and so we're riding up this
hill to your to your Manion and I
remember you look at me in this way that
only like real friends can do this and
you look at me and you go you have to
stop listening to this you are like you
can't listen to this anymore like this
is terrible this is like hurting you and
it was it wasn't from a judgmental place
or a place of musical Brilliance it was
a friend being like dude you are
depressed that guy gives out a vibration
you know he was he was incredibly
depressed and and Incredibly talented a
terrible Nexus so good so good and he
was a trap but like it's a trap but it
is a trap it's like you can squeeze out
some really super positive juice and
then to the left of your body you're
filled with cancer like that's that's
the
that's the problem with people that
there's there's so many different things
where people are depressed and morose
and they're talking about really dark
things but dude it wasn't just you like
so I get to your house I'm in this
Mansion all of a sudden you had a that
was this when you had a [__] piranha
tank do you remember that you had
piranhas remember so all of a sudden I'm
in a like Mansion where there's a
piranha tank and Eddie Bravo I remember
cuz I was going up like to fake to like
hide smoking cuz I I was addicted at the
time and so
yeah and I remember like I was sneaking
up to smoke and at some point Eddie
Bravo I'd like gone up this hill to like
like hide smoking and Ed Eddie Bravo
walks up the hill to me and is like
imitating smoking to me making fun of me
for being addicted to
cigarettes but like but like you know
you know what but Joe you know what
happened like if I live this is where I
really go back and I think Eddie Bravo
in that moment I'm like what a prick
don't tell me not to [__] smoke cut
to me sitting in front of a doctor being
like well you have cancer in your balls
and I and I and I remember like
referring back to that moment where he
was like stop smoking yeah you know what
I mean which was cool it was like like
there's so many like in those moments
well there's a thing where you can do
where you can protect people temporarily
from their emotions but you won't
protect them from the consequences of
their actions that you see that may they
don't and I think we're all responsible
for our friends blind spots and when we
see blind spots go hey hey hey hey hey
there's only so much you can do though
there's only so much you can do now
Eddie Bravo could have like turned into
a dragon and been like creepy right
nicotine's a very addictive drug man it
gets you it get get you in a weird way
but he was legitimately trying yeah to
get me to stop smoking Eddie Bravo is a
good man that was a sweet moment like
when I look back I always like when I
look back precancer I always think of
that moment it's like man you thought
that guy was such a [__] like you
thought he was such aun because you
didn't want to quit that Hab yes if I I
always like but you look back like he
wanted me to do better he didn't want me
to get one of my balls chop I got L I
got L I got lucky because like it didn't
spread through my whole body and I
didn't die we have two choices right now
I can pee my pants or I could run to the
bathroom and we stop it and then we come
back no don't stop but I've never had it
where you go to the bathroom talk to
Jamie we're five hours in how many hours
it doesn't matter I got to be so bad be
right amazing I've been Dy I've been
dying for this moment Jamie just so you
know like through the years of us doing
Rogan I usually am the one who has to go
to pee Oh my God but in this moment here
I am in a with the thing
happening and uh you
know it does what does he do in this
spot with when the guest leaves what
does he does he say pull something up
you're doing no he feel just talk he
just yaps yeah well uh good at it
subscribe to my patreon dtfh we have a
Tuesday we have a
meditation uh Wednesdays we're doing a
doom book club it's amazing the book
Doom by Frank Herbert is incredible
Fridays we have a family gathering it's
just us hanging out but join us there uh
you know the truth is it is a simulation
you know and we told you that before you
linked into the thing and uh we told you
we would wipe your memory and that you
would feel like you
were uh helpless in the sense that the
thing you are right now you don't know
what the power that you wield so you you
chose that just you know and we said
that in this moment we would do a thing
where we alerted you of the fact that
you had been you had intentionally
decided to dive into a simulation making
you limited very powerful you're Thor in
the in the human world that you're in
right now you're actually Thor you uh
you're you're a powerful Norse god that
has gotten sucked into a very temporary
like magic
spell isn't even that powerful compared
to the powers in the world you come from
but right now you have become convinced
that you are a limited identity in the
Mortal realm which you requested by the
way you said I want to be an insurance
agent real estate agent school teacher
psychologist fireman cop I wanted to be
an a pilot somebody was a flight
attendant someone who worked in a
mum teacher somebody who was a historian
a failed writer a failed comedian you
and and you became this temporary thing
but the truth is you're a God and you're
confused Joe welcome back oh my God I
peed so hard it was
amazing I don't want it to it I just
want everyone to know if you're like if
you're like no one should have this
amount of uh
influence no one no one should be able
to say things that affect politics no
social ideas you're right I don't I
don't I agree with you right I didn't
want to do this right this is a weird
thing yeah but I'm doing my best that's
stop I'm not stopping
D you're going to retire because like no
matter what you do it's like Jiu-Jitsu
you can't go for a choke just right away
you can't just dive on the choke yeah
you got to slowly cook the person slowly
where work through positions what's the
joke here re naked real naked you get
the mounts you let them Buck you off you
get half guard you hold on you escape
side control you try to mount again they
turn over you get their back hooks in
squeeze Jesus Christ takes time all
things take time don't you worry though
like that like what if like and again
like we've been going on so many hours
now so now at this point I'm just fing
how much time has this podcast going
on 4 minutes and 40 seconds but don't
you
wor 4 hours and 40 minutes Joe don't you
worry that spy's first episode we're
right I was right I knew it you knew it
I'm like Duncan has to be number one do
you know you had to be number one when
you invited me on I didn't even I tried
not to think about it because I was so
flattered by you have to I felt Darkly
flattered and then I and then I on your
like subreddit I saw the don't read that
the votes for who crazy people I saw the
votes for who would be on the number one
thing I wasn't even listed Joe those
people are fools no they're not I I
actually listen listen to me they're
fools I know what I'm doing look at this
[__] knife dude tuckamore custom
knives shout out did but like not to
like I do feel like a kind of people are
fools they're wrong listen you you have
helped me in many steps of the way
because uh you and I as friends um you
know we we we came from different
backgrounds but we're both very
compassionate and very interested in
exploring alternative ideas both of us
and we we we you and I have had so many
conversations where you said something
to me and I've went hm damn maybe huh
and I've had to reconsider the way I was
focusing in on something and because I
respect you and this is something I've
said of Ari as well and and Joey and
even Eddie Bravo and Jamie and all the
people that I'm around if if you say
something to me I consider it like I'm
thinking of it in a different way like
if you say I don't think that's a good
idea because of this I go huh okay tell
me why right and I I'll let it go I I
I'm I don't want to be I don't want to
cling on to that early idea man and I
think that's half our problem that's
half our problem you know I've always
felt like a weird sense of guilt about
Eddie Bravo man cuz like Eddie
Bravo uh want me to do that yeah yeah
thanks dude I always felt like a weird
is a Gil Jamie said yeah I thought he to
cut his finger off last time he did I
felt I felt like a weird s a gill Edie
Bravo cuz like and I don't agree with
all his conspiratorial ideas no I don't
either but neither does
he but dude this is an important thing
like this is an important thing like not
only did he tell me to quit smoking and
then I got one of my [__] B and I got
one of my balls chopped off well he was
right about that but right but I want to
tell you another thing he said don't eat
[__] he said another cheers brother he
said another thing to I do feel like
it's worth mentioning I've always felt a
weird sense of guilt because I I think I
judged him harshly and it makes me feel
like a a dumb dumb but like like cuz
he's like a jiujitsu master you know so
like I always he's you know he's my
master yeah like if someone said who's
your master I'd say first John jock
Machado second Eddie Bravo one of my
best friends is my master so I always
felt I always had this trick at the very
least a trickling sense of like man I
think you're ra about your judgment
there but but it's dangerous yeah it's
danger can kill you yeah well that also
talking that's the problem anytime I've
been talking to him I'm always a little
bit like nous at any moment I could die
it's like a pet snake yeah like what if
some at some moment you do like go
insane and decide to kill me I won't I
won't you know who I feel like that
around who Joey Joey Diaz yes what are
you you think he would kill you no no no
no but he's so wild he's so crazy he
like he's like a bear I want to keep
feeding Joey Diaz is like you know he's
the goat you know that right well I do
like you know he had he he's the
greatest of all time there's no one
who's ever been funnier I've I've seen
Joey Diaz hit like frequencies I've
never seen anybody else hit yeah he was
hanging out in uh Colorado with like
like around Shambala which is like the
place like my meditation teacher's
teacher was teaching Boulder Yeah
man so he encountered some like beings
there that were like really Advanced and
like he he he actually he like digested
some of that stuff like he's wild Joey
Diaz is wild remember like to me like
the thing that like you know one of the
aspects of this particular moment the
kie Yuka that so [__] up this is kuga
right yeah it has to be well kuga like a
lot of people explain so kuga it's the
age we're in right now explain the yugas
so the yugas are like vast spans of time
and we're considered to be in the kuga
now the other this is like something
that was actually actually predicted
several years ago yeah well hund like
thousands of years ago but in terms of
like people recognizing this right now
is kuga kuga there's there's AR there's
like you know differences what part of
the kuga we're in but there's no
difference in that we're in the kuga
explain the yugas I'm sorry the yugas
are a period of time that um um one of
the ways to
like that they get represented is like
uh imagine a dove flying through the sky
with a silk scarf and in the beak and
the tip of the scarf brushes against the
peak of the halalas so the amount of
time it takes for one of those Peaks to
get pushed down to a valley that could
be considered a Yuga it's like it's a
it's a it's actually a in Hinduism it's
a it's a period of time and people argue
about that length of time negotiable
it's negotiable but there's certain
symptoms for each Yuga and so the K
Yuga the uh symptoms are uh you can't
remember very well your memory's all
[__] up you're impetuous you're fat
you're fast in your decisions you're
easily addicted you know if you look
back at the uh history of Hinduism the
vadas were originally sung so they were
memorized and people would sing
them they would sing them and they
weren't written down writing is
considered a degradation yeah
yeah it was written down because they
heard it and then they they like it was
written down later down the line the
idea was you didn't need to write
anything down cuz you would memorize it
I I remember when I was a kid in high
school
my friend Brian catel going through all
the numbers he' memorized and it was so
many he had so many phone numbers
memorized because we didn't have phones
so you had to memorize numbers or write
them down in a little pad so what we
consider to be technology is really a
crutch to make up for our idiocy in the
age of the kuga which is what we're in
right now and a lot of people get
confused because they think Kali means
kie the goddess of Destruction how many
youas I'm not I think four three or for
what what do you know I don't know the I
don't know the answer I only know the
Jamie's like this is an 8 Hour podcast
even know how to look this up right now
you have to give him overtime pay I've
been trying to figure out too that not
that I want to end this at all but this
being our first Spotify podcast it kind
of has to be two we have other things I
don't know how they're going to deal
with this file and whatnot well we
we we're right now at 5 hours into the
podcast right how many hours
yeah 5 hours we should just make it two
two and 1 half hour podcast I feel like
I've been stopping it should we I don't
know how to I don't want it SP Spotify I
know what I'm doing this is why I
brought Ducky on I'm GNA miss you man
that's the main thing You're Not Gon to
miss me I'm GNA be around you come on
dude you want to live in South Dakota
I'm sorry I forgot I didn't want to
South Dakota my sweet home I [__]
Arizona sorry I'm going to South Dakota
and I can't wait but dude it's rough to
come in here see people pack cuz look
man here's the main thing it's like
we're not packing Stone yeah dude but
it's not we're not packing ourselves up
because of some like like like tones
Thompson thing we're packing ourselves
up because the country we were born into
has fallen into the throws of a really
dark period induced by a once in a
hundred-year pandemic that's what I'm
saying but why do you want to live in a
place where none of us are
living why not think about this I I know
why I don't want to live in Austin I
know that why well cuz I'll tell you why
Joe if you really want another real dark
reason cuz you announced
it you know what I mean had you not
announced it it might be a different
story but you and Elon Musk was G to get
out anyway yeah but elon's coming to
Austin you're coming to Austin talking
about it I know so welcome like Austin
that's Silicon Valley so no yeah yeah
dude yeah I'm sorry but that is what you
have created by your I do you know uh
Matthew has a great idea what he wants
to make a primer for people moving to
Austin where you say hey don't turn what
you escaped from into the place you're
going to oh [__] that's brilliant yeah
don't turn the place you're escaping to
exactly like where you fled yeah man
yeah I get it brilliant and that's he's
right Austin this what we we were
talking about earlier we're we were
talking about defunding the police and
defunding ice and Def like all this
nonsense that people are like let's just
like figure out a way to be nice to each
other yeah man I agree and I don't think
that's based on any locality now the
Austin thing I like offline I'll tell
you my decision cuz I did offline I
didn't think about it Joe I thought
about it what turned you off to
it well you know my my feeling is it's
it's I'm stammering cuz it's like
telling you why I would reveal where I'm
headed and I don't mean to be like like
all magical about that but the main
thing listen let me say where you are
headed is a great choice thank you
brother I've been and you fit in there
like a pee in the Pod I might wind up
being there you might I'm ready to keep
moving listen this is the thing I think
about the Spotify deal and and and just
the idea of what a is moving forward I
want you to be involved it's why I
wanted you to be number one and like
legitimately you and I have some of my
favorite conversations brother I love
you man I love you too we've been
friends for a long [__] time yeah man
I'll be involved with anything you're
involved then let's do it and I I meant
that and by the way not not not to go
back to Eddie Bravo apologetics but I
didn't finish my point back then and I
think it's an important point to
make he said to me something that was so
[__] weird when he said and this was
on top of him taking on a missionary
stance with my inhalation of tobacco
smoke so by then I was already like over
little defensive I was defensive and I I
didn't I I was like I was too dumb at
that time to like recognize like [__]
man this guy's got a [__] like he's a
jiujitsu master so what he's saying is
not coming from like a place of someone
who like hasn't like worked really hard
at a particular he's saying just don't
kill your body yeah but one thing he's
said to me which is I always think back
to it cuz I really remember when he said
I was like you sick of Fant and what he
said to me was exactly what's happening
to you right now what did he say he said
you have no idea what's going to happen
to him he's going to be like like he's
going to be so huge and I remember him
saying it this was this was Fear Factor
it was not like a safe assessment man it
was like when he said it to me it felt
culty it felt [__] up it felt like it
felt crazy right and it was I I remember
him saying it to me and like being like
man you're I didn't say it cuz I was
afraid of
him we I'm thinking like you're [__]
crazy that you would think that but he
you know it's weird that he's right you
know that's what's weird about it it's
like this is is your first episode on
Spotify and it's crazy man because like
I get and I'm honored deeply honored
that you invited me out well there was
no second choice do you know that thank
you brother you were First Choice 100%
across the board when they said who do
you want to have first on Spotify before
they said Spotify is a dunan trussle
that's so cool Joe I appreciate so cool
and I I really believe that what what I
said that I think you and I have
different shows there's something about
you and I together that is different
than just me by myself man we friends
we we're not just friends man like we've
known each other for so long and there's
no doubt we've tested each other back
and forth up and down and left and right
we know we love each other like you know
if if you call me up at 3: in the
morning Joe I need your help like I am
[__] there dude I'm a Commando I'm
ready to drop in from a helicopter I'm
going to save you yeah and because of
that like because of our long
relationship we've been we've been
friends for so long
dude I
mean how long when do we like '90s when
did you start working with the story
'90s dude we've been friends since the
'90s the '90s so more than 20 years yeah
we we've gone you have seen me go from
being the town court of The Comedy Store
to being someone supporting themselves
off of their comedy man like you you've
seen me go from like you you were
friends with me when I was
like uh when I was when I was like no no
one would have like ever gambled on
anything happening with me other than no
not no one just no one's stupid I saw it
right away when the moment I first saw
you do little
hobo yeah dude I saw you do little hobo
in the O and I'm like oh my God yeah man
but you keep doing that that to me like
that's the thing is like you keep doing
that like that's the reason that you uh
you deserve what you have you really do
like all the haters all the people who
are like I get the
haters it's like it doesn't work the the
the trick is it's like I get it if
you're not a like someone explained it
to me that like when you look at people
that doing really
well especially if they all socialize
with each other it becomes like a Walled
Garden and it feels like it's alienated
it feels like you're you're isolated
you're locked out and it makes you feel
bad it makes you feel shitty yeah and
that's the problem that's the problem
dude you hated me you just so you know
like when we first met no you didn't
hate me but you were irritated by me cuz
like you don't remember when you first
met was in the belly room I was with
Princess Corey Cory Como and like uh I
was trying to at the time I was really
into like it wasn't even called trolling
them but it was like saying a thing
opposite to what you should say and I
remember like something you were a
contrarian I was being a contrarian and
something came up about marijuana you
mentioned marijuana I'm sitting with
Cory com I'm always I was already
nervous around you cuz at the time you
were like you know you were you were
still like at that time you were still
like in this incredible trajectory and
like I made a stupid joke about how weed
was like bad you know I'd come from like
I was like you know there's never been a
time that I haven't been high for years
and you know what I mean especially then
but I made this dumb joke about how weed
was and I remember you looked at me with
such such like a scaving look of like
cuz you had just started like
understanding how wonderful marijuana
was and you really thought I meant we
was bad and I remember Corey gave me
this look of like no Duncan no don't
don't do the
joke it was a terrible moment because
you weren't you weren't in a place where
you could even like you weren't
tolerating that because you were were
getting high and starting to realize
that it wasn't probably what well I
think when I first started smoking pot I
became a zealot like real quick because
I realized i' had been lied to that's it
and I had misunderstood the the the idea
of what marijuana was I I became a
zealot that's what it was you were a
zealot in the look you gave me I
remember the way you looked at me I
realized like God damn he I bet he hates
me forever never but today in the same
situation I'd be like yeah right I funny
you were defensive yeah yeah I was a
zealot I was certainly a zealot once I
first experienced marijuana I I became a
zealot but you and I had such awesome
conversations we had most of our
conversations when we first became
friends on the phone I would call you up
I go yo dude I'm here uh Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday what's up what
are you doing man like dude I read this
Alice Huxley book and you start telling
me about some crazy [__] and you and I
would just go I mean it would be like a
a significant chunk of my day on like
Monday when I would call in is that you
and I would have these cool
conversations so you take me on the road
with you we go to the Irvine Improv
we're driving back from the Irvine
Improv in your car I'm so stoned you're
playing Terrence McKenna Terrence
McKenna is talking about the singularity
and he's talking about like uh this idea
that we're accelerating towards this
point in the future novelty yeah and I
I'll never forget that ride back from
the Irvine impr I'll never forget it
because like I'd never heard that
Terence McKinna speech I knew about
Terence McKinna roughly from like you
know I I had encountered him in my
earlier years as a psychona but like
something about that particular lecture
that you're playing something about
leaving something as weird as a comedy
show and this idea that he was saying
and this is the part that still sticks
with me to this day which is you know
look we are heading towards a
point of concurr currence of events that
is known as a singularity and that the
closer we get to it the more we're going
to experience these think tachon
particles being blown backwards through
time that will produce these events in
history that we call
novelty and something about that ride
back and just that moment me listening
to it I started think I it wasn't like I
even thought this isn't real I thought
that is real and so here we are now
2020 in the middle of a pandemic you've
become what has been described as the
Oprah for men broa broa and you are like
you are someone who like great leaders
and principalities are trying to get
into this podcast do you remember when
you live with me and I started buying
Buddha [__] started buying like you
already had the Buddha [__] but I
started buying all the I like bought a
Shiva I bought this giant bronze Shiva I
brought they're like and you go hey you
know why you're attracted to this right
yeah well that's what that's the thing
that weirds me out about you man that's
the part that where I'm like oh I get it
it's like well there was some
realization that happened and you're
picking up on that and so because you're
picking up on that you have ganes out
here and you have all these like Eastern
symbols but I just think they look cool
no no I don't that's what I think well
yeah you think you think they look cool
but also you happen to have this massive
audience
uh regardless of whatever that is I just
remember that uh that r i remember that
ride back and I remember like I remember
like thinking like you know I think
there's something real in here like I
think what McKenna is saying is probably
true you know I think this uh
pandemic I think this pandemic
represents something he predicted which
is we're in a novel wave right now this
is It's been it's been a century since
the last pandemic no no one here knows
how to deal with this and now we're in a
novelty wave and maybe well we got lazy
we we didn't take into account all of
the possible variables and a big one
with this Administration was uh
pandemics yeah man but not just that
it's like the problem is like where
you're kind of in a bit of a bind is
that all this human attention has been
placed upon you and you have to wrestle
with your identity because that's why I
need you to move to Austin you don't
need me an Austin my friend come help me
come on I can't do this to I'll help you
I'll be I'm always there for you man but
the problem is is like you have this
burden of attention and it's like it's a
it's a real like for whatever reason
like some like you've people have
decided you're you're one of the
magnifying glasses focusing this beam of
attention into the world and So within
that is all this room for disaster it's
like you know what I mean like
room for disaster is the perfect way to
put it yeah oh my God yeah someone pays
attention to every aspect of your life
there's so much room for disaster yeah
man but I think at a certain point in
time it's like there's a sacrificial
lamb a person who lays himself down on
the cross is that you no all of us it's
all of us but you know it's a it's a
really you are in a bit of a bind
because the pro it's like look man
here's what I love about not being
George Washington I didn't have to make
the decisions he made there I'm reading
this book Dune it's so beautiful like if
someone says Duncan I know you only have
14 teeth I don't have to make the
decision but I can sell you all the rest
of them for I don't have to I don't be
Shillings I don't to be Jesus I don't
two P I don't have to be church I don't
have to be any of these people man I
don't want to be them I would not assign
myself to that Incarnation but like in
Dune I'm reading this great book Dune by
Frank Herbert it's so good and in in
this desert world there's these beings
called The Fan they're like they they
they like have become they represent
complet complete Attunement with nature
and so at at this wonderful point in the
book this Imperial like
Galactic representative of this
imperialism
is like sitting in a like Canyon with
all his wounded men they're almost done
and the fman one of these tribal beings
is saying to them you have to make a
water decision and what they mean by
that is your wounded men you have to
pick one of them to die and we render
their body into water because in this
world there's no water so you have to
make a water decision and the the fan is
interacting with the being in this pure
way which is the only only way you can
act if you're truly in two of nature
you're innocent and and it isn't like
dark or anything he's like you have to
make a water decision right and the
being is saying to
him like hesitating and the fan is
saying to him do you want me to make the
water decision for you and they don't
mean it in an aggressive way they mean
like would you you love these people
would you give up the decision to us
wouldn't you be enough to make the
decision yourself fortunately in the
book one of them dies and they they're
able to like Ren their body into water
but what I'm saying is like these being
the position of power and all the whole
series of Dune is based on this problem
which is like if you get saddled with
any kind of power even if it's a even if
you want to pretend it's a kind of
clownish power you are still in a very
difficult situation because you have to
make a water decision like you will have
to like if you're Trump and you're a
clown president or if you're Obama
you're some Advanced president orone
lost and there's only 20 of you yeah man
someone's got to become water you have
to make a water decision if you're if
you're the president there 335 million
people everything you decide is a water
decision that's a little easier but if
you're on Lost yeah there's 13 people
left yeah man it's brutal it's brutal
and like no matter what trick you try to
use to deal with it no matter what trick
you Ed you're still forced into this
terrible it's a predicament man it's a
Chinese handcuff situation it's like
Chinese handcuffs are [__] it's not
a Chinese handcuff that's ever been
invented it's going to hold me down it's
a creepy Place Chinese handcuffs are
like this
yeah well yeah I know I know man but
it's ultimately it's like damn I always
feel bad it's like I never want you to
trend on Twitter whenever I see you
trending on Twitter it really sucks for
me cuz I'm like [__] is he okay that's
what I hate about Twitter is like people
will trend on Twitter you know what I'm
saying and it's like I do I get it I
hate it cuz I'm like [__] was it in a
car accident I think just stay off
Twitter yeah you're right I got to say
on Twitter I just don't think it's good
for you the problem is you're you're
interacting with people that don't
they're not communicating first of all
and foremost
maybe they're they're not communicating
with people that are right in front of
them so they don't feel social cues they
don't feel empathy they don't feel so
they're they're talking in this weird
way that's only existed for like [__]
10 years it's at dunan TR on Twitter
follow me Duncan trussle on Twitter no
you're right IE you two L's two s's two
L's no jiren laner you know like the
idea is like get the [__] off social
media I agree I don't think that's right
either is it weird for this I think I
think I think it's inevitable I think
it's too big too much of a part of
everything I think there's
no I don't think there's a future in
telling people to stay off it I think
there's more of a future of telling
people to understand what it is and
manage it to look at social media to
look at Twitter and and Instagram and
all those things and understand what
they are I don't think you have to get
off but you should you should spend a
lot of time outside of that I got to get
off there man it's not good to read
comments it's not good to um Google your
name I don't think that's good and
that's how when you see me and you see
I'm okay that's why cuz I don't do that
those things you get crazy should we cut
ourselves for Spotify should we like do
like a little Blood Brother ritual where
we cut our fingers and like mix our
blood that's how you get your [__]
covid test earlier let's do it we're
like Co we don't have we don't have Co
anymore should we like do a slice no
come on it's good Jesus why not Duncan
got all great all great rich rituals are
based in like some kind of blood Bond do
you think there's this honestly if you
didn't know me if I wasn't your friend
would you think there's a responsibility
that I have that I'm not meeting no I
think you're meeting it I think the
problem is like no matter how like it's
like the it's hilarious and in the in in
Star Trek you know Captain Kirk they if
you're going to be like someone who like
gets to be a commander of a Starship
you're given a problem that is
unsolvable so no matter what you do it's
you can't win no matter what like when
you get to a certain level of power any
decision you make on some level is wrong
and right simultaneously this is quantum
Computing my friend so I do not you know
in my analysis of your podcast and all
my deep judgmental qualities I do not
see what you're doing as being wrong at
all I see sometimes you make naive
decisions that I would make too what
would you say I think sometimes you have
people on who later found out to be like
at least in the moment they were on the
show a little like [__] up like for
sure in the early days I I had an issue
in the early days where I didn't want to
admit that I was getting as many views
as there was and uh I would do a show
and I'm just like no one's watching this
and I would have some crazy person on
and maybe uh there there was a few that
was like I shouldn't have talked to that
dude that dude was [__] up yeah but
that was uh learning process you know
that was there's there's a thing about
doing a
podcast where there's no school for it
right there's no way to figure out how
to do it perfectly it's not like
learning how to play piano it's real
linear there's all these weird ways to
do it and no one knows so
unfortunately I was like I guess like
second generation first generation is
for sure Adam Curry he's the poda and
then there's like uh Adam Corola there's
a few other people but I I came right
after that yeah 2009 so no one knew what
the [__] we were doing and I think there
was a there's certainly been some times
where I didn't want to admit that it was
reaching as many people as it was yeah
you can't think about that cuz it makes
you feel crazy well that's why I want to
have you on cuz I knew we were going to
get drunk and get high and the first
episode would be as Preposterous as an
episode can be yeah and then from this
you can like have people on who are like
real or whatever I mean look man anyone
ever I've ever talked to anytime I've
ever been in a situation where people
are talking [__] about you or or like
questioning my friendship with you
because I think because I'm because you
had this person or that person on if I'm
friends with you something's weird with
you or me or whatever I all I always and
will
forever stand up for you man because I
know you and I and I and and to me it's
like look what like you got into this
ridiculous predicament like you're in a
you're in a bind man you are you are in
a bind and it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful bind but it's a real it's a
real problem and but like because of
your heart which is very open and very
sweet you allow this like you allow
everyone to have you allow a lot of
people on your podcast that don't make
sense according to the zis and so people
get mad at you and they pound
and and I I always feel so rotten about
that because it's like man you don't
understand this is a real Progressive
like you're looking at someone who is
exactly the being that you would hope
would be the like result of like great
government and great education and
you're [__] attacking an ally that's
the part that gets me up that's where I
get really bummed is it's like man you
have to understand that person look you
should if you ask me
I feel like Duncan should I have Ben
Shapiro on I feel like no jo no there's
so many better people to have on in that
guy but that doesn't mean you can't have
those other people on too well if you
listen to me but I would say to you I go
listen man I know what you're saying but
if I just took you to dinner you me and
Ben chapiro went to some [__] kosher
joint i' love i' love hang out with him
we I I guarantee you you'd like him no I
know that he's a good guy the problem is
not him the problem is all the people's
reactions to him and him right those
there two things going on two things the
things that he said and the reactions
and the fact that he's kind of
weaponized their reactions yeah look
he's a good guy look I don't I to me
it's like I I would I would be so bored
if you only have people on the show that
I agreed with it would be such a shitty
show but I I do have a a rule where I I
won't
have anybody on anymore unless I feel
that they enter into those arguments
with good faith yeah man I know that and
I feel like Ben Shapiro he enters into
all discussions with good faith he's not
an insulting guy he he and I have had
interesting conversations about gay
marriage interesting conversations about
um uh all sorts of uh aspects of society
racial relations black lives matters and
and and and he and I talked about it in
a very respectful way even though we
disagree there's been no there's been no
insults there's been no shittiness and I
think that's the problem with putting a
guy like that on some sort of a standard
traditional talk show you have him on
and some social justice Warrior and they
argue with each other and you got a host
and you break every seven minutes to go
to commercial you don't find out what
he's about he's not a bad guy man and he
gets shaped as much by those seven
minute segments where you're battling it
out
to get soundes as you and I do byin
spots at The Comedy Store trying to pass
open mic night based on this podcast you
would imagine that I have a chip on my
shoulder about Ben Shapiro which I
really don't I don't think you do I
don't think you the reason I brought up
Eddie Bravo is only because like uh I
think like what you're doing is really
sweet and good and I think your heart is
in the same place it was and I met you a
while ago which is pretty bizarre like
they would somehow maintain a a thing
that's integral you know I've met you
know you meet people out here who go
through rough patches and they're not
who they portray themselves as initially
they're actually like con artists or
fuckups or like bad temporarily I think
people get better but sometimes they're
bad temporarily but you you really like
have like maintained this I think a
really beautiful kind of uh North Star
regarding your ethics and your
consideration and things so yeah man I
I'm like I'll do anything for you really
I'm one of your great devotees I'll kill
for you
Joe I'm one of your great devotees I I I
really am too man I I feel like like
legitimately honestly I I I I feel like
I've been tested where I've been given
an opportunity to help other people and
uh I feel like it's uh there's no
controversy in my mind my mind knows the
right choice yeah man and so I've always
tried to promote all these different
comics and I think that that's what we
should all do with each other I think I
don't think we need to make all the
money I think you need to make some
money I need to make some money what do
we need man we need barbecues and
[__] Margaritas I've
hugs I'm not a selfish person I've seen
a lot of people be selfish I've never
seen you be like this is the thing I
don't care but here's how I'm selfish
I'm selfish and that I'm not selfish cuz
I know that being selfish is negative to
you it's bad for you it's dangerous it's
sloppy it's weak it's some [__] [__]
so I never I'm never selfish because I'm
selfish because I don't want myself to
be a [__] you discovered a like thing I
figured it out when I was uh jealous I
figured it out when I was younger I
remember watching Comics who were better
than me when I was like 21 and I was
thinking like God [__] these guys how
did he come up with that joke and then I
and I I I don't remember when it
happened but it was early like 21 22 I
remember catching it and going oh I
caught a bad pattern like I got this
pattern where I'm jealous instead of
like or I could be the way I was before
I ever got into comedy which is inspired
instead I was jealous and so it it made
me realize like oh I've got a bad
pattern that I'm I'm chasing this bad
pattern do you remember that time Joe
that we drank a bowl of blood in front
of that m
statue it was chicken blood we were
dying anyway
whatever look I feel like it's like I'm
I I do is this the longest podcast ever
look it doesn't matter where we we're
done I got to pee again let's wrap it up
wrap it up but what are we at and hours
5 and a half hours it's over we did it
Kevin Smith was 5 hours we won Joe thank
God you think you should do this in two
podcast I think we should whatever you
want to do care right listen Spotify
don't get greedy we give you a 6- hour
opening podcast 5 and half hour thanks
my friends it gets better there's going
to be actual scientists on this show if
you keep listening uh I will talk Duncan
Trussell into doing regular podcast
either through Zoom Skype I have I I
have thoughts I have ideas I want to
help I would have this conversation if
we were recording that's the funny thing
I've I've only been I I feel like I've
been extending it yeah just cuz I want
to keep talking I know me too man we're
going to help all right how they Kush
that Jamie I'm sorry catch big
kiss we should have done the blood
ritual I would have cut myself we [__]
up